AFTERNOON DO WANT TO APOLOGIZE
TO THOSE WHO ARE WATCHING THOSE
WHO ARE IN THE ROOM INTO OUR
SIMPLY MEMBERS FOR GRATEFUL
THAT- EACH OF YOU ARE HERE. WE
APOLOGIZE ABOUT STARTING A BIT
LATE LITTLE BIT OF A CRAZY DAY
WITH COMMITTEES- HERE ON JULY
FIRST WHICH IS. CRAZY TO THINK
THAT IT IS JULY FIRST- THE
SENATE GOVERNMENT S. SENATE
CLEANING GOVERNS IN FINANCE
WILL BECOME AN ORDER LAYS IN
GERMAN THAT START WITH HER
FIRST BOOK OF BUSINESS IN THAT
DECEPTION A QUORUM MISTER NOW
GOOD AFTERNOON IF YOU COULD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
MCGUIRE HERE MCGUIRE PRESIDENT
SENATOR NIELSEN NIELSEN PRESENT
SENATOR ALSO THERE WERE ALSO
PRESENT SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SENATOR WIENER. WIENER PRESENT
YOU HAVE A CAR WITH A QUORUM
REQUIREMENTS BEEN ESTABLISHED
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN. I WOULD
LIKE TO BE TO TAKE CARE SOME
HOUSEKEEPING NUMBER GONNA CALL
FOR A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ON HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS
LAYS IN GERMAN EIGHTY FOURTEEN
SEVENTY SIX ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN. WAS PULLED
BY THE AUTHOR FROM TODAY'S
AGENDA THAT BILL WILL BE BACK
IN FRONT OF THIS COMMITTEE NEXT
WEEK. THAT LEAVES US WITH
FOURTEEN BILLS ON THIS
AFTERNOON'S AGENDA TWELVE WITH
EITHER AN AUTHOR OR A
REPRESENTATIVE PRESENTING HERE.
IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
IN TWO BILLS PROPOSED FOR
CONSENT. AS WE KNOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL WAS
GOING TO BE PRESENTING FOR SOME
MEMBER BERMAN. AND OUR GREAT
VICE CHAIR VICE CHAIR NIELSEN
WILL PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF MR
GALLAGHER. ALL RIGHT- ON IT TWO
DAYS CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE
TWO ITEMS ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
THREE FORTY. ITEM NUMBER FOUR
AB FOUR FOURTEEN IS THERE A
MOTION TO APPROVE TODAY'S
CONSENT CALENDAR. THE MOTION BY
DRAWS A THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
RESO. GOOD TO SEE YOU LET'S
CALL THE ROLL ON THE CONTENT
COUNTER TWO ITEMS PLEASE MISTER
PER NOW THE MOTION IS TO ADOPT
THE CONSENT CALENDAR SENATOR
MCGUIRE AYE MCGUIRE AYE AYES
SENATOR NIELSEN. NIELSEN ON A
SENATOR TORONTO. DORADO A
SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR
WIENER. WIENER HI I'M GONNA ASK
A SENATOR WINNER WHO'S BEEN
CARRYING HOUSING AS CENTER
WINNER YOU SURPRISE SAID OF THE
MAJORITY LEADER IS NOT HERE
TODAY. I AM DEFINITELY NOT
SURPRISED HI TO THERE WE GO
WE'RE GOING TO BE A GIVING HIM
THE RICARDO LARA AWARD HERE- IN
JUST A FEW MOMENTS OR I SHOULD
SAY MAYBE IN A COUPLE HOURS-
AND AS SOON AS HE ARRIVES- BUT-
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN- IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVER NINETEEN
EMERGENCY TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AS WELL AS
EMPLOYEES WHO MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN HERE
TO SOCIAL DISTANCING FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES HERE IN THE
CAPITAL. IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE IS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORA
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES HAVE
ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. LAYS IN GERMAN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO BE TO PARTICIPATE
IN TODAY'S HEARING VIA OUR LIVE
TELECONFERENCE LINE WE WELCOME
YOU. IMPACT ON ANY BILL WE
WELCOME TO CALL. 877-226-8189
OUR LIVE TELECONFERENCE LINE IS.
877-226-8189 AND THE CODE IS
TWO EIGHT SEVEN. SIX ZERO FIVE
NINE. WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THOSE WHO ARE
CALLING INTO OUR TELECONFERENCE
LINE WILL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
WE'RE GOING TO ASK A LITTLE BIT
OF A FAVOR IF YOU DON'T MIND
CAN YOU PLEASE MUTE YOUR DEVICE
WHEN YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING- PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY THAT JUST WILL LIMIT
THE FEEDBACK THAT WE HERE IN
COMMITTEE. N THE UNLIKELY
EVENT THAT INDIVIDUAL BECOMES
UNRULY BOTH ON A TELECONFERENCE
LINER HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE- ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE. HERE IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE ANYONE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTION MUTED ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU JEREMY TOOK CARE SOME
HOUSEKEEPING WE'RE GOING TO
WELCOME THE ONE THE ONLY.
ASSEMBLY REALLY TO- THE PODIUM
NUMBER GOING TO BE HEARING.
FROM THE GOOD ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FROM THE EAST BAY WERE INTO
SOUTH BAYAND THAT OF COURSE IS
A MEMBER COURT. I'M GONNA TAKE
A MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE THIS IS A
GOOD BILL. AND AT IT IT'S BEEN
AN ABSOLUTE PLEASURE TO WORK
WITH YOU SOME THE MEMBER THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COLLABORATIVE
NATURE- AND REALLY GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR FOCUS. ON THIS CRITICAL
ISSUE EVEN AS WE COME OUT OF
THIS EPIDEMIC. I DO WANT TO LET
YOU KNOW ASSEMBLY WERE YOU DO
HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. UP
FROM THE COMMITTEE SO WE
WELCOME A TRUNCATED VERSION OF
YOUR STATEMENT YOU DO A
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND WE
WELCOME YOU. PLEASE DO TAKE IT
AWAY SIR. A AT. THE LEGAL WE
NINE HAVE YOU PASS NUMBER IS A
NUMBER IS WORKING. GIVE US ONE
SECOND REMEMBER. RUBIO OKAYARE
YOU EVER THERE WE GO OUR AREA
WELL I REALLY ENJOY THE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT VERY
GRATEFUL FOR SO I WILL HAVE A
MORE BRIEF STATEMENT YEAH IT'S
GREAT PLEASURE TODAY TO PRESENT
TO YOU ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
THREE NINE WITH A PRESERVER
ABOUT PARTICIPATION FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS A POST PANDEMIC AS
WE'VE SEEN RIGHT NOW OR ONE OF
THE RARE EXAMPLES I COULD
PRESENT A BILL ABOUT SOMETHING
THAT IS HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
AND THROUGH THE MIRACLE OF
TECHNOLOGY WILL BE ABLE TO HEAR
FROM TO MY WITNESSES ZACKS FELT
IN GALWAY CITY COUNCIL MEMBER
AND INSIDE FOR THE FIRST
AMENDMENT COALITION I ALSO HAVE
JUST MENTIONED THAT HOW.
IMPORTANT THIS BILL AS I ONLY
RECENTLY FIGURED OUT THAT THE
BROWN ACT OF NINETEEN FIFTY
THREE WAS ALSO ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE THREE NINE THE SAME EXACT
BILL NUMBER SO I THINK IT'S A
GOOD SIGN OF THAT AND HOW WE
CAN MODERNIZE OUR PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION AND MAKE SURE
THAT MORE PEOPLE INCLUDING A
PROCESS RIGHT NOW IT ONLY
APPLIES TO CITY COUNCILS AND
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
WITH OVER TWO HUNDRED FIFTY.
THOUSAND POPULATION AND WE'RE
HOPING TO KEEP MOVING ON THIS
PROGRESS BECAUSE IT DOES HAVE A
SUNSET CLAUSE FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY THREE AND WE'LL KEEP
WORKING ON IT BUT THAT LIKE TO
TURN OVER TO MY- WITNESSES
DAVID SNYDER AND I KILLED HIM
IF THEY WANT TO COMMENT NO
THANK YOU SO MUCH SEVERELY IN
DEBT LOOK I THINK THAT AND WE'D
LOVE TO BE ABLE TO SEE THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT SAID DECEMBER
LEE. I TO BE ABLE TO LOOK AT
ALL GOVERNMENTS NO MATTER-
POPULATION TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THIS BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
REALLY CRITICAL ESPECIALLY FOR
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION I KNOW
THAT WE'RE GONNA NEED TO BE A
TO TAKE THAT ISSUE UP LATER AS
IT HAS A PREVIOUS AMENDMENT IN
A PREVIOUS COMMITTEE. BUT I
JUST WANNA SAY AGAIN IS AN
EMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR WORK I WOULD LIKE TO FIRST
TURN IT OVER TO THE GOOD
COUNCIL MEMBER FROM GILROY THAT
ZACH HILTON COUNCILMEMBER
HELPING YOU DO HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT N COMMITTEE HERE TODAY
WE WELCOME YOUR STATEMENT WE
ASK THAT ITS TRUNCATED SINCE
YOU DO HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
MR. HELTON THE FLOOR IS YOURS
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. PLEASE
PROCEED. HELLO COMMITTEE CHAIR
STOPPING ABOUT EYE AND JACK
BUILT RESIDUE OF GO OR INTO
YOUR COMP MEMBER HE GOT THE TO
AND DOES COME BY THE BROWN
ACTIVE LEARN TO MEETINGS
REMOTELY BUT MANY WILL RESORT
BACK TO THEIR OLD WAYS THAT IS
WHY WE NEED CREATIVE SOLUTIONS
LIKE AB THREE THREE NINETY
CONTINUE PUSHES OFF BOARD AB
THREE THREE NINE WILL ENSURE
CALIFORNIANS HAVE THE ABILITY
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT DECISION MAKING
PROCESS BY EXPANDING
OPPORTUNITIES TO JOIN PUBLIC
MEETINGS. THEY MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT VIA TELEPHONE INTERNET
BASED SERVICE OPTIONS SO DURING
AND BEYOND THAT WE NINETEENTH
ENDEMIC MEDIAN PASSER BY TO
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO
CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THE STATE
TO BETTER PARTICIPATION LOCAL
GOVERNMENT MEETING SO IN
NINETEEN A CLOSER WE CAN PRINT
OUT MEDIAN VIRTUALLY AND I
WATCHED MY OWN CITY COUNCIL.
STRUGGLE TO FIND A WAY TO ADOPT.
AND OF WHERE WE ARE IN THE- OF
OUR BASED PARTICIPATION BIG
ACROSS. OUR CITY HALL. WE
FINALLY HAD PROBLEM REGARDING
MY OUT. FOR EVERY POSITION WE
HAD IN OUR COMMISSIONS AND
COMMITTEE. WE CAN'T CRAWL BCK
INTO THE DARK IN A WAY FOR
BEING TRANSPARENT TO THE
PUBLIC. BY RETURNING BACK TO
THE VERY PRESENT EXISTED BEFORE
WE ARE DOING THE PEOPLE'S
BUSINESS AND I MEAN. THAT MEANS
WE NEED TO DO IT ON THEIR TIME
WHETHER COMMUTING HOME COOKING
DINNER FOR FAMILY PUTTING HIM
DOWN OF THAT STUDY FOR YOUR MID
TERMS WORKING. OR ENJOYING OUR
BACK CALIFORNIA RECREATION
OPPORTUNITIES. SECURITY COUNCIL
ON APRIL NINETEENTH APPROVED
THE CONTRACT YOU UPGRADE OUR
AUDIO VISUAL EQUIPMENT. IN THE
COUNCIL CHAMBERS I AM PROUD TO.
WITH THE STEPS WE HAVE TAKEN TO
INCLUDE A HYBRID MODEL. THAT
ALLOWS ALL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO PARTICIPATE. ALTHOUGH
GO RATED IT MANDATED FOLLOW THE
BILL EVEN A SMALL STUDIO FIFTY
SEVEN THOUSAND HAD THE
COMMITMENT ABOUT THE NEED TO
FOLLOW THE PROVISIONS. I DON'T
SEE WHY LARGER CITY COUNCIL.
AND BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
MEETING CAN'T DO THE SAME AB
THREE THREE NINE WOULD
ESTABLISH STANDARDS PROPOSED IN
BOTH. AGENDAS IN DIRECTION. I
JOIN THE MEETING VIA
TELECONFERENCE CONFERENCE
TECHNOLOGY IN A TIMELY MANNER.
AND I EASILY ACCESSIBLE
LOCATION ONLINE. LAST WEEK VERY
CLEAR STANDARDS THAT ENSURE THE
EQUITABLE PROVISION OF ACCESS.
TO PUBLIC MEETINGS ARE
NECESSARY TO ENSURE A
GOVERNMENT THAT IS ACCOUNTABLE
TO HIS CONSTITUENTS. OUR
DEMOCRACY CANNOT FUNCTION- LET.
EVERYONE IS ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
EQUALLY THANK YOU ANY
CONCLUSION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR IBM. CUSTOMER THANK YOU SO
MUCH YOUR LEADERSHIP GREAT TO
HEAR ABOUT GILROY AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS HERE
TODAY OUR FINAL. MAIN WITNESS
IN SUPPORT IS GONNA BE MISTER
SNYDER FROM THE FIRST AND THEN
MAKE A COALITION. MISTER SNYDER
WE MAY ACTUALLY HAVE GINNI THE
ROW- INSTEAD OF MISTER SNYDER
BUT LET'S CHECK INTO ENGINEER
DAVID. ON THE LINE FROM THE
PERSON IN THE COALITION. I HERE
DAVID HEY MISTER SNYDER THANK
YOU SO MUCH YOU UP TO TWO. TO
FOR YOURS PLEASE PROCEED
WALKING TO COMMITTEE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN WE CAN
I'M DAY SNYDER AND I'M THE-
DIRECTOR OF THE FIRST AMENDMENT
CALL. WE AT THE- FOR FREE. OPEN
AND ACCOUNTABLE GOVERNMENT AND
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION IN CIVIC
AFFAIRS WE HELP JOURNALISTS
ACTIVISTS ACADEMICS. AND MANY
OTHERS ACT THAT THEIR
GOVERNMENT WE DO SO BY
PROVIDING EDUCATION. ONE ON ONE
LEGAL COUNSLING LITIGATION AND
MORE ARE ON THE DURING AND
WITHOUT IN DISTRICT TWO. AND
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
THREE THREE NINE. WE BELIEVE
THAT THE HELP OF ANY DEMOCRACY
DEPENDS ON THE ABILITY OF THE
PEOPLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THAT
DEMOCRACY TO OBSERVE. AND
INTERACT SELECTED AND APPOINTED
OFFICIALS. THEY HAVE THEIR
VOICES HEARD. AT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT LEVEL THIS MEANS
BEING ABLE TO SEE AND HEAR. AND
IMPORTANTLY TO SPEAK AT PUBLIC
MEETINGS IN REAL TIME. BEING
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC
MEETINGS YOU MEAN HAVING TO
ARRANGE CHILDCARE. OR TAKE TIME
OFF WORK. GETTING A RIDER
PAYING FOR TRANSIT TRAVELING
LONGER DISTANCES WITHIN RURAL
COMMUNITIES ARE WORSE. BEING
ABLE THOSE. UNABLE TO
PARTICIPATE DUE TO HEALTH
CONCERNS OR DISABILITIES. THAT
THE BURDEN SO HIGH THAT IT MADE
MEANINGFUL PARTICIPATION OUT OF
REACH. FOR MANY. AND IT LEFT
GOVERNMENT THREE TO MAKE
DECISIONS WITHOUT INPUT FROM
THE COMMUNITY. THERE'S ONE
SILVER LINING FROM THE PANDEMIC
THAT ACT THAT THE GOVERNMENT
DECISION MAKING. BECAME
AVAILABLE TO A BROADER RANGE OF
PEOPLE THAN IT WAS BEFORE.
EIGHTY THREE THREE NINE WOULD
ENSURE THESE. GAMES ARE NOT
LOST. AB ONE BOARD SUPERVISORS
MEETING IN. OF POPULAR OVER.
ABOUT IT WOULD REQUIRE THEM TO
PROVIDE CONSTITUENTS WILL
EITHER A AND- INTERNET BASED
OPTIONS FOR PARTICIPATION. FOR
THE PAST YEAR AND A HALF
AGENCIES DEMONSTRATED THAT THEY
CAN PROVIDE. BACK THAT. LOCAL
DEMOCRACY IN CALIFORNIA DEPENDS
ON TRANSPARENCY FOR ITS HELP.
WITH LIABILITY THE BILITY SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF OUR STATE. THE
FIRST AMENDMENT COALITION URGES
THE COMMITTEE TO ENSURE THAT
LEVEL OF ACCESS. IS MAINTAINED
AS PROVIDED FOR IN EIGHTY THREE
THREE NINE BEYOND TE PANDA.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THIS IS NOT A GOOD TO HEAR FROM
YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE'RE
GOING TO NOW IT CHECK IN TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE OUT HERE IN
AT THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE WHO'D
LIKE TO GO TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. HEARING SEE NO ONE
RISE WE'RE NOT GONNA GO TO ROOM.
TWENTY FORTY TO BE TO SEE IF WE
HAVE ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. THERE IS LOVE IN ROOM
TWENTY WERE NOT GOING TO GO TO
OUR LIVE TELECONFERENCE LINE.
TO BE ABLE TO QUEUE UP ALL
INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD LIKE TO
BE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE THREE NINE NOW MISSED. IF
YOU CAN MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE
UP ALL IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
THREE NINE NOW. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB
THREE THREE NINE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME. EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR WILL
GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER OFFLINE
AND THEN PLACE IT BACK IN THE
QUEUE. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
YOU UP OR AB THREE THREE NINE
AND WILL BEGIN TODAY WITH- LINE
ONE HUNDRED TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD ONE TWELVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
KEY WHEN DEALING WITH THE ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION. PROUD CO
SPONSOR IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
THREE NINE. I WILL ALSO BE
READING A CONSOLIDATED LIST OF
ADDITIONAL ORGANIZATIONS IN
SUPPORT. SENIOR IN DISABILITY
ACTION. NEXTGEN POLICY. HOUSING
IS A HUMAN RIGHT ORANGE COUNTY.
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION. CALIFORNIANS
AWARE. INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA
STATE STRONG. TOGETHER WE WILL
INDIVISIBLE LOS GATOS. HOPE
PUBLIC ATTITUDES. EACH DAY FOR
EVERYONE AND CENTER FOR RACE
POVERTY AND THE ENVIRONMENT.
THANK YOU HEY THANK YOU SO MUCH
ANYTIME YOU GOT TAXPAYERS IN
INDIVISIBLE ON THE SAME PAGE
THAT'S PRETTY IMPRESSIVE SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH. FOR THAT
VERY. GRATEFUL LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
NICOLE BORNEMANN ON BEHALF OF
THE CHILDREN PARTNERSHIP IN
COURT THANK YOU NICOLE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. MISTER MODERATOR
GOING TO OUR NEXT LINE PLEASE.
ABSOLUTELY LIME ONE OH FOUR YOU
ARE OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
RICHARD MEMBER DEREK HURTS WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANKS ERIC NEXT
LINE PLEASE. ONE FORTY FIVE YOU
ARE OPEN. AFTERNOON HER NUMBER
OF VOLUME BUTTON BURKE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIAN D. IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER. ONE ONE
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE THIRTY FOUR YOU ARE
INDEBTED YOU. REQUIRE EXCELLENT
I MEAN COMMITTEES THIS IS
ANDREA HAD STRUM. I DON'T
REMEMBER FROM THE TUBBS FIRE
WE'RE GOING TO ASK IN A
POSITION ON THE BILL THANK YOU
SO MUCH ANDREA THANK YOU FOR
CALLING IN LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. ONE FORTY SIX YOU ARE
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS RON RAPP SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU RON NEXT
CAR. ONE FORTY FOR YOUR UP.
THANK THE GOOD LORD FOR
COMMUNITY ACTION- SPEAKING ON
BEHALF ADDITIONALLY- SANTA CRUZ
DE IN THE SOUTH SIDE FORWARD IN
INSULIN FOR EVERYONE PLEASE
STAY IN THE STREETS FOR PEOPLE
SAN FRANCISCO IN THE SOUTH BAY
AND THE PEOPLE ARE HOUSING
ORANGE COUNTY AND URBAN
ENVIRONMENTALISTS. VERY HAPPY
TO BE ABLE TO CALL IN WITH OUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH YOUR
CALL GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU I NINETY FIVE
YOU ARE OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
ERIN ACCOUNTS WITHIN OAKLAND
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
IT'S GREAT THANKS AND- NEXT
TIME PLEASE. THANK YOU I LOVE
FINAL REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR A BI THREE THREE
NINE AND WE WILL GO TO LINE ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY. GOOD AFTERNOON
SURE MEMBERS JORDAN CRIMES ON
BEHALF OF THE PENINSULA YOUNG
DEMOCRATS IN EIGHTY TWENTY TWO
AND TWENTY FOUR IN STRONG
SUPPORTER. THANKS SO MUCH THANK
YOU SO MUCH NEXT CALL PLEASE.
MISTER KERR WE HAVE EXHAUSTED
THE QUEUE ALL RIGHT. NO THERE
ARE FOLKS WHO ARE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR MURRAY
WILL BE BACK WITH YOU IN JUST A
MOMENT WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO
THOSE WHO MAY BE IN OPPOSITION.
BUT WE HAVE ONE LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS WHO IS IN THE QUEUE
TODAY THAT'S JEFF NEAL FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES MISTER NEAL WE WELCOME
YOU IN OPPOSITION OR ONE LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS. OF AB THREE
THREE NINE THE FLOOR IS YOURS
YOU HAVE TO MINISTER. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AS YOU SAID JEFF BEAL
WITH CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES. ALSO
SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF OF MY
COLLEAGUES AT THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES- BECAUSE OUR
COLLECTIVE EXPERIENCE OF THE
PAST YEAR AND A HALF AS- HAS
CHANGED THE CONVERSATION.
AROUND THE BROWN ACT IN A
NUMBER OF THOUGHT PROVOKING
WAYS. AS THE SUPPORTERS NOTED
WE FOUND OUT THAT. IN MANY
CASES AND UNDER CERTAIN SETS OF
RULES REMOTE MEETINGS WORK-
UNFORTUNATELY EIGHTY THREE
THREE NINE. IT DOESN'T
IMPLEMENT THE RULES THAT PUBLIC
AGENCIES HAVE BEEN WORKING
UNDER INDEPENDENT JUST ONE.
SPECIFIC. REQUIREMENT OF IT.
WE'RE CONCERNED THAT RETAINING
THE WAY PROBE. PURCHASE BUT NOT
THE PIECES BE EXECUTIVE ORDERS
THAT HAVE ALLOWED MORE
FLEXIBILITY IN MANAGING PUBLIC
COMMENT WE'LL SEE MORE. LOCAL
AGENCY MEETINGS OF THE
DEFECTIVE ONES ANYWAY TOO OFTEN
DISTRACTED BY THINGS THAT WE
HAVE BEEN ACTING OVER THE PAST
YEAR. EXAMPLES BEING- HUNDREDS
OF CALLERS CALLING IN FROM OUT
OF STATE ON HOT BUTTON ISSUES
SUCH AS PUBLIC REQUIREMENTS. OR
ANOTHER EXAMPLE FROM JUST LAST
WEEK AT THE MEETING THE HEAD
SEVEN HUNDRED CALLERS ON THE
SINGLEISSUE. UNDER THE
EXECUTIVE ORDERS LOCAL AGENCIES
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO MANAGE
DISRUPTIONS AND MANAGE
OVERWHELMING NUMBERS OF
PARTICIPANTS FIVE. FOR EXAMPLE
LIMITING THE TOTAL TIME FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT IN A WAY THAT
YOU SHOULD BE FAMILIAR TO
EVERYONE SITTING ON THIS
COMMITTEE. IT'S A SOLUTION THAT.
HONORS THAT DIVERSITY OF VOICES.
WHY ASO ALLOW GETS TO A- BE
NAY ON THE MATTER SUPPORT
IMPORTANCE- BUT FLEXIBILITY
AREN'T IN THIS BILL. I WILL SAY
WE'VE HAD EXTREMELY PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
AND I WHEN I THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEE AND HIS STAFF. FOR
THOSE CONVERSATIONS OVER THE
PAST TWO WEEKS AND- WE JUST HAD
MORE TIME TO WORK TOGETHER I
FEEL HOPEFUL THAT WE BE ABLE TO
COME TO AN AGREEMENT ON HOW TO.
OPEN THE BROWN ACT OF THE
MODERN ERA. OF COURSE ONE WILL
THAT CHANGE YOUR INDEPENDENT
BECAUSE THAT ADDITION TO THE
PUBLIC ELECTED AND APPOINTED
OFFICIALS WERE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY WITHOUT
PUBLISHING THEIR ADDRESS ARE
OPENING THEIR HOMES TO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC. WHICH SHOULD TO
WORK OKAY. I SUSPECT WAS ONE.
REASON WHY GILROY WAS FINALLY
ABLE TO FILL ALL THE SPOTS ON
THE BOARDS AND COMMISSION
BECAUSE- THOSE APPOINTED
OFFICIALS COULD PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY. I'M MORE TIME WOULD
ALSO ALLOW US TO STUDY. WHAT
DIFFERENT PUBLIC AGENCIES DID
OVER THE PERIOD A LOCKDOWN WHAT
WORKED WHAT DIDN'T SIMILAR TO
THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
REPORT. WAS JUST RELEASED A FEW
DAYS AGO- HOPEFUL TO WORK ON
THIS ISSUE WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEE AND YOU MISTER CHAIR IN THE
NEAR FUTURE BUT IN ITS CURRENT
FORM WE MUST WORK QUICKLY
OPPOSED. THREE THREE THREE
NINE. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
PARTICIPATING AT TODAY VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT AT WE ARE NOW
GOING TO BE AT CHECKING IN TO
SEE IF THERE'S AN ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE SOMEONE ELSE. WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE TO SPEAK. IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE WELCOME. NICE
TO SEE A- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS I'M JEAN HURST
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA-
WE ECHO THE COMMENTS OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES. THANKS SO
MUCH SO IT'S GOOD TO SEE HER
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE. ALL RIGHT ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION WOULD LIKE TO RISE
AT THIS TIME HERE IN THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE. SIGNON RISE ARE NOT
GONNA GO CHECK OUR OVERFLOW
ROOM. THE GUY THAT CRICKETS
WE'RE NOT GONNA GO TO A
TELECONFERENCE LINE WE'RE GONNA
CHECK IN WITH MR MODERATOR MR
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
QUEUE UP ALL INDIVIDUALS WHO
MAY BE IN OPPOSITION OF AB
THREE THREE NINE NOW. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR TO AYE CHAU
OPPOSITION FOR AB THREE THREE
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. WE'LL BEGIN WITH WINE
ONE HUNDRED FORTY THE SCHOOL AT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS F THE COMMITTEE PAUL
GUNS ALL THIS ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF TORRANCE AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU SO MUCH
POP THANKS CALLER PLEASE. ONE
FORTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON HEARING MEMBERS
MATTHEW CYBERLINK COMING OUT OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CLERKS AND ELECTION OFFICIALS
ECHOING THE COMMENTS THAT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THE CURRENT EXCELLENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THE
FINAL REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. OFFICIAL OPPOSITION. FOR
EIGHTY THREE NINE. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE ONE TWENTY TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBERS
PERSONAL HEROES ON BEHALF OF
THE PUBLIC RISK INNOVATION
SOLUTIONS AND MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM AND ON THE IN BEHALF OF
CITY OF BEVERLY HILLS AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE CAN
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ONE MOMENT MR CHERRY JUST HAD A
COUPLE Q. UP. WITH AN OPERATOR.
AS OUR MODERATE MODERATOR
DENISE ALL RIGHT AS A MATTER GO
RIGHT AHEAD. OKAY IN FOR
ANYBODY ELSE GOING AT ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME AND WE WILL GO. TO
ONE OH NINE. BUT AFTER THEIR
TECHNIQUE DOWN ON BEHALF OF THE
TOWN OF APPLE VALLEY IN RESPECT
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH ASK OUR PLEASE. WHAT
FIFTY FOUR YOU ARE OPEN. THAT
AFTERNOON MR KAREN MEMBERS
THANK FORGET ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITIES RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THINGS WERE JUST. LET'S
CHECK IN WITH OUR NEXT CALLER.
THERE'S NOBODY ELSE QUEUED UP
AT THIS TIME MISTER CARE RAMOS
MATTER WE'LL TALK TO YOU IN
JUST A FEW MOMENTS THIS RING
BACK TO COMMITTEE TO HAVE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR SOMEONE
LIKE TO BRING FOR THE MOTION WE
HAVE QUESTIONS BY SIR WIENER
PLEASE. OUR SYSTEM REMOVE THE
BILL- ANTICYCLONES FIRST OF
ALL- AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL- I
DO AGREE WITH- WITH C. SACK
THAT WE'RE LONG PAST TO TAKE A
BROADER LOOK AT THE BROWN ACT
AND HOW IT CAN BE MODERNIZED ON
HAVING SPENT A NUMBER OF YEARS-
ON THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SAN FRANCISCO SUBJECT THE
PRODUCT ARE MANY GOOD THINGS IN
THE BROWN ACT BUT BUT IT WAS
DEFINITELY WRITTEN. IN A
DIFFERENT ERA AND I THINK OUR-
REPRESENTATIVES HE SACKED-
REYES SOME EXAMPLES OF WAYS
WHERE THE PRODUCT IS JUST WAY
OUT OF DATE AND WE MAKE A VERY
VERY HARD AT TIMES FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS REALLY OPERATE
EFFECTIVELY IN A COMMON SENSE
WAY- AND THAT'S AGAIN THE
THOUGHT HE KNEW HERE THERE FOR
THIS PARTICULAR BILL BUT I
THINK IT'S A VERY VALID POINT-
TO RAISE. I WILL SAY- IN TERMS
OF WHAT WE'VE SEEN WITH PUBLIC
COMMENT- AND THE CONCERN I
THINK HE MENTIONED THAT THERE
WAS A TIME WHEN SEVEN HUNDRED
PEOPLE CALL THEN YOUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT UNLIKE. THE
LEGISLATURE DOES HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PUT. THE LIMITS
ALTHOUGH I THINK THERE SOME.
VALVES SITUATIONS WHERE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CAN DO THAT BUT THEY
SHOULD HAVE SOME MORE
FLEXIBILITY OF. APPARENTLY
ENTIRE PROCESS IS BEING
COMPLETELY OVERWHELMED- WHEN I
WAS ON THE VERGE SUPERVISORS WE
HAD SOME WE HAD NO TELEPHONIC
COURSE WE HAD THERE WERE
HEARINGS OR WE HAD EIGHT HOURS
OF PUBLIC COMMENT WHERE PEOPLE
JUST. CAME DOWN THE OLD FASHION
WAY AND IT TOOK SIX SEVEN EIGHT
HOURS OR EVEN MORE- SO EVEN
WITH LIVE TESTIMONY YOU CAN
REALLY HAVE AN OVERWHELMING
AMOUNT OF. A PUBLIC TESTIMONY
AND I WILL ALSO SAY THAT I WHEN
WE WENT TO TELEPHONIC TESTIMONY
HERE NUMBER THING OH BOY STATE
OF FORTY MILLION PEOPLE PLUS
PEOPLE FROM ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY- YOU KNOW WE'RE GONNA
HAVE LIKE INTERNET. CALL IN
TESTIMONY IN WHAT IS THAT GOING
TO BE LIKE. AND I AS A
COMMITTEE MEMBER AND ALSO AS A
CHAIR. THERE'S ONLY BEEN A FEW
TIMES HEN WE REALLY HAVE A
LIMIT- THE TIME OR THE TIMING-
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN PRETTY RARE
THAT WE TIED. YOU KNOW A REALLY
OVERWHELMING NUMBER OF PEOPLE
SO I THINK THE- ESPECIALLY THIS
IS- JUST FOR US TO BE SO
EXTENDING THIS FOR A COUPLE OF
YEARS- YOU KNOW AS WE'RE COMING
OUT OF THE PANDEMIC AND PEOPLE
USED TO IT AND- YOU KNOW I. I
THINK IT MAKES A LOT OF SENSE
AND THEN WE CAN REEVALUATE. AND
AGAIN I HOPE WE WILL TAKE A
BROADER LOOK BUT I'M NOT GOING
TO MOVE THE BALL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. MISTER SENATOR VERY
GRATEFUL BUT I COULD DO A FINAL
CALL FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE WHICH MOTION ON
THE FLOOR PERSON WIENER MOTION
FOR BY SIR WIENER. ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS COMMENTS
HERE AND SEE NINE SOME RELIEF
THE PLEASURE TO WORK WITH THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
COLLABORATION. GREAT BELL- AND
WE'LL LET YOU CLOSE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE SENT TO THE CHAIR FOR
A DUE DILIGENCE AND- ATTENTION
TO THIS BILL. I DO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THE OPPOSITION ITS EXACT
AS A VERY VALID POINT I THINK
THERE IS A WAY THAT CAN
MODERNIZE THE BROWN ACT PAUL.
HAVING MORE PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION WILL OFFICIAL
SITE I THINK THEY'RE VALID
POINTS THAT IS MY COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND ALL.
REPRESENTATIVES OF LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES TO BE WORKING ON
THE EXTENT. BUT YOU KNOW AS WE
DID SEE IT RIGHT NOW IS
OVERLYING EVAN THAT MAKE IS
THAT WE CAN USE TECHNOLOGY TO
OPEN THE DOORS OF DEMOCRACY
EVEN IF IT MIGHT NOT BE
LITERALLY DOING SO. AND HAVING
THAT PARTICIPATION I THINK IT'S
ALWAYS A GOOD THING BECAUSE- I
AM SURE WE OFTEN HEARD HOW WE
LACK PARTICIPATION LONG TIMES
BUT NOW WE KIND OF SEPARATE
THEM OPPOSITE PROBLEM. SO IF WE
CAN ENCOURAGE MORE FRUSTRATION
FOR TAWDRY IT'S ALWAYS GOOD AND
YOU HAVE MY- AND IT'LL PROMISE
I'LL BE BACK FOR THIS COMMITTEE
WORKING ON A SIMILAR ISSUE
AGAIN VERY VERY SOON SO. THANK
YOU AND- SO FASTER I'VE OF THE
NUMBER THANK YOU SO MUCH MOTION
IS ON THE FLOOR BY. SENATOR
WIENER MR CANAL IF YOU CAN
PLEASE. CALL THE MOTION IN CALL
VOTE. THE MOTION IS. PASS AS
AMENDED. BUT THE MAN. AND REFER
TO THE CAN. ON JUDICIARY.
SENATE MCGUIRE HI. MCGUIRE AYE
SENATOR NIELSEN. NIELSEN A
SENATOR DORADO DORADO- A
SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR
WIENER AYE WIENER HI. FOUR ZERO
VOTE LAYS HIM FOR YOUR VOTE
WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT THEY'LL
OPEN A LOT OF THE MAJORITY
LEADER TO BE ABLE TO ADD ON WE
ARE NOW MOVING ON WE'RE GOING
TO WELCOME THE GREAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS IN THE RECORD TO BE A
TO TALK ABOUT ALL ISSUES OF THE
ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA TRANSIT
DISTRICT IN THIS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OUT GREAT NEWS WE HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THE FLOOR
HERE TODAY WE'RE GONNA AT
REQUEST RESPECTFULLY OF COURSE-
IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND- ADVANCING
A TRUNCATED VERSION OF YOUR
STATEMENT THE FLOOR IS YOURS
SIR AND WELCOME BACK IT'S GOOD
TO SEE YOU OKAY- I ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
TO REMOVE DISTRICT. FORMATION
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD BE RENDERED
UNUSABLE BY THE BILL- THIS IS A
GREAT BILL- TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT BUT PROBABLY JUST GOING
TO BE THERE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
OR BEVERLY GREENS AND JILL
SPROCKETS SO I HOPE THAT UP
HERE THIS IS JUST THERE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AS A MEMBER AND I JUST
MIGHT TAKE A MOMENT AND TO
THANK THE SIM NUMBER AS ALWAYS
TO FOR BEING COLLABORATIVE WILL
SEE ANOTHER BILL. THAT NEXT
WEEK FROM THE SIMMERING IN
REALLY GRATEFUL FOR- I'M BOTH
IN THE CELL VERY GRATEFUL SIR
ALL RIGHT. SO WE HAVE- BEVERLY
GREEN FROM AC TRANSIT WHICH- MS
GREEN YOU DO HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT HERE IN COMMITTEE. SO
WE'RE GONNA ASK FOR A TRUNCATED
VERSION- OF YOUR STATEMENT MISS
GREENE THE FLOOR IS YOURS
HEARING COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
JERRY MCGUIRE AND CAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
ON BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA CONTRA
COSTA TRANSI DISTRICT COURT.
TRANSIT UPDATED AFTER IT
EXPIRED DURING EIGHTY SEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR TO UPDATE AND
MODERNIZE PROVISIONS OF OUR
AUTHORIZING STATUTE. MANY OF
THESE CODE SECTIONS HAVE NOT
BEEN UPDATED TO KEEP PACE WITH
TECHNOLOGY AND THE GROWTH OF
THE DISTRICT AND THEY WERE
ENACTED. IN NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE
AMONG THE LONG OVERDUE CHANGES
THAT AB SEVENTY FOUR MAKE DID
TO REPEAL THE CONFUSING
FORMATION LANGUAGES STEP UP
SIMPLY DESIGNATE AC TRANSIT. AT
THE RAPID TRANSIT DISTRICT-
UPDATE PROVISIONS SPECIFY
SIGNATURE. FOR NOMINATION
PAPERS AND ALLOW PAPERS TO BE
SUBMITTED WITH THE FILING FEE
IN LIEU OF SIGNATURES. AB
SEVENTY FOUR WOULD ALLOW THE
DISTRICT TO USE DIGITAL
SIGNATURES AND MAKES NUMEROUS
OTHER TECHNICAL CHANGES THAT
ARE LONG OVERDUE. ON BEHALF OF
MAKING TRANSIT I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AB SEVENTY FOUR
WITH ME TODAY IS JOKES FRANK AC
TRANSIT'S GENERAL COUNSEL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH ON THE
SCREEN AND I THINK IF YOU'RE
OKAY WITH THIS THROUGH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I WE'RE GONNA
JUST GO STRAIGHT TO OUR IN
PERSON COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS
JUST BECAUSE WE HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT ON. THE COMMITTEE HERE
SO LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE'RE
NOT GONNA OPEN IT UP TO ANYONE
IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
WHO'D LIKE TO RISE TO BE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY
FOUR PLEASE DO SO NOW. THANK
RISER GONNA BE LOOKING ROOM
TWENTY FORTY TO SEE IF ANYONE'S
GOING TO BE STANDING IN SUPPORT.
XENON WE'RE NOT GONNA GO TOWARD
TELE CONFERENCE LINE. THAT
WE'RE GONNA HAVE THE THAT
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP ALL
INDIVIDUALS TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. OF AB SEVEN EIGHT FOUR
NOW. THANK YOU FOR YOUR IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY FOUR YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE NINE ZERO HERE IN SUPPORT
OF AB. SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR. YOU
MAY NOW HAVE MATTER MODERATOR
META MODERATOR MR MODERATOR IS
NO LONGER THERE SO I APOLOGIZE
META MODERATORS COULD HEAR
VOICE. NO WORRIES MISTER CHAIR
AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN QUEUE AT
THE MOMENT ALL RIGHT DAYS
GERMAN WE'RE GONNA BRING IT
BACK HERE TO THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE TO BE TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE WE DON'T HAVE A LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS ON RECORD
HERE TODAY WOULD LIKE TO BE TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE THAT TO
RISE. IN TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
CURRENCY KNOWN WE'RE NOT GONNA
GO TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. NO ONE IS RISING
IN THAT ROOM WE'RE NOT GOING TO
GO TO A TELECONFERENCE LINE.
NOT A MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO MAY
WANT TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB SEVEN EIGHT FOUR. NOW THANK
YOU FOR NOT A- LOT OF AB SEVEN
EIGHT FOR YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT
THE END ZERO. ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOR IN OPPOSITION OF AB SEVENTY
FOUR. AND WE HAVE NOT BEEN
LISTENING TO YOU AT THE TIME MR
LOOK AT THAT WE'RE BRINGING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE TO SEE IF WE
HAVE A MOTION A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR. WE'VE MOTION BY VICE
YOU'RE NIELSEN THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER VICE CHAIR. WE'RE
GOING TURN OVER TO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR CLOSE. AS WE ARE
BOTH THE GOOD ACTORS SO THE
RECORD IS A FISHING HE'S IN
HE'S OUT I LIKE IT THANK YOU SO
MUCH AS A MEMBER FOR AT YOUR
PATIENTS AS WELL. FOR US TO GET
INTO THE BILL. SO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY VICE
CHAIR NIELSEN MR CANAL CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE MOTION. AND
THEN CALL THE VOTE. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND WE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR MCGUIRE HI. MCGUIRE A
SENATOR NIELSEN. NIELSEN IS
SENATOR DORADO. DORADO HIS
SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR
WIENER. THREE ZERO THREE ZERO
VOTE LAYS IN GERMAN WE'RE GONNA
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE GET THOSE OTHER
VOTES ON THANK YOU SO MUCH
SINGLE CHAIRED SENATORS WE'LL
SEE NEXT WEEK. ALL RIGHT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN. HE LOVES
IT. ALL ISSUES OF DEVELOPMENT
PEACE AND HIS NAME IS A MEMBER
GRAYSON I SAY THAT A LITTLE
FLIP. BUT IN ALL SERIOUSNESS. I
JUST WANNA TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. THIS IS THE GENTLEMAN
WHO IS. LOOKING FOR INPUT THEM
THAT MONITORING YOU SINCE WE'RE
GETTING FEEDBACK I JUST SO WE
DON'T HEARING COMMITTEE PLEASE.
WHILE THEY'RE NOT IN. THIS ONE
AS A THANK YOU TO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR HIS COMMITMENT ON
THIS ISSUE. WORKING WITH ALL
SIDES AND THIS CAN BE
CANDIDATES AND NEVER. EVEN
WORKING YOUR BACKSIDE OFF ON
THIS ISSUE. IT IS BEEN
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT. AND OUT
WE JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TRANSPARENCY YOUR
COLLABORATION WITH MYSELF AS
ALONG WITH. A GERMAN ASSEMBLY
WOMAN- AGUIAR-CURRY. THAT FROM
THE SIMPLY LOCAL GOV COMMITTEE
VERY GRATEFUL SIR. I'LL TURN IT
OVER TO YOU AND I DO WANT TO
LET YOU KNOW SIR. YOU HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL. SO WE ASK THAT
YOU PROVIDE A TRUNCATED VERSION
OF YOUR STATEMENT. PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR AND I DO WANT TO
ALSO THANK YOU. DAN COMMITTEE
STAFF AS WELL AS- MY COLLEAGUE
ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE AND HER
STAFF AS WELL. FOR THE GREAT
WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE IT IS
TRUE I HAVE BEEN INVOLVED. AT A
LEAD TO TIME AND- PUTTING
TOGETHER A WORKING GROUP. THAT
I OF ALL STAKEHOLDERS. AND WE
HAVE COME UP WITH WHAT I
BELIEVE IS A REALLY GOOD- PIECE
OF LEGISLATION THAT WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD. I WOULD LIKE TOTHANK
EVERYONE WHO DID PARTICIPATE IN
THE WORKING GROUP. OF FOR ALL
THEIR WORK AND SO NOW. AB SIX
ZERO TWO. ESTABLISHES
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
STANDARDS FOR THE NEXUS
STUDIES. THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
PREPARE. WHEN IMPOSING A
DEVELOPMENT IMPACT FEES THESE.
INCLUDE REQUIREMENTS. THAT
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS CITY THEIR
EXISTING LEVELS OF SERVICE
PROVIDED CAPITAL FACILITIES
PLAN. FOR PROPOSED. VINTAGES
AND COMPLY WITH PUBLIC NOTICE.
AND OPEN MEETINGS REQUIREMENTS.
SO IT TIES FEES MORE CLOSELY TO
ACTUAL IMPACTS. TAKEN TOGETHER
THESE COMMON SAFE. SINCE
REFORMS WILL PROVIDE
CONSISTENCY CLARITY. AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. I DO HAVE.
WITNESSES THAT CAN SELF
IDENTIFY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
ASSEMBLY. WERE REALLY GREAT I'M
UNDERSTAND IS THAT WE LUIS MORE
DAY ON FROM CAL. BE TO SIGN I
DO NOT BELIEVE IT IS CURRENTLY
ON BUT THAT'S GO TO. LEWIS
FIRST IN CALIFORNIA. OKAY THERE
WE GO HOW YOU DOING ALL RIGHT
YOU ARE NOW ON LET'S GO TO.
LET'S GO TO LEWIS IN TO SIGN
LEWIS- WE HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN COMMITTEE NOW SO
WE'RE GONNA ASK FOR. A
TRUNCATED VERSION OF THE
STATEMENT PLEASE PROCEED. GREAT
ARM AND I BELIEVE LOWEST
RANKING IS DIALING IN RIGHT NOW
SO I WILL- JOHN VAN THIS IS
DOESN'T MATTER NOT. HAVE PUBLIC
AFFAIRS- HERE TODAY
REPRESENTING HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRED MEMBERS- ARE
PROBLEMS SPONSORING THIS
MEASURE AND GRATEFUL TO THE
FAMILY MEMBERS ARE ALL THE WORK
THAT YOU PUT INTO THAT- AND WE
ALL KNOW CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CRISIS. ALL ACROSS HOW THE
BACTRIM FROM HOMELESSNESS TO
HOMEOWNERSHIP. WE'RE THINKING
INCREASING COST COST PRESSURES
APPROVED DRIVES PROVIDE CASE
MANAGEMENT HOUSING YOUR
RESIDENT. AND ONE OF THE FEW
AFFORDABLE HOME OWNERSHIP
HOUSING DEVELOPERS IN
CALIFORNIA. ADEQUATELY HUMANITY
IS INCREASINGLY IMPACTED BY OUR
STATE HIGH HOUSING COSTS.
ESPECIALLY THE COST OF
CONSTRUCTION BECAUSE IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THAT OUR HOME DO NOT
EXCEED 30% OF OUR- INCOME. AND
YOU NEED THEM TO STAY THAT WAY
IN ORDER TO REMAIN AFFORDABLE.
NEED HABITAT COVER THE GAP
FUNDING AND SHOULDER EVER
INCREASING COST BURDENS LIKE
IMPACT YOU. AB SUSPENSION
PROVIDES TRANSPARENCY AND
CLARITY AS TO WHAT. YOU ARE
DIRECTLY CONNECTED YOU. BY
CREATING CLEAR GUIDELINES AND
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR NEXUS
STUDIES ENSURING THAT- THE
PROPORTIONAL TO THE SQUARE
FOOTAGE THE UNIT. IN COURAGE OF
THE BALLPARK DEVELOP SMALLER
MORE ACTUALLY AFFORDABLE HOMES.
ACCEPTABLE TO MORE BUYERS AND
THEREBY. CALIFORNIA AND-
ACCEPTABLE. TO MORE BUYERS- BUT-
IN CALIFORNIA WHICH CURRENTLY
AN EXTRA. SLOW RATE OF
HOMEOWNERSHIP THE BILLION ACTS
FIRST THAT INCLUDING MORE.
ENTRY HOUSING. UNITS FOR COULD
CREE OP FOR. WEALTH AND FOR
TRADITIONALLY OUT OF THE ESTATE
MARKET. THANK YOU THE ASSEMBLY
MY- AND MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE-
PRETTY AVERAGE TO TESTIFY TO
THEIR- YOUR TIME RESPECT
REQUEST AND I ABOUT THANK YOU
SO MUCH I'M REALLY GRATEFUL
THAT YOU TESTIFIED TODAY I
APPRECIATE THAT WE'RE NOT GOING
TO GO TO MISSOURI DAY FROM
CALIFORNIAN B. YOU HAVE UP TO
TWO MINUTES BUT YOU DO HAVE.
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN COMMITTEE.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
BIRTH. DATE WITH CALIFORNIA BE
I JUST OUT OF RESPECT FOR THE-
TIME. I WAS VERY BRIEF I THINK
THE COMING OVER GREAT THEN AND
MY COLLEAGUE. AT HABITAT
COVERED THE ISSUE VERY WELL I
CALIFORNIA'S PARTICULARLY
EXCITEDABOUT THIS BILL BECAUSE
OF THE FIRST SQUARE FOOT
CHANGE- THE BILL WOULD MAKE.
IMPACT THESE ARE ARE
CALCULATED. THE TRANSPARENCY
PORTION OF THIS BILL AS WELL IS
CRITICAL. IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. AT THE AFFECTING
BEADS CLIPPING BUT MATTER. AND
THE CAPITAL OF THE CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENT PLAN IS PROBABLY
THE PREMIER PLACE OF BIRTH BE
DETERMINING. WHAT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ITSELF HAVE I SAID
MATTER. OF THAT THAT
TRANSPARENCY IF INSURANCE BUT
WE'RE JUST NOT. APPLYING THE-
WILLING ELIANA BABCOCK BAIT
THAT- IT IS IT'S CRITICAL AFTER
MAKING SURE THAT CALIFORNIA IS
AN AFFORDABLE PLACE FOR
EVERYONE. THANKS FOR YOUR TIME
TONIGHT YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISS MARTY GRATEFUL-
THAT MISSOURI DAY WITH
CALIFORNIAN BE LEADS IN GENERAL
ARE NOT GOING TO BE SEEN IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL HERE IN THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE IF YOU COULD PLEASE
RISE. SEEN ON RISE ARE NOT
GONNA GO TO LONELY IS FROM THE
CAPITAL THAT'S ROOM TWENTY
FORTY- WOULD YOU THINK- CENTER
DRUGS OR WHAT'S GOING ON TWENTY
FORTY. NAY THAT'S OUR I'M
SAYING ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA GO
TOWARD TELE. LAW OF WORK AND
CHECK WITH- MET MODERATE IF WE-
PLEASE QUEUE UP THE INTO THE-
IN SOME. OF AB SIX OH TWO NOW.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
AB SIX OH TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AND THAT THE ONE
THAT DIDN'T THEIR APPEARANCE
PARTS OF AB SIX OH TWO- NOT
FOLKS AND WE WILL GO TO LINE A
ONE FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
RESEARCHER AND MEMBERS ALEX
TOWARDS ON BEHALF OF THE
HOUSING ACTION COALITION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
TORRANCE VERY GRATEFUL LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO LINE ONE
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS YOUR THIS IS BOB MILLER
FOR FIELD SAID COMPANY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER NAYLOR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU BETTER COME
FROM MINE ONE FIFTY FIVE YOUR
LINES OPEN. THE SHERIN MEMBERS
MY NAME IS TRACY MELANCHOLIC I
REPRESENT SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
EMD OR AT THE DMV AND ABUNDANT
HOUSING LA IN SUPPORT THANK YO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU KNOW COME
FROM MINE ONE FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE DOCUMENTARY
CARE AND NUMBERS WHAT ABOUT THE
BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA PLANNING AND
URBAN RESEARCH ASSOCIATION ON
IT FOR THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE PHONE CALL. LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT LINE. THANK YOU COME FROM
NINE ONE OH EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI ALLISON SCHALLER
CALLING FROM LOS ANGELES
HOLLYWOOD FORWARD AND STORIES
FROM THE FRONT LINE CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH LET'S GO AND CHECK
IN WITH OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU MR JERRY ONE MOMENT-
WE DO HAVE ONE MORE IN CUBA
WHICH IS SET TO GIVE THEM THEIR
LINE NUMBER AND AGAIN WE ARE ON
AB. SIX OH TWO IN SUPPORT. MY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE
AND THEN THEY'RE OFFERING
SUPPORT OF AB. SIX OH TWO. AND
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF ONE OF
SIXTY FIVE ONE SIXTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I THEIR EYES BACK
PULLING AS BEING ON MY- OWN
BEHALF AND THEN- IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE HONG KONG. LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT LINE. THANK YOU
WE HAVE ONE MORE IN Q. THAT
JUST QUEUED UP ONE MOMENT FOR
THAT NEXT LINE AND AGAIN WE ARE
ON AB SIX OH TWO AND SUPPORT.
IN MY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND ONE MOMENT MISTER CHAIR
WERE GIVEN THEIR LINE NUMBER
SURE THING. AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE IS SIXTY SEVEN. LINE
ONE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. KELLY FELL INTO THE DAIRY
COUNCIL CALLING AT THE PORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU KELLY. NOT
A MODERATOR MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT LOOK AT
THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH READING
MODERATOR WILL BE RIGHT BACK
WITH YOU WE'RE GONNA SEE DOES
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION HERE ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE EIGHTY
SIX OF TWO IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO PLEASE RISE THE
MOMENT. C. KNOWN RIGHTS ARE NOT
GOING TO GO LOOK AT ROOM TWENTY
FORTY NO ONE IS AROUND TWENTY
FORTY BETTER MODERATOR BACK
WITH YES SO QUICK- WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE YOU THAT PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD
LIKE TO GO TO SPEAK. IN
OPPOSITION TO AB SIX ZERO TWO
NOW. THANK YOU FOR IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SIX OH TWO YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE AND THEN ZERO IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THE COLLECTIVE.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE OF ONE
SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE SIX FOUR HEARING ONE
MEMBERS AND- IS FOR C. THANK
YOU TERM NUMBERS ANTHONY KENNEL
WITH- CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR AND STAFF AND
BOTH HOUSES FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS MEASURE- WE STILL HAVE
SOME MINOR CONCERNS THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO BE ADDRESSED AND
WILL ARE WE WORK WITH THE
DOCTORS STAKEHOLDERS ON THEM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MISS TEN HELP GRATEFUL LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU HAVE A COMPLETE LINE
OF ONE TO TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN CHOIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THAT
HAVE CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES WE UNFORTUNATELY HAVE
AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL HAVE
APPRECIATED ALL THE HARD WORK
BY THE AUTHOR AND FRANKLY I'M
OUR WILLINGNESS TO NEGOTIATE-
TO GET TO THIS POINT BUT DO YOU
HAVE TO REMAINING ISSUES
RELATED TO DHCP TEMPLATE. AND
THE CAPITAL IMPROVEMENT
PLANNING REQUIREMENTS HOPE TO
RESOLVE THOSE AND BE ABLE TO
BECOME NEUTRAL ON THE BILL
THANKS CHRIS. LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
AND WE DO HAVE ONE MORE IN Q.
AND AGAIN WE ARE ON OPPOSITION
OF AB IS SIX OH TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AND WE
WILL GO THROUGH IT LINE OF ONE.
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS JASON RILEY CALIFORNIA
CITIES. THAT WE SHARE THE SAME
CONCERNS AS OUR COLLEAGUES OVER
THE STACKS WE ARE BOTH THE MOST
OF IT THANK YOU FOR YOUR MIND.
I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT RYAN THANK
YOU SO MUCH APPRECIATE IT.
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE MODERATOR ALRIGHT WE'RE
GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO BE A TO SEE IF W
HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
MOTION ON THE FLOOR FROM
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY CENTER
DORADO- MISTER GRAYSON I JUST
QUICKLY ON THE ISSUE OF
AMENDMENTS PLEASE. YES I- BUT I
DO WANT TO NOTE THAT I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
OUTLINED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. YOU'RE THE GM THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS AMEMBER DO YOU
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS BEFORE THE CELL
NUMBER. CLOSES MISTER CINNAMON
CLOSING STATEMENT PLEASE THANK
YOU FOR CONSIDERATION
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A- THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COLLABORATION IN
TRULY. SOME NUMBER. THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOUR AMAZING WORK I
KNOW IT'S BEEN. A BEAR IN
ANOTHER STILL WORK TO DO SO
VERY GRATEFUL SIR. THANK YOU
YOUR PLEASURE TO WORK WITH.
THAT MR NOW CAN YOU PLEASE.
CALL THE MOTION AND THEN CALL
THE VOTE. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND
WE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING. SENATOR MCGUIRE HI
MCGUIRE- A SENATOR NIELSEN. ALL
RIGHT NIELSEN AYE SENATOR ALSO.
TWO THOUSAND BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR WIENER.
THREE ZERO THREE ZERO LAYS IN
GERMAN KEEP THAT ROLE OPEN AND
HONEST REASONABLE I'LL GET BACK
TO YOU AS SOON AS WE HAVE WE
CULTURAL THANK YOU SO MUCH GUYS
USER. ALL RIGHT WELL AS IS
CUSTOMARY- WELL AS WE'RE
WAITING FOR ENOUGH THAT LOOK AT
THAT. MAYES IS IN THE HOUSE WE
HAVE A DOUBLE HEADER. BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN. GIVE US ONE
MOMENT WE'RE GOING TO PULL UP
THOSE TWO BILLS. WELL ALL RIGHT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN I WOULD
LIKE TO CALL OUR ATTENTION TO
ITEM NUMBER FIVE WHICH IS AB
FOUR TO EIGHT ITEM NUMBER FIVE
EIGHTY FOUR TO EIGHT WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR FROM MR MAYES ON
ITEM NUMBER FIVE EIGHTY FOUR TO
EIGHT FIRST THEN WE'RE GONNA
TURN IT OVER TO MR MAYES ON AB
FIVE SEVENTY ONE THAT'S ON FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIX HERE TODAY ALL
RIGHT IT'S AMAZING SENATOR IF I
COULD- ASK YOUR INDULGENCE I
WALKED OVER HERE WITH JUST ONE
OF THEM AND IF MY STAFF IS
LISTENING TO BE GREAT IF YOU
COULD BRING ME. AT THE FOUR
TWENTY EIGHT BECAUSE I'VE ONLY
GOT FIVE SEVENTY FIVE SEVENTY
ONE IN FRONT OF ME NO WORRIES-
INSURGENTS ARE CALLING YOUR
OFFICE RIGHT NOW THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR FOR TWENTY EIGHT
IN FRONT OF YOU CRAP FIVE
SEVENTY ONE ITEM ALL RIGHT HE
WILL TAKE IT SO LET AND
GENTLEMAN BUT WE'RE KEEPING IT
INTERESTING HERE TODAY- MISTER
MAYES THANKS AGAIN FOR YOUR
WORK I WILL TURN THE FLOOR OVER
BY THE WAY MR MAYS YOU HAVE.
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THE BILL
THEY WERE GOING TO ASK FOR A
TRUNCATED VERSION OF YOUR
STATEMENT THE FLOOR S YOURS
AND WELCOME TO COMMITTEE WELL
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE I FEEL
LIKE I HAVE TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT LONGER BECAUSE IT TAKES A
LITTLE BIT FOR MYSELF TO GET
HERE FOR THE OTHER ONE- BUT TO
GET DOWN HERE HOWEVER- I
CHAPLAIN RIGHT NOW HE'S IN THE
TAP DANCE FLOOR FOR EXACTLY
WHAT WITH THAT- I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE ON AB FIVE
A SEVENTY ONE HE'S GOING TO
GIVE US A CALL AT THIRTY SECOND
VERSION PLEASE OF THE THIRTY
SECOND VERSION IS- IMPACTING
DEVELOPMENT OF IT AND DIVERT
DEVELOPER FEES FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNDER JESSE BONUS LAWS.
CAN SIGNIFICANTLY AFFECT THE
OVERALL COST OF THE PROJECT AND
ARE OFTEN PASSED ALONG TO
BUYERS THE FORM OF HIGHER HOME
PRICES ARE PREVENT PROJECTS
FROM GOING FORWARD THAT IS WHY
THIS LEGISLATION SIMPLY
PROHIBITS IMPOSING CERTAIN FEES
FOR DEED RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE
UNITS- WITH THAT IF YOU WANT TO
HEAR FROM JENNIFER SPEC I'D BE
A SHE CAN SURE CAN ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT'S GREAT THANK
YOU SO MUCH A VERY GRATEFUL AS
A MEMBER MAYES AND LOOK AT
THAT- STAFF IS HERE ABOUT THE
COLLAPSE SO AS THEY WERE
RUNNING DOWN FIVE FLIGHTS OF
STAIRS SILVA- VERY GRATEFUL ALL
RIGHT SO WE HAVE JENNIFER ON
THE LINE JENNIFER WE WELCOME
YOU TO COMMITTEE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION. OF
REALTORS JENNIFER WE DO EVITE
PARTISANSHIP. FROM COMMITTEES
TO WE'RE GONNA ASK. FOR A
TRUNCATED VERSION OF YOUR STAY
MISS FACT AT THE- IS YOURS
WELCOME. MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE JENNIFER SPOKE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS
PROBLEMS OF EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY
ONE HAPPY ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
JENNIFER YOU ARE WONDERFUL
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL THAT IS OUR ONE AND
ONLY LEAD TO. SUPPORT WITNESS
WE'RE NOT GOING TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM
HERE ROOM THIRTY ONE ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BE EVER STAND ON
EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY ONE IN
SUPPORT. SEE NO ONE STAND WE'RE
NOW GOING TO GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY AND THERE IS ABSOLUTELY
NO ONE ROOM TWENTY FORTY LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN WE'RE NOT GOING
TO GO TO OUR TELECONFERENCE
LINE CHECKING WITH MADAME
MODERATOR META ROB MODERATOR
THAT SECU UP ANY INDVIDUAL WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BE A TO SPEAK. IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE SEVENTY ONE
NOW. THANK YOU FOR YOUR IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE. SEVENTY ONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
ONE AND THEN THOROUGHFARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE SEVENTY ONE.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE ONE
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN-
THIS IS BOB MILLER AGAIN AGAIN
IN SUPPORT OF. THIS BILL ON
BEHALF OF FIELD SAID THAT THANK
YOU SEE NAYLOR IS ALL OVER
TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH BOB
VERY GRATEFUL LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OSBORNE QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT MADAM MODERATOR GONNA BE
BACK WITH YOU IN JUST A MOMENT
DO MORE NOW TO BE GOING TO
OPPOSITION OF AB. FIVE SEVENTY
ONE. THAT WE DO NOT HAVE A LEAD
SUPPORT WITNESS ON RECORDS ARE
NEVER GONNA ASK IF ANYONE IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
WOULD NOW LIKE TO BE ON THE
STAND IN OPPOSITION. SEE NO ONE
STAND WERE NOT GONNA GO TO ROOM
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEN KNOWN
STAND THERE WE'RE NOT GONNA GO
BACK TO OUR TELECONFERENCE
LINE. CHECKING WITH MADAME
MODERATOR META MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE QUEUE UP INDIVIDUALS
IN OPPOSITION TO AB FIVE
SEVENTY ONE NOW. THANK YOU IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FIVE SEVENTY
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOR IN OPPOSITION OF AB FIVE
SEVENTY ONE. MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE NO ONE IN OPPOSITION AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH
THAT A MODERATOR WE'RE GONNA
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE TO
BE ABLE TO SEE THIS QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONVERSATION OR A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR WE'RE
LOOKING FOR A MOTION. QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. MMHM ALL RIGHT WE
GOT A MOTION BY DRAWS- THAT IS
CENTER DRAWS A THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THESE MISTER MAYES IF
YOU'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO CLOSE
I'M VERY GRATEFUL FOR- YOU'RE
WORKING THROUGH ALL THESE BILLS
MISTER CHAIR- AND IT WOULD
RESPECT THE REQUEST AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU I CENTER MAYES ONE
BEST TO WORK WITH SO WE'RE
REALLY GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE
HERE AND- THAT WE GOT EIGHTY
FOUR TWENTY EIGHT COMING UP
NEXT. MISTER GRINNELL WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY CENTER
DRIVE SO. CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE MOTION AND CALL THE VOTE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR MCGUIRE
AYE. MCGUIRE AYE SENATOR
NIELSEN. NIELSEN A SENATOR
DORADO. DORADO YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR WIENER.
THREE TWO ZERO ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER NOW WE'RE
GONNA KEEP THE ROLE OPEN ON
THAT BILL WE'RE NOT GONNA JUMP
BACK ONE ITEM NUMBER FIVE ALONG
WITH THIS AND THEY WERE MADE
THIS IS AB FOUR TWENTY EIGHT
FOCUSING ON BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS TERM LIMITS AS
WELL- SO WE'RE GONNA TURN THE
FLOOR OVER SIR ON AB FOR TWENTY
EIGHT HOURS YEAH THANK YOU SO
MUCH SO TERM REQUIRING MEMBERS
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY BEFORE YOU TODAY ON AB
FOUR TWENTY EIGHT AND- I WANT
TO THANK YOUR STAFF YOU AND
YOUR STAFF FOR. ALL OF YOUR
WORK ON THIS ITEM OF THE LAST
COUPLE OF WEEKS AB FOUR TWENTY
EIGHT IS RATHER SIMPLE AND IT
STRIKES AT THE CORE OF OUR
DEMOCRATIC INSTITUTIONS WE MUST
ENSURE THAT OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE STRUCTURED IN A
WAY THAT LEADS TO THE BEST
ELECTED REPRESENTATION POSSIBLE
AT THIS BILL GUARANTEES
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR COUNTY
SUPERVISORS BY ALLOWING THEM TO
STAND FOR REELECTION AND GAIN
EXPERTISE ON THE JOB THROUGH A
MINIMUM OF TWO ELECTED TERMS IN
OFFICE WILL ALSO CONTINUE TO
ALLOW THEM ADEQUATE
COMPENSATION IS LAID ON THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION SO.
THAT WE'VE GOT QUALIFIED
CANDIDATES FROM ALL WALKS OF
LIFE THAT ARE NOT JUST
INDEPENDENTLY WEALTHY. AB FOUR
TWENTY EIGHT DOES NOT CONTAIN A
RETROACTIVE CLAUSE. AND WILL
NOT DIRECTLY OVERTURN ANY LOCAL
MEASURE HOWEVER A RECENT LOCAL
MEASURE. HIGHLIGHTED A
DEFICIENCY IN STATE LAW THAT WE
MUST ADDRESS RESULTING IN THIS
BILL. BEFORE YOU TODAY- I AM
JOINED I THINK WITH A COUPLE OF
FOLKS- IS JEAN HURST AVAILABLE.
YEP NOT SO WE HAVE NOT MISS
HEARST AIMS TO BRING IN HERE IN
COMMITTEE ROOM SO WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE YOU DO IF IT'S
ALRIGHT. MISTER ZIMMERMAN WE'RE
GONNA HAVE YET TAKES HEAT
MOMENTARILY AND THEN WE'RE
GONNA AT FIRST INVITE. JEAN
HURST- REPRESENTING RC RC IN
URBAN COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THEN WE'RE GONNA AT
WELCOMES YOU BRING INTO THE
FLOOR- REPRESENTING S. C. I. U.
S. FIRST WELCOME BACK THANKS SO
MUCH MISTER CHAIR AGAIN JEAN
HURST HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA.
I IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAYES IS AB FOUR AT TWENTY
EIGHT. ARE WE ARE COLLECTIVELY
IN STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS
CHANGE IN STATUTE TO ENSURE AN
APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF COMMITMENT
TO THE OFFICE OF OUNTY
SUPERVISOR. A LEVEL OF
EXPERTISE AND ACCOUNTABILITY TO
THE OFFICE. AND THE CONTINUITY
OF GOVERNMENT THEY CALIFORNIANS
CAN BE CONFIDENT IN. MY COUNTY
SUPERVISORS IN CALIFORNIA AND
LIKE IN MOST PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY. ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR A
WIDE ARRAY OF FEDERAL STATE AND
LOCAL SERVICES. THIS IS BECOME
MOST EVIDENT OVER THE LAST YEAR
IS COUNTY SERVED AS THE FRONT
LINE RESPONSE TO THE PANDEMIC.
AND CERTAINLY UNDERSCORES THE
NEED. FOR TIME FOR SUPERVISORS
TO GAIN ACCESS EXPERTISE AND
EXPERIENCE IN MANAGING A
COMPLEX A COMPLEX THAT. OF
SERVICE OBLIGATIONS OF
FINANCIAL RESPONSIBILITIES. A
SINGLE TERM SIMPLY DOES NOT
ALLOW FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
SUCH EXPERTISE. AND AS A RESULT
OUR MEMBERS ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
WHAT A SINGLE TERM LIMIT WOULD
MEAN. FOR COUNTY POLICYMAKING.
AND SERVICE PROVISION AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. IF YOU KNOW COUNTY
SUPER. TAKE THEIR RESPONSE
SERIOUSLY AND ALL WITH NON THAT
REQUIRED TO DEVELOP EXPERTISE
AND UNDERSTANDING OF THE WIDE
ARRAY OF DUTIES OF THE ROLE. AS
A RESULT WE RESPECTFULLY URGE
HER AYE VOTE ON EIGHTY FOUR
TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISS HERS WERE VERY GRATEFUL
NOW GOING TO WORK ON THEM IS
WRITTEN TO YOU AT THE PODIUM
HERE REPRESENT S. YEAH YOU YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES SIR IT'S
ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE AT THE FLOOR
IS YOURS- CHAIRMAN WARREN
SENATORS TERRY BRENNAN ON
BEHALF OF THIS YEAR YOU
CALIFORNIA- AS YOU. WELL AWARE
IF YOU'RE YOU'VE BEEN ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE- DEBATE ABOUT TERM
LIMITS THAT WE- MOSTLY OPPOSE
THEM AT THE STATE LEVEL. OFTEN
SUPPORTED THEM AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL- IN EACH INSTANCE TRYING
TO STRIKE THE BALANCE BETWEEN.
EXPERTISE AND BRINGING NEW
BLOOD AND NEW IDEAS TO.
GOVERNMENT BUT IN NONE OF THOSE
INSTEAD IS HIS HAVE WE SUPPORT
A SINGLE TERM LIMIT. THAT SEEMS
TO TILT THE BALANCE AWAY FROM.
KAPATID EX EXPERTISE SAID AT
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT LEVEL- FOR
THAT REASON WE'RE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL- I WOULD ALSO SAY
THIS. ARGUMENT THAT THEY'RE
SOMEHOW SOMETHING IN THIS BILL
THAT OVERTURNS WHAT HAPPENED AT
SAMPOERNA DINO I THINK THE
ANALYSIS VERY. ADROITLY POINTS
OUT THAT- BE LOCAL CHARTER FILL
PROCEED TO EVERYTHING THE ONLY
WAY TO CHANGE WHAT HAPPENS
CENTER SAMPOERNA DINO WOULD BE
A SUBSEQUENT VOTE OF THE PEOPLE
AND THAT CHARTER CHANGE OR- A
SUCCESSFUL LEGAL CHALLENGE AND
NONE OF THAT IS INCLUDED IN
THIS BILL. FOR THAT REASON WE
ARE TRANSPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
BRANDON ALL RIGHT TO LAZING
GENTLEMEN YOU HAVE HEARD FROM
MISS HEARST EVERDEEN RC RC IN
URBAN COUNTIES YOU HEARD FROM
MR BRENNAN REPRESENTING S. C.
I. U. WE ARE NOW GOING TO GO TO
OUR TO LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. WHO ARE ON THE LINE
THAT WE'RE GONNA FIRST START
WITH TOM MURPHY HE'S WITH THE
RED BURNING GROUP MISTER MURPHY
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES WE WELCOME
YOU TO COMMITTEE IN OPPOSITION
OF AB. FOUR TO EIGHT MISTER
MURPHY. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANKS FOR
PROVIDING THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK. BUT ONE SIMPLE QUESTION
THAT MUST BE ANSWERED TODAY. IS
AB FOUR TWENTY EIGHT GOOD
GOVERNANCE. THE SIMPLE ANSWER
IS NO. FOR TWO REASONS FIRST IT
MEAN FOR TWENTY YEARS PLACES
RESTRICTIONS ON THE KOREAN FULL
EXERCISE OF THE PEOPLE'S RIGHT
TO INITIATIVE. EARLY VOTERS A
THREE TO SET TERM LIMITS THAT
THEY DEEM APPROPRIATE. APPROVAL
OF EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY EIGHT
WILL LIMIT THAT FREEDOM WITH NO
REASONABLE JUSTIFICATION. BASIC
JUSTIFICATION FOR THIS
RESTRICTION OF RIGHTS THAT IT
TAKES A VERY VERY VERY LONG
TIME TO LEARN AND BECOME
EFFECTIVE IN THE JOB. EVEN A
RESERVE ACCURATE AND WE
CERTAINLY DON'T CONCEDE THAT
POINT. THIS IS STILL
INSUFFICIENT JUSTIFICATION THE
BOYS A RESTRICTION OF A
CITIZEN'S RIGHT TO INITIATIVE.
IN REALITY IS POLITICAL INTENT
OF THE BILLS TO TORPEDO SAMBAR
DINO CARRIES MAJOR K. BUT
SHOPPERS BEEN FIRED BY THE
COUNTY'S POLITICAL ONLY THAT
THEIR OWN CONSTITUENTS. THEY
PROPOSED TO INCLUDE YOUR. WHAT
IT ACTUALLY DOES AND SELF
INTEREST LEGISLATION ON BEHALF
OF POLITICAL CRONIES. FOR
TWENTY EIGHT THE LINE TO
SUPPORT SOME BIRD THE CLERK
SAYS WILL THE SUPERMAJORITY
VOTERS AND A SINGLE COUNT. DO
SO BY IMPOSING UNNECESSARY
RESTRICTIONS HOWEVER I CAN
CITIZENS FIFTY SEVEN OTHER
TOWNS KNOWN THROUGH THE ONLY
APPROPRIATE AND PROPER VOTE ON
THE SCHOOL BOARD TWENTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TO REPEAT
THAT WE APPRECIATE YOUR VOICE
IN OPPOSITION WE'RE NOT GOING
TO GO TO SCOTT KAUFMAN SCOTT
COMPANIES REPRESENT HOWARD
JARVIS TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION
ALL RIGHT SIR YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES WE WELCOME YOU TO
COMMITTEE THIS WILL BE OUR
THIRD AND FINAL LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS WITH EQUAL TIME BETWEEN
OPPOSITION IN SUPPORT. MISTER
KAUFMAN WELCOME SIR THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
THE PROPONENTS OF THIS BILL
CONTINUE TO CLAIM IT HAS
NOTHING TO IT MEASURE K. WILL
HAVE NO EFFECT ON MEASURE K.
THEY EVEN DID SO HERE TODAY THE
COMPANY ANALYSIS. THAT WOULD
MENTION THOUGH HAS IT HAS A
DIFFERENT THEORY HOW I'LL QUOTE
THAT NOW FOR YOU. QUOTE BECAUSE
VOTERS IN ST BERNARD DINO HAVE
ADOPTED TERM LIMITS AS
AUTHORIZED UNDER CURRENT LAW A
FEWER THAN THE NUMBER OF TERMS
THAT WOULD. BE REQUIRED BY AB
FOUR TO EIGHT IT WOULD PROVIDE
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR A CANDIDATE
FOR SUPERVISOR YOU CHALLENGED
AND POTENTIALLY OVERTURN
MEASURE K. IN COURT ON THE
BASIS THAT IT WAS PRINTED BY
STATE LAW DUE TO THE CONFLICT
BETWEEN THE SINGLE TERM LIMIT
MEASURE K. AND THE REQUIREMENT
THAT. TERM LIMITS BEFORE AT
LEAST TWO TERMS ON THE OTHER
HAND IT BECAUSE OF THAT HE WAS
PRIVATIZED INSURANCE MAY BE
LIMITED. LIMIT AB PROPOSED IT
COULD BE ARGUED THAT AB FOUR TO
EIGHT ONLY REVISES THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR FUTURE
PROPOSALS. FOR TERM LIMITS. AS
WRITTEN AB FOUR TO EIGHT LEAVES
TO THE CORE. THE QUESTION OF
WHETHER MEASURE K. WILL
CONTINUE TO OPERATE. THE INTENT
IS CLEAR. THE PROPONENTS OF
THIS BILL BELIEVE MEASURE K. IS
A PROBLEM. THE REAL PROBLEM IS
STRIPPING VOTERS STATE WIDE OF
THE ABILITY TO DESIGNATE THEIR
PREFERRED LENGTH OF TERM. AND
SAID HEY OF THE COUNTY
SUPERVISORS BECAUSE WE DISLIKE
THE OUTCOME OF AN ELECTION. AND
WE ASK YOU TO VOTE NO THANK
YOU. NOTHING THANK YOU SO MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY HERE
TODAY THAT IS IN GERMAN WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO NOW IS WE'RE
GOING TO SEE. BOTH SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION WE'RE NOT GONNA GO
BACK TO SUPPORT WE'VE HEARD
FROM FOR LEAD WITNESSES.
SUPPORT OPPOSITION NOW WE'RE
GONNA SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR TO
EIGHT HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE CAN YOU PLEASE RISE.
SEE NO ONE WE'RE NOT GONNA GO
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY TO BE A TO
SEE IF ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. SEEN NO ONE
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GO TO A TELECONFERENCE
LINE. WE'RE GONNA CHECK IN WITH
OUR MODERATOR MADAM MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE GIVE UP. ANY
INDIVIDUAL IN IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOUR TO WAIT NOW. THANK YOU FOR
IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR TO EIGHT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
THAT IS ONE AND THEN THEY'RE
OUT HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR
TWENTY EIGHT. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE ONE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS FROM THE COLD
WAR NORMAN ON BEHALF OF SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE'RE NOT
GONNA GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU LETTER COME
FROM BEHIND ONE OF THIRTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M NOT. SO
GOOD AS A WE HAVE A AYE IN
OPPOSITION- IS WELL WE TAKE ALL
COMERS HERE SO SOMETIMES WE'RE
GONNA FOLKS IN OPPOSITION
DURING SUPPORT SOMETIMES WHAT
SUPPORT DURING OPPOSITION. WE
WELCOME ALL COMMENTS THANK YOU
SO MUCH LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER MADAM HONORED. THANK YOU
WE HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME OKAY WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE AND NOW GO TO THOSE
WHO MAY BE IN OPPOSITION. WE'RE
GONNA SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE AT THIS TIME.
FINO AND RIZER GOING TO GO TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SIGNON RICE
MATTER MODERATOR WE'RE COMING
RIGHT BACK AT YA I TO BE ABLE
TO CHECKING TO SEE IF THERE IS
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. OF AB
FOUR TO EIGHT CAN YOU PLEASE
QUEUE THEM UP NOW. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR IN OPPOSITION OF AB
FOUR TO EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AT THE END ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS
ONE AND THEN ZERO HERE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FOUR TWENTY
EIGHT. AND WE WILL GO TO A LINE
OF ONE THIRTY FOUR. I'M STILL
OPPOSE I REPEATED MYSELF ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU. IT'S ALL GOOD WE WELCOME
YOU BACK AT WORK AND THAT GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE MADAM
MODERATOR. THANK YOU WE HAVE NO
FURTHER OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT
THE FINE ARTS TAKE YOU SO MUCH
FOR A MINOR WE'RE GOING TO TURN
IT BACK OVER TO COMMITTEE
DECEIVE YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONVERSATION WE
HAVE A MOTION. BY SENATOR
DORADO LOOK I THINK I JUST WANT
TO EMPHASIZE ON THIS IN HONOR
TURN IT OVER. TO I HAD TO GO TO
SOMEONE AND THEN THE CINNAMON-
IS THAT AT. THE PERSPECTIVE
NATURE I JUST WANT TO POINT
OUT. THAT THE BILL SPECIFICALLY
SAYS. WHAT VOTERS CAN PROPOSE.
IN REGARDS TO WHAT THE FUTURE
LOOKS LIKE SO- IT WAS VERY
CLEAR ON THAT- THE SENTIMENT
HAS BEEN VERY CLEAR ON THAT. I
JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT BECAUSE
I THINK THERE'S BEEN SOME
CONCERN IS SO MY NUMBER. BUT
I'LL LET YOU AYE DO YOUR CLOSED
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE A MOTION
ON THE FLOOR. I CENTERS RAZA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I WANT TO.
AGAIN THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR
IN. A STAFFER WORKING
DILIGENTLY ON THIS I KNOW
THERE'S A FEW FOLKS THAT HAVE
GOTTEN. AND PASSION ABOUT IN
FACT I'M A BIT IMPASSIONED
ABOUT AS WELL BECAUSE- OF FOR
ME- I'VE BEEN DOING PUBLIC
SERVICE FOR. A SIGNIFICANT PART
OF MY LIFE IT'S INTERESTING NOW
THAT I'M IN MY MID FORTIES. AND
I FIRST RAN FOR A CITY COUNCIL
WHEN I WAS TWENTY FOUR. YEARS
OLD AS I KNOW THAT MANY OF YOU
HERE. I'M HAVE RUN FOR LOCAL
OFFICE. WHEN I RAN WHEN I WAS
TWENTY FOUR AND I GOT ELECTED
WHEN I WAS TWENTY FIVE I
THOUGHT I HAD ALL THE ANSWERS.
AT THAT POINT IN TIME. AND I
REMEMBER GETTING ELECTED
THINKING I KNEW WHAT I WAS
DOING IN THAT LITTLE TINY TOWN
THAT I RAN AND WON. IN WITH.
ONLY A TWENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
LIVING IT AND IN A BUDGET OF.
AROUND TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN.
AND ABOUT FIFTY FIFTY STAFF IT
TOOK ME. AT LEAST THREE YEARS.
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT IT WAS THAT
I WAS DOING ON THAT ON THAT
CITY COUNCIL. IN FACT IT
PROBABLY TOOK FIVE YEARS TO
UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT THE
DECISIONS. THAT I WAS MAKING
AND THAT WAS A IN A VERY VERY
VERY SMALL TOWN. THE TWO
COUNTIES THAT I REPRESENT
RIVERSIDE IN SEMINOLE COUNTY-
HAVE NORTH OF TWO MILLION
PEOPLE. THEIR BUDGETS ARE IN
THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
THURMOND PLEASE ARE OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND. PEOPLE IT TAKES TIME
AND SITTING IN THOSE SEATS
COULD BEGIN TO UNDERSTAND THE
IMPACT THAT IS BEING MADE. AND
WHEN YOU ONLY HAVE ONE. TERM TO
BE ABLE TO SERVE AND- THAT
MEANS YOU HAVE. ON AVERAGE YEAR
ONE POINT SIX YEARS OF SERVICE
ON THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS. FOR
TWO AND A HALF YEARS OF SERVICE
ON THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS.
THAT'S NOT. ENOUGH TIME FOR
ELECTED REPRESENT TATIAN TO
UNDER. UNDER THAT THIS. THAT
ARE BEING MAY. THE BILL BEFORE
YOU. SIMPLY SAYS THAT THE
VOTERS. I IN COUNTIES CAN
DECIDE- FOR. A THAT THEY WANT
TO HAVE TERM LIMITS BUT IT'S
LIMITED JUST. A TWO TERM SINCE
THE WITHOUT THE RESPECT THE
REQUEST AND I BILL. THANK YOU
SO MUCH AS A MEMBER WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR MOTION ON
THE FLOOR BY. CENTER DRIES OUT.
MISTER GRINNELL IF YOU COULD
PLEASE CALL THE MOTION AND THEN
CALL THE VOTE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS AND
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS.
SENATOR MCGUIRE HI MCGUIRE- A
SENATOR NIELSEN. NIELSEN KNOWS
SENATOR DORADO. DORADO HI
SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR
WIENER WIENER HI WE HAVE A
THREE ONE VOTE THREE ONE VOTE
WE'RE GONNA KEEP YOUR OPEN
ALLOW OTHER MAJORITY LEADER TO
BE ABLE TO ADD ON THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND SEMANSKY SEE YOU WILL
SEE I THINK NEXT WEEK. ALL
RIGHT. I THOUGHT WE HAD A
SIMILAR NUMBER RIVAS CITING-
HERE. ALL RIGHT- SO- LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE I GIVE US
JUST A COUPLE MINUTES WE'RE ON
THE HUNT- TO BE ABLE TO WE HEAR
THAT AS A MEMBER RIVAS IS. HE
IS ON THE PHONE HE'S ALWAYS
WORKING. ELIZABETH COMING TO US
UP FROM THE VALLEY WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL AND THAT- IS A MEMBER
RIVAS IS WITH US LOOK AT
SIMILARLY HAD A CRITICAL BILL
ONLINE OPEN MEETINGS IN A
SIMILAR RIVAS HAS BEEN WORKING
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THIS ISSUE
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU. I THAT IS VERY
COMPLEMENTARY TO WEAR THIS
RELEASE VAN- AND JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO. MR RIVAS THAT
THIS BILL WOULD ESSENTILLY
ALLOW LOCAL AGENCIES USE
TELECONFERENCING AT WITHOUT
COMPLYING WITH A SPECIFIC BROWN
ACT RESTRICTIONS DURING
EMERGENCIES AND IT'S REALLY
CRITICAL- ESPECIALLY WITH THE
FIRES THAT WE'VE SEEN.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE SO I'M
GONNA TURN IT OVER TO THE
CINNAMON IN SAY THANK YOU FOR
ALL OF YOUR WORK SIR THE FLOOR
IS YOURS WELL THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- IT SENATORS GREAT TO SEE
EVERYBODY AND- MISTER SURE YOU
DID A GOOD JOB AND SUMMARIZING
WHAT THE BILL DOES AND
CERTAINLY. YOU KNOW I THINK WHY
THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT IS IT-
CREATES A MECHANISM FOR US TO
ALLOW ROOM YOU KNOW THE-
ABILITY FOR LOCAL AGENCIES. TO
YOU KNOW USE REMOTE ACCESS I IN
IN THE STATE OF A- E. MERGES IS
NOT RELY ON AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
TO ACCOMPLISH THAT AND SO. YOU
KNOW- WITH THAT- REALLY- I'M
VERY THANKFUL TO THE COMMITTEE
STAFF- WEEK NOW I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THEIR ENGAGEMENT AND
WE WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS- AND SO
WITH THAT- HI- YOU KNOW. COULD
HAVE. EARLY- SHE AND HIGH VOTE
AND- I'M NOT SURE IF WE HAVE
OBSERVE THAT ARE PROVIDING BEAT.
WE DO YEAH SO IT LOOKS LIKE- WE
HAVE TO AND AGAIN AS A MEMBER
THIS IS BEEN ANY AT A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR YOU. AND I
GOTTA TELL YOU- IT'S INCREDIBLY
TIMELY RIGHT IN JUST BEING
CANDID OUT FROM OUR NECK OF THE
WOODS- AND HOW IMPORTANT THIS
IS A TO BE ABLE TO ENSURE THAT
THE PEOPLE'S BUSINESS
CONTINUES- DURING TIMES OF
EVACUATION IN PARTICULAR- WITH
THE GOVERNOR DECLARED EMERGENCY
SOAP. LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
LET'S GO TO OUR FIRST LEAD
SUPPORT WITNESS IF IT'S OKAY
WITH THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THAT
WE HAVE MARKETS DETWILER ON
REPRESENTED CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION MARKETS
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN THE VICE CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND BACK.
EIGHTY THREE SIXTY ONE INTENDED
TO CODIFY PORTIONS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S MARCH TWENTY TWENTY
EXECUTIVE ORDERS RELATED TO THE
BROWN ACT. DUE TO HOW THE
CORONA VIRUS PANDEMIC MADE IT
IMPOSSIBLE TO BE SAFELY
IMMERSED AND CERTAIN PROVISIONS
OF THE BROWN ACT CREATED A
DILEMMA. WE'RE BY COMPLIANCE
WITH ALL OF ITS TERMS WOULD
ENDANGER PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY. RECOGNIZING THE
QUANDARY. MINISTRATION ISSUE
THAT YOU HAVE ORDERS WOULD MAKE
IT POSSIBLE FOR LOCAL AGENCIES
TO CONTINUE TO BE PUBLICLY AND
DELIVER ESSENTIAL LOCAL
SERVICES. WHILE ALSO REMAINING
IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE BROWN
ACT AT THE SAME TIME ENSURING
THAT THE PUBLIC WAS NOT EXPOSED
TO POTENTIAL SOURCES OF
INFECTION. THE INTERACTIVE
ORDER SERVICE IN RECOGNITION OF
THE FACT THAT CERTAIN BROWN
PROVISIONS INSUFFICIENTLY
ADDRESSED EMERGENCY SITUATIONS
NOT CONTEMPLATED. WHEN. THE
INFORMATION WERE ORIGINALLY
DRAFTED. ANY AMENDMENT CANADIAN
THE RESPONSE WITH TO LOOK
AGENCIES TO AMERICAN SUCH. BY
LOCAL AND- FROM THE BILL'S.
UNTIL WELL STILL NONETHELESS
PROVIDE GOVERNMENTS WITH OF. TO
TRANSITION TO REMOTE PUBLIC
MEETING WHILE ALSO ENSURING
THAT THE PUBLIC. HEARING THAT
PUBLIC ACCESS FROM SCRIPT
MANTRA BY. AMONG OTHER PERMITS.
PROTECTIONS AGAINST
TECHNOLOGICAL DISRUPTION AND
CLARITY SURROUNDING THE TIME
WHICH PUBLIC COMMENTS MAY BE
CLOSED. ASIANS HAVE BEEN
CRAFTED OVER THE LAST YEAR AND
A HALF WITH INPUT FROM LOCAL
AGENCIES BASED ON THEIR
EXPERIENCE AS WELL AS THE INPUT
OF OTHER GOOD GOVERNMENT
STAKEHOLDERS. EIGHTY THREE
SIXTY ONE OF NOT JUST ABOUT THE
CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC BUT
ABOUT A MEETING THE NEXT
EMERGENCY SHOULD THERE BE
ANOTHER FUTURE EMERGENCY WHICH
MAKES UNSAFE FOR INDIVIDUALS TO
MEET IN PERSON HELLO YOU CAN BE
WILL BE EMPOWERED TO BE
REMOTELY AND ENSURE THAT
CRITICAL PUBLIC SERVICES
CONTINUE. RATHER THAN RESORTING
TO CANCEL. MEETINGS AND ROBIN
SERVICES. YOU ALL YOUR TIME IF
YOU. WITH RESPECT TO THE
MEASURE AND I WILL ON THE LINE
LISTENING PRESS QUESTION. THANK
SOME MARKETS WERE GRATEFUL THAT
AND GENTLEMEN WE'RE NOW GOING
TO GO TO OUR LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS- WERE REPUBLICAN AND
DEAN IS ON REPRESENTING AC AC-
YOU CALIFORNIA. KILLING THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES IN THE FLOOR
IS YOURS IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU GOODAFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CAITLIN GENE
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE WITH ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION. WE ARE
GRATEFUL TO THE AUTHOR STAFF
SPONSORS INDEED COMMITTEE FOR
THE RECENT AMENDMENTS BEING
MADE TO THE BILL TODAY. WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL CONCERN BUT NOT BEEN
ADDRESSED AND THEREFORE WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE EIGHTY
THREE SIX ONE. SACRAMENTO WELL
THE GOAL OF ENSURING THAT
PUBLIC AGENCIES CAN CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE CRITICAL SERVICES
DURING TIMES OF CRISIS OR
EMERGENCY AFFORDABLE. LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS MUST CONTINUE TO.
ACTIVELY CONDUCT THE PUBLIC'S
BUSINESS IN AN OPEN AND
TRANSPARENT MANNER. THE LEADING
FUNDAMENTAL AND LONGSTANDING
PUBLIC PROTECTION SHOULD BE%
EXTREMELY RARE AND HIGHLY
CIRCUMSCRIBED. UNFORTUNATELY
EIGHTY THREE TO ONE GOES TO FAR
BY EXEMPTING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
FROM THE OBLIGATION AND THE
BROWN ACT TO IDENTIFY THE
LOCATION OF EACH TELECONFERENCE
OCCASION AS WELL AS THE
REQUIREMENT THAT TELECONFERENCE
LOCATIONS BE ACCEPTABLE TO THE
PUBLIC. WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THE BILL AMENDED TO REQUIRE
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATIVE BODY
TO APPEAR ON VIDEO DURING
PUBLIC MEETINGS WHENEVER
TELECONFERENCING. AB THREE SIX
ONE NO LONGER REQUIRES ELECTED
OFFICIALS TO PARTICIPATE IN
PUBLIC MEETINGS IN FACT THE
FIGHT THEIR CONTENT THAT. THE
PUBLIC MUST BE ABLE TO VIEW
THEIR ELECTED OFFICIALS. ON
VIDEO. MORE THE PUBLIC HAS THE
RIGHT TO BE A TO PROVIDE
COMMENT TO THEIR ELECT
OFFICIALS AT THE- AS THAT WILL.
IF THEIR LIFE ARE BEING. AS
SUCH IT IS A- THAT BOTH THE
INTERNET SERVICE IN. COPS ARE
PROVIDED FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ADDRESS THE MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATIVE BODY. THE CURRENT
PANDEMIC HAS REMINDED US HOW
SPECIAL A FUNCTIONAL GOVERNMENT
IS. ALL OF OUR WELL BEING.
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
HAVE RAISED THEIR VOICES TO
FIGHT FOR MORE EQUITABLE BUDGET
RELIEF PACKAGES. TO VOICE
CONCERNS WITH RE OPENING
PLANNED AND ADVOCATE FOR THEIR
LOCAL SMALL BUSINESSES. WE
SHOULD BE EMBRACING THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT HAS MADE IT
EASY FOR PEOPLE TO STAY
CONNECTED DURING THIS TIME. AND
WE SHOULD CONTINUE IT BEYOND
THE PANDEMIC. A WELL INFORMED
AND ENGAGED COMMUNITIES IS
CRITICAL TO BUILDING TRUST AND
REBUILDING BETTER. THE PUBLIC
ACCEPTABILITY REQUIREMENTS OF
THE BROWN ACT ENSURING THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS CANNOT ATTEND
MEETINGS IN PERSON. AND CAN
DIRECTLY ADDRESSED MEMBERS OF
GOVERNING BODY. PROBABLY
REMOVING THE FIDELITY IS
CONTRARY TO THE BASIC. TENANTS
OF A REPRESENTATIVE DEMOCRACY.
ON BEHALF OF EIGHT CARE. ACTION
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO VOTE
NO ON A BETWEEN SIX ONE TODAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
JUSTIN REALLY GREAT OF YOUR
COMMENTS- MISSING WILL BE
HANGING WITH THIS ON WITH. MR
DETWEILER IS WELL SO LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE GOING TO A
TELECONFERENCE LINE EXCUSE ME
WE'RE NOT GOING TO CHECK IN
HERE. IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE TO BE TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
SIX ONE IF YOU COULD PLEASE
STAND ALLEN COME TO THE PODIUM.
C. NINE WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
GOING TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
KNOWN AS RISE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO
OUR TELECONFERENCE LINE. WE'RE
GONNA ASK MADAM MADAM MODERATOR
TO PLEASE- BRING FORWARD ALL
INDIVIDUALS WHO THAT COULD BE A
TO SPEAK- IN IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE SIXTY ONE NOW CAN YOU
PLEASE. KEEP THEM UP IN SUPPORT
OF AB THREE SIX ONE NOW. THANK
YOU ARE YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB THREE SIXTY ONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT THE END ZERO. THAT
IS ONE NINE ZERO FOR YOUR
SUPPRT OF AB THREE SIXTY ONE.
AND WE WILL GO TO A LINE OF ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
JACKYL THEN KILLER CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER IN SUPPORT. HEY THANK
YOU SO MUCH COULD HEAR FROM ME
AGAIN THAT'S GOT OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU ABOUT
A LINE ONE FORTY TWO YEAR LINES
OPEN. TWENTY REYNOLDS IN
CALIFORNIA VISORS ON BEHALF OF
INTER COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
SO MUCH LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU NEXT
TO GO TO LINE ONE OF SEVENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SHALL BE AS THE LEAST SHARP ON
BEHALF OF THE SENATE SANTA CRUZ
METROPOLITAN TRANSIT DISTRICT
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR
THE APPRECIATED THANK YOU
THAT'S GOT OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU ONE EIGHTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE MONEY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA TROUBLES
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANKS
REALLY APPRECIATED THANK YOU SO
MUCH YOUR PHONE CALL NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU THEIR
COMPOUND LINE AT ONE EIGHTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU IN BREAKING WITH THE
APPLICATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AMBER NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THAT'LL BE ONE EIGHTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS DANE
HUTCHINGS WITH THE RAINY PUBLIC
POLICY GROUP. WORK ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY CARLSBAD REDWOOD CITY
FOSTER SAID. THANK YOU DAN
LET'S GO TO NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
THANK YOU KNOW GOAL LINE ONE-
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES THIS
IS ERIC CHURCH WHERE VISIBILITY
RIGHT CALIFORNIA. YOU DON'T
SUPPORT. THANKS ERIC LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU
ONE EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
POPULOUS ALL THIS ON BEHALF OF
THE ORANGE COUNTY WATER
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THAT'S GOING
TO AN EXCELLENT. ONE EIGHTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JEFF NEAL
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION COUNTIES ALSO IN
SUPPORT. GOOD TO HEAR YOUR
VOICE THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR
LINE ONE EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATORS IN THE MORNING ON
BEHALF OF MESA WATER DISTRICT
COURT THANK YOU THANK YOU HAVE
ANY LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NO FURTHER SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME ARMENTA MODERATOR
WILL BE RIGHT BACK WITH YOU
HERE IN JUST A FEW MOMENTS FOR
NOT GOING TO BE CHECKING FOR
THOSE WHO MAY BE IN OPPOSITION
OF AB THREE SIXTY ONE WE'RE
GONNA START. HERE IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE IF YOU'RE
IN OPPOSITION CAN PLEASE STAND.
SIGNON STAND- IN OPPOSITION OF
AB THREE SIXTY ONE WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE GOING TO OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM. OUR OVERFLOW
ROOM IS LONELY AT WE ARE NOT
GOING TO BE GOING TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE A LINE. I'M NOT
A MODERATOR THAT'S QUEUE UP TO
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THREE SIXTY
ONE NOW. THANK YOU IN
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE SPEND
ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE NINE
ZERO FOUR IN OPPOSITION OF AB.
THREE SIXTY ONE. AND WE HAVE A
FEW KERN UP ONE MOMENT MISTER
CHAIR WIDELY DOWN THEIR NUMBER.
AND AGAIN WE ARE ON AB THREE
SIXTY ONE IN OPPOSITION. AND
AGAIN WE'RE ON AB THREE SIXTY
ONE IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE IT WON ALL THREE.
LINE ONE OF THREE EARRING
COMMITTEE. THAT'S CORRECT I ONE
OH SEVEN THANK YOU ONE OH SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DANIEL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF THEY
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA JUSTICE
ALLIANCE THE PROPOSED LEFT MY
DISPOSITION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL TODAY MATAMATA THIS
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
pAIRLINERS OPEN. YES HI BEING
KILL- THIS IS A LIVIA SIDEMEN
WITH LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR
CATHOLIC CONTABILIDADE OFFICE
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF. FIRST
AMENDMENT COALITION ACT FOR
WOMEN AND GIRLS CALIFORNIANS
THE WHERE PEOPLE BUT YOU DON'T
SEE HOW IT TARGETS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION COMMUNITIES UNITED
FOR RESTORATIVE JUSTICE.
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA ASTHMA
COALITION TOGETHER WE WILL
INDIVISIBLE LOS GATOS AND
MERION GROWTH HERE WITH AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH A
LIVIA FREESHEET. THAT THAT'S
GOING TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION THANK YOU AT THE
TIME MISTER CHAIR. ALRIGHT
LADIES IN GERMAN OR BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE TO GET TO SEE
IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONVERSATION. WE WOULD
ALSO WELCOME EMOTION AT THIS
TIME. WITH A MOTION BY SENATOR
WIENER ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
COMMENTS LAST CALL
CONVERSATION. PLEASE SENATOR
AZAM GOOD AFTERNOON YES THAT
QUESTION THE AUTHOR PLEASE
PRETTY. GOOD TO THEM- QUICKLY
RESPOND TO THE COMMENTS MADE I
THINK IT WAS BY ACLU. ON THERE
ARE- PROPOSALS I THINK IF I
UNDERSTOOD IT RIGHT TO. APPEAR
ON VIDEO FOR THE OFFICIALS TO
APPEAR ON VIDEO I THINK IT WAS.
AND TO ALLOW PUBLIC COMMENT BY
PHONE OR INTERNET DID I GET
THAT RIGHT. SURE YEAH AND YOU
KNOW I HAVE SOME- I CAN
POSSIBLY. ON THOSE EXACT
CONCERNS I KNOW WE'VE BEEN
ENGAGING WITH THEM SINCE DAY
ONE- YOU KNOW AND I THINK AS-
THE CHAIR. PROPERLY MENTIONED
AT THE TOP OF- THIS DISCUSSION.
IS THE YOU KNOW WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE BILL THAT WAS PRESENT
EARLIER BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE.
WHO ALSO HAS A IN A POINT ON
THE SPACE TO INCREASE. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY ARE THOSE THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT BUT THE EFFORT WE
HAVE HERE IS VERY DIFFERENT- IN
FACT I'M A CO AUTHOR OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEASE BILL
BECAUSE I SUPPORT. THAT AS WELL
SO IT'S BEEN VERY CHALLENGING
TO WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION-
BECAUSE- YOU KNOW THEY- YEAH-
YOU KNOW THEY- HAVEN'T IN MY
OPINION. WANTED TO SERIOUSLY
ENGAGE WITH OUR BILL- THEY'RE
VIEWED IT AS AN OP YEAH BUT A
BILL THAT'S A COMPETITION WITH
MISTER LEE'S BILL WHICH HIGH- I
DISAGREE WITH. OTHER EXHAUSTION
AND WILLING TO WORK WITH THEM
AS WE HAVE FROM DAY ONE AND I
THINK. YOU KNOW THE ONE THING
WE HAVE TO KEEP IN MIND IS A WE
ARE DOING DID YOU KNOW AND OUR
EFFORT IS WHAT THE POINT IS WE
WHAT WE'VE LEARNED OVER LAST
YEAR AND A HALF OF. THE DISK
AND THEN IT. IS THE IMPORTANT
IT IS IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE.
PREPARED FOR THE NEXT
EMERGENCY. I AND SO YOU KNOW
HOPEFULLY WE'LL NEVER HAVE TO
USE SOMETHING LIKE THIS I KNOW
IT HAS A SUNSET OF TWO YEARS.
BUT CERTAINLY AND IN THOSE NEXT
TWO YEARS LOCAL AGENCIES WILL
NOT HAVE TO WAIT FOR AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER TO ALLOW THEM
TO USE THE TECHNOLOGY THAT'S
BEEN USED ALREADY AMID THIS
PANDEMIC- BUT WILL CERTAINLY
ALLOW US. AND ALLOW THESE LOCAL
AGENCIES OCTOBER TO ENSURE THAT
THEY'RE PROVIDING CRITICAL
SERVICES ON IT YO UNCERTAIN
TIMES- AND SO CERTAINLY THIS
IS- AN EXTENSION OF WHAT WE
HAVE HAD UNDER THIS EMERGENCY-
WE JUST WANT TO INSURE THAT
LOCAL AGENCIES HAVE THAT
FLEXIBILITY. AS TO ENSURE THAT
THAT THAT DAY- CAN- MAKE SURE
THAT. THEY CONTINUE THEIR WORK
NOW. SHOULD WE HAVE AN
EMERGENCY THE FUTURE. THANK YOU
SO THEIR DRUG OF. I IN HEARINGS
NO OTHER COMMENTS I THINK THAT
IMPORTANT ABOUT THIS IN WHAT I
REALLY APPRECIATE WITH THE
SUMMARY OF THIS IS THAT I'M
LUCKY THERE ARE GUARDRAILS ON
THIS THIS IS ONLY IN A TIME OF
A GOVERNOR DECLARED DISASTER
AND THIS IS BE HONEST. SOME OF
THE WORST DISASTERS IN THE
STATE HISTORY OUR GOVERNOR
DECLARED DISASTER SO WHAT I CAN
DO SAY IN OUR NECK OF THE WOODS
WE'VE ENTIRE COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN EVACUATED- AND-
BUSINESS MUST CONTINUE BUT THE
OTHER IMPORTANT GUARD RELIGION
THIS IS THAT NOTICING
REQUIREMENTS ARE STILL-
INDEBTED IN THIS BILL- A HALF A
THAT THE PUBLIC HAS ACCESS IN
THE MEETING IT REQUIRES THAT
THE GENDER PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE PUBLIC TO
DIRECTLY ADDRESS THE
LEGISLATIVE BODY PURSUANT TO
THE BROWN ACT- A TO HAVE TO GET
THEY HAVE TO GIVE NOTICE TO
HAVE THE PUBLIC CAN ACCESS THE
MEDIAN IN PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. AND THE ONLY REASON
WHY I BRING THIS UP IS BECAUSE
THAT'S BEEN REALLY CRITICAL NOT
FOR THE SENATE MEMBER DIED TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE THIS IN TIMES
OF NEED IN OUR COMMUNITIES. AND
WE HAVE SEEN THIS COME MORE
pUNFORTUNATELY MORE AND MORE
ESPECIALLY IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IS WE'VE HAD IN
TURKEY MEANS EVACUATED OR BURN
THROUGH SO- YOU KNOW THAT THAT
IS BEEN REALLY CRITICAL IN
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE THIS TOOL
BUT ALSO BE VERY SPECIFIC IN
WHEN THE TOOL CAN BE USE AND
IT'S GOING TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
THAT. SEND THE WRONG TURN OVER
YOU FOR YOUR CLOTHES WELL I
APPRECIATE THOSE COMMENTS
MISTER CARE AND YOU KNOW AS I
MENTIONED THIS IS ABOUT- YOU
KNOW BEING PREPARED FOR THE
NEXT EMERGENCY. BUT CERTAINLY
THE REASON WE DO THIS WORK IS
TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE THE HIGH
LEVEL OF TRANSPARENCY IN THIS
WORK AS WELL YOU KNOW TO ENSURE
THAT ALL VOICES ARE- YOU KNOW
WILL BE HEARD- AND THAT WE DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT IS YOU KNOW-
MAINTAINED TO THE HIGHEST LEVEL
SO WITH THAT. YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY- RECOVER SPEC LAST
NIGHT- OPENED. ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT I IN THE GYM SO
MEMBER THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M
VERY GRATEFUL ALL RIGHT WE HAVE
A MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY CENTER
WIENER. MR CONNEL CAN YOU PUT
THE- CALL THE MOST. AND THEN
CALL ABOUT. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS A MAN BUT FIRST A MAN
IN RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY SENATOR MCGUIRE AYE
MCGUIRE AYE SENATOR NIELSEN ALL
RIGHT NIELSEN HIS SENATOR
DORADO DRAWS OH FIVE SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR WIENER RIGHT
WIENER HI. FOUR ZERO VOTE LAZY
EVER KEEP THAT BILL OPEN CENTER
WIENER. STILL ALARM FOR THE
MAJORITY LEADERS SO- YOU KNOW.
ALL RIGHT HEY ONE OF OUR
FAVORITES YEAH IS HERE IN FRONT
OF US AND THIS IS A MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH AND IT WHAT IT
WOULD HAVE TO SAY IS THIS IS
ALL HER- IN THE MAKING IN
REGARDS AB EIGHTY THREE. REALLY
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS- IT'S AN IMPORTANT DEL I
DO WANNA LET YOU KNOW AS A
MEMBER THAT YOU DO HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THE BILL
SO- WITH ALL RESPECT IF YOU
DON'T MIND- WILL LOOK FOR A
TRUNCATED VERSION OF YOUR
STATEMENT THE FLOOR IS YOURS
AND JUST WANT TO SAY. WHAT A
PLACE YOU ARE TO WORK WITH EACH
AND EVERY TIME FORESHORES THANK
YOU CHAIR- **** RICHER BECAUSE
ALSO MY WITNESSES PLAN FOR AN
EARLIER HEARING SO THEY'RE NOT
AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW AB EIGHT OH
THREE WOULD AUTHORIZE THE
DEVELOPMENT PROPONENT STATEWIDE
TO SUBMIT APPLICATIONS FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION OF FEE SIMPLE.
INFILL HOUSING ON SMALL LOTS
AND MULTI FAMILY- ZONES TO
ATTRACT NEW RESIDENTS CITIES
NEED TO PROVIDE NEW AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OPTIONS AS CASE THAT IS
MORE OFTEN A SMALL LOT
ORDINANCE SHOWS SMALL HOME NOT
DEVELOPMENTS ARE FEASIBLE UNITS
TO INCREASE HOMEOWNERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES. WHILE WORKING
WITHIN THE EXISTING LAND USE
DESIGNATIONS WE KNOW WE HAVE A
MISSING MIDDLE HOUSING PROBLEM
WE KNOW THAT WE NEED TO HAVE
MORE FOR CELL UNITS THAT ARE
MORE AFFORDABLE BY DESIGN AND
BY MAKING THEM FEASIBLE AND
MAKING A SMALL SHIFT OWN WAVING
MINIMUM LOT FIVE. AS LONG AS
THEY BOTH TO THE EXISTING THAT
DENSITY THAT THE CITY HAS
DECIDED WE CAN ACTUALLY CREATE
THE STARTER HOMES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AGAIN IN WITHOUT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER IF I
VOTE ON EIGHTY EIGHT OFFERS ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER INDIA WE JUST
GOT WORD THAT WE DO NOT HAVE
THOSE WITNESSES ON THE LINE.
ALL GOOD THOUGH SO IF IT'S
ALRIGHT WITH YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO IS
WE'RE GONNA START WITH SUPPORT
WITNESSES HERE AND THERE IN
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE THAT SEE
IF ANYONE LIKE TO BE A RISE IN
SUPPORT. OF AB EIGHTY THREE
SEEN NOW AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO
GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY SECOND
THROUGH TWENTY FORTY. THIRD
RESIDENT. SAID IT REALLY IS- SO
NOW WE'RE GOING TO BE GOING TO
OUR LIVE TELECONFERENCE LINE
WE'RE GONNA CHECK IN WITH MANTA
MODERATOR MATTER MODERATOR IF
WE CAN PLEASE QUEUE UP. ALL
INDIVIDUALS IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT WITH. NOW IF YOU ARE IN
OF AB EIGHT OH THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO YOU
WILL GET A LINE NUMBER AND PUT
BACK INTO Q. AS LINE NUMBER
THEN BACK IN Q. ONE ZERO. AND
WE DO HAVE SOMEBODY QUEUING UP
HERE IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT TO
THE LINE NUMBER. CAN WE WILL GO
TO THE LINE OF ONE EIGHTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OUR THIS IS
RECALL WOULD COMPLETE LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT A
PORTABLE HOUSING AND LOCUSTS
GREAT BILL PLEASE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER HALL
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. HEY WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYBODY ELSE IN QUEUE AT THE
TIME SO IF YOU THINK OUR BOARD
OF AB EIGHT OH THREE. ONE NINE
ZERO. AND WE STILL DON'T HAVE
ANYBODY GIVING UP MEDICARE
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND A
MODERATOR NOT GONNA WILL BE
RIGHT BACK WITH YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
AT CHECK IN AND ADD TO IT WITH
OUR OPPOSITION TO BE RECEIVED
AS ANYONE. IN OPPOSITION TO AB
INTO THREE WE'RE GONNA ASK THEM
TO PLEASE STAND HERE IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. FINO AND
STAMINA GOING TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY NO ONE'S IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY THAT A MODERATOR WE'RE
BACK WITH YOU A QUICK STYLE
WE'RE GOING TO CHECK IN IF YOU
COULD PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS IN OPPOSITION
OF AB IN A THREE. NOW IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION OF AB. IT'LL
THREE. PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONCE AGAIN THAT'S IN OPPOSITION
OF AB IT'LL. THREE ONE NINE
ZERO. AND IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
WE HAVE ANYBODY KEEPING UP NO
WORRIES THANK YOU SO MUCH I MET
A MODERATOR ALRIGHT WE'RE GOING
TO BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
TO BE TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS WE ALSO
WOULD WELCOME A MOTION. UP
LOOKING AT ALL MY GOODNESS-
MULTIPLE FOLKS WE'RE GONNA ITS
CENTER AND WIENER BY A HERE
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND SO LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN WE HAVE A MOTION
ON THE FLOOR RIGHT CENTER
WIENER A LAST CALL FOR
COMMENTS. THREE NINE CINEMA
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FROM IVAN ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR BY CENTER WIENER MISTER
NOW CAN. YOU PLEASE CALL THE
MOTION AND THEN CALL THE VOTE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR MCGUIRE.
AYE MCGUIRE- A SENATOR NIELSEN.
NIELSEN A SENATOR DORADO. ACTOR
ALSO- A SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SENATOR WIENER RIGHT WIENER HI
ATTY CURRENTLY THE FOUR ZERO
VOTE WE'RE GONNA BE TRACKING
DOWN THE MAJORITY LEADER
INSURGENTS ARE CALLING THE
OFFICES WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE GETTING THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. AS IS
TRADITION IN MY RIGHT EYE
CENTER DRIVE SO I CENTER WIENER
I'M DOES A LITTLE SONG AND
DANCE HERE- ACTUALLY THINK THAT
WAS JIM BELL AND I THINK I
HEARD. THAT ONE SENATOR BELL
DID THAT HE PASSED UP THE
TRADITIONAL CENTER WIENER MY
RIGHT. IT ALL RIGHT TO CENTER
WE- WE- WE LOOK TO YOU AS WE
ARE TRACKING DOWN INSTANTLY
AND- TRUST ME YOU DON'T EVER
WANT TO SEE ABOUT. ALL RIGHT
LAZY OVER TO TAKE HIS WORD FOR
IT. RIGHT IS RIGHT HERE ALL
RIGHT SO- IF WE DON'T HAVE
ANYONE BACK IN ABOUT TWO
MINUTES WE'RE GONNA ASK THE
VICE CHAIR IN HIS FOURTH OF
JULY PLANTS. SO WE'RE GOING TO
BE- HEARING THAT YOU HAD TO THE
RIVER THIS WEEKEND. ALL RIGHT
THERE WE GO- R. G. LOOK AT.
DOURADO IS. BREAKING OUT THE
TWO BY. FOUR ARE MY GOOD. I DID
HI DE. YEAH WHAT DO WE DO THAT
ALL RIGHT LAYS WITHOUT FURTHER
DO WORK INTERNET- OVER TO THE
VICE CHAIR AND VICE YEARS
NUMBER ITEM NUMBER TEN AB EIGHT
FIFTY ON BEHALF OF THE
GALLAGHER THE FLOOR IS YOURS IS
RIGHT HERE. MISTER MEMBER
CONSENT OF THE COMMITTEE I WILL
PRESENT THIS FOR A SUPPLEMENT
GALLAGHER WHO HAD TO GO NORTH A
LITTLE BIT EARLIER TODAY. THIS
BILL EXTENDS A SUNSET DATE FOR
A PILOT PROGRAM NOW ACTION.
THAT ENCOURAGES VOLUNTARY
CONSOLIDATION OF SMALL
MUNICIPAL WATER SYSTEMS IN THE
CITIES THESE THREE CITIES EL
MONTE MONTEBELLO AND WILLOW'S
CALIFORNIA. THIS PROVIDING OF
QUALITY AFFORDABLE POTABLE
DRINKING WATER AND CLEAN WATER
FOR OTHER PURPOSES IS REALLY
CHALLENGING FOR VERY SMALL
SYSTEMS THAT DON'T HAVE ACCESS.
AND THEREFORE THIS GIVES US AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO
CONSOLIDATE. WITH OTHER SYSTEMS.
IN NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON BROUGHT
LEGISLATION FORWARD FOR EL
MONTE IN MONTEBELLO IT WAS
SUNSET IT AND THEY HAD ADDED
WILLOWS ALSO TO THE BILL.
BECAUSE OF COLVARD NINETEEN IN
OTHER REGIONS OF THE CITIES ARE
NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
COMPLETE THE PROCESS OF THIS
CONSOLIDATION IN THOSE THREE
CITIES. PRIOR TO THE JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWO TWO YEAR- IT
AT THE END THEY NEED A TWO YEAR
EXTENSION OF THE SUNSET. THIS
WOULD JUST HAPPEN THEN SUNSET
IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. AND GIVE
THOSE RESIDENTS SOME CONFIDENCE
AND HOPE. THAT THEY COULD GET
THE RESOLUTION IN THE
CONSOLIDATION. THIS IS A BIG
DEAL YOU KNOW AS WE SPEAK WE'VE
TO ARRANGE A- WATER HALL FROM A
CITY. TO A TO A RURAL AREA AND
TAME A COUNTY THE PUMP WENT DRY
AND THEY DIDN'T HAVE ANY WATER
AT ALL THE LOCAL PROVIDER SO
THE CITY HAS ACTUALLY HELPED
THAT'S NOT A CONSOLIDATION
THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT THAT EXEMPLIFIES WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
HERE. AND WE DO HAVE ONE
WITNESS TO TESTIFY AID MR
JUSTIN'S CAR BUT WOULD BE ON
THE LINE MISTER CHAIRMAN THE
OTHER POTENTIAL- WHAT NASH IS
NOT AVAILABLE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER VICE CHAIR
AND REALLY GRATEFUL TO YOU FOR
PRESENTING THIS BILL. WE ARE
NOT GOING TO BE GOING TO
AYGESTIN SCARRED FROM THE
CALIFORNIA WATER SERVICE AT MRS
GUARD YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES BUT
I DO WANT YOU KNOW YOU HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT SO WE'RE
GONNA ASK FOR A TRUNCATED
VERSION OF YOUR STATEMENT YES
IN THE FLOOR IS YOURS YOUR NOUN
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I APPRECIATE IT- JUST TO
LET YOU KNOW- MISTER WHEN
PEABODY FROM THE CITY WELL AS
TO WHAT'S GOING TO BE LEAD BUT
NOTHING FOR THE HOLIDAYS- IN
ADDITION TO BEING THE CITY
MANAGER LAWS HE'S ALSO THE FIRE
CHIEF THERE. ARE PULLING DOUBLE
DUTY AND HE HAD TO RESPOND TO A
FIRE WHICH THE REASON HE COULD
BE HERE. BY THANK YOU SO MUCH
I'M SPEAKING AS HE SAID ON
BEHALF CALIFORNIA WATER SERVICE
IN CALIFORNIA BY ASSOCIATION. I
WANT TO THANK AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS GALLAGHER AND GETS INTO
THEIR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
LEGISLATION AND OF COURSE IT'S
AN ORDEAL CENTER. OPERATE ANY
MEASURE TODAY THIS BILL WILL
HELP ENSURE CUSTOMERS SMALL
WATER SYSTEMS RECEIVE CLEAN
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER. WE APPRECIATE THE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR-
MANAGER JUSTIN THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL OUT
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY HERE TO
DATE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE
ARE GOING TO BE LOOKING TO OUR
LEAD OPPOSITION WHEN IS WE
DON'T HAVE ANYONE RECORDED.
WITH THE COMMITTEE SO LET'S IN
GERMAN WE'RE NOT GONNA ASK ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS HEARING ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO GO TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. FIRST LAST NAME
AND ALONG WITH YOUR
ORGANIZATION GOOD AFTERNOON
SIR. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AN OB
OR MEMBERS- JOHNNY P. THAT
WOULD CALIFORNIA ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
MONTEBELLO IS OR OF EIGHTY
EIGHT FIFTY THANK YOU. JOHNNY
HAVE BEEN WONDERFUL YOU'VE BEEN
HERE THE ENTIRE HEARING TO TAKE
YOU SO MUCH SIR FOR HANGING
WITH US- I WAS THE MAYOR OF
EIGHT AND COUNCILMEMBER UPON
YOU KNOW PARKS ALL. ALL MY
GOODNESS YOU KNOW ALL ABOUT AN
HONOR. HEY THANK YOU SO MUCH
SERVER THE GRATEFUL YOU'VE BEEN
THROUGH SOME LONG MEETINGS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE WITH US
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT FIFTY CAN YOU PLEASE RISE
NOW. SEE NO ONE WE ARE NOW
GOING TO BE I CHECK IN WITH
ROOM TWENTY FORTY IN SPORT.
SCENE NO ONE RISE WE ARE NOW
GOING TO GO TO A TELECONFERENCE
LINE. THAT WE'RE GONNA CHECK IN
WITH MADAME MODERATOR IF YOU
COULD PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS IN. SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHT FIFTY NOW. IF YOU
ARE IN. OF EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS.
BUTTON ZERO. AND ONCE AGAIN
THAT IS IN SUPPORT OF AB. EIGHT
FIVE ZERO ONE SEVEN ZERO. AND
IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE WE HAVE
ANYBODY COMING UP WITH A CHAIR
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
MODERATOR WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
LOOKING TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL WE'RE GONNA ASK ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO PLEASE STAND HERE
IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE.
SCENE KNOWING STAND GOING TO GO
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEN
KNOWING STAND RIGHT NOW TO GO
BACK TO AMANDA MODERATOR MANY
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN- PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO MAY
BE IN OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT
FIFTY. NOW IF YOU ARE
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT FIFTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THE END
ZERO TWO TWO THOUSAND Q. ONE
AND THEN ZERO. YOUR OPPOSITION
OF AB. EIGHT FIVE ZERO ONE TEN
ZERO. R. N. ONCE AGAIN THERE IS
NOBODY QUEUEING UP HEY THANK
YOU SO MUCH MENTAL MODERATE
APPRECIATE THAT WE'RE GONNA
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONVERSATION
FROM COMMITTEE TO HAVE A MOTION
FOR THE MOTION BY CENTER WIENER
MOTION BY CENTER WIENER LAST
CALL QUESTIONS CONVERSATION
FROM COMMITTEE. THE NINE ARE
MISTER VICE CHAIR WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE PLEASE I JUST RECEIVED
THIS IS EXEMPLIFYING THE PLIGHT
OF LITTLE. CAKES WE'VE GOT THE
FIRE CHIEF OUT ON A FIRE RIGHT
NOW IT HAS NOT ON THE PHONE
WITH US. ADVOCATING I DON'T
THINK WE NEED IN THIS IS A GOOD
EXAMPLE I ASK AND I WILL NOT
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND- LOOK AT
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT. MISTER
CHAIRMAN I THINK THAT THE
BOTTOM LINE IS WHEN THIS BILL
ORIGINALLY CAME TO US FROM OUR
SIN NUMBER GIVE SEEN HERE. AS
pHAD SOME CONCERNS IN A NARROW
DOWN TO THESE VERY SPECIFIC.
OUT COMMUNITIES AT WHICH IT
REALLY GRATEFUL FOR- IN A YOU
KNOW STRONG BELIEF IS THAT
VOTERS SHOULD ENDORSE ANY SALE
THIS WATER SYSTEM BUT I. DO
APPRECIATE THE WORK BY ITS
OWNERS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER IN OF COURSE THE VICE
CHAIR HERE TODAY. SO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY SENATOR
WIENER. MR CANAL CAN YOU
PLEASE. CALL THE MOTION AND
THEN CALL THE VOTE. FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PAY. BUT FIRST BE
RE. TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR MCGUIRE
HI MCGUIRE- A SENATOR NIELSEN
RIGHT NIELSEN- A SENATOR
DORADO. TORONTO ON A SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER HI. THAT'S CURRENTLY FOR
YOUR VOTE FOR YOUR VOTE THANK
YOU SO MUCH IT LAYS IN GERMAN
AND COMMITTEE INTO- ARE TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS GIVE US TWO
MINUTES. TO DO A QUICK TWO
MINUTE RECESS WE'RE GONNA AND
THEN HEAR FROM IS A MEMBER
FRIEDMAN- AND THEN ASSUME THERE.
ARE MOMENTS SO I GIVE US TWO
MINUTES PLEASE.
THANK YOU JIM THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PATIENCE THAT WE ARE
BACK AT WE'RE GOING TO WELCOME
A SIMILAR FRIEDMAN UP TO THE
PODIUM I'M NOT JUST A KNOWLEDGE
IS A MEMBER FRIEDMAN SHE'S BEEN
A CHAMPION AND ALL ISSUES OF
HOUSING NOT JUST IN HER NECK OF
THE WOODS BUT THROUGHOUT THE
GOLDEN STATE REALLY ONE OF THE
STATE'S LEADERS ON THIS ISSUE-
AND I ALSO WANT TO SAY HOW
GRATEFUL I AM FOR YOUR
COLLABORATION- IN IN YOUR
SINCERE ENGAGEMENT ON THIS
BILL- AND KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO BE ABLE TO FOCUS IN
ON IN THE CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED
PARKING. AND I JUST WANTED
KNOWLEDGE OF PUBLICLY AT YOUR
PLACE WOULD BE TO WORK WITH I
KNOW THAT THIS IS A TOUGH
SUBJECT AND I APPRECIATE AT
YOUR ENGAGEMENT AS WELL AS A
NUMBER SO I CAN TURN THE FLOOR
OVER TO YOU ON AB FOURTEEN OH
ONE- AND I JUST WANT TO CONFIRM
THAT YOU'RE GONNA BE TAKING IN
THE AND IT MEANS THAT ARE IN
FRONT OF US WELL FIRST OF ALL
I'D LIKE TO HAVE ALL OF MY
BILLS HEARD IN YOUR HEARING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SAYS YOU'RE
THE ONLY FILL IN NICELY
GRATEFUL- YES WE ARE GOING TO
BE TAKING THE AMENDMENTS- I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH US TO
ASIA BRING UP YOUR CONCERNS AND
WHAT THE AMENDMENTS WILL DO IS
THEY WILL NARROW THE- SCOPE OF
THIS BILL AND NARROW THE- THE
BUSES- BASICALLY BUS
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WILL APPLY
TO THAT IS REALLY THE HIGHEST
HIGHER QUALITY BUS STOP AS
OPPOSED TO A BUS LINES AND I
THINK THAT THAT'S A WISE MOVE-
SO AT THIS BILL WHICH IS A
PRIORITY BILL FOR THE LA
CAUCUS. IS A BILL THAT REALLY
LOOKS TO DO A LOT OF THINGS ONE
THING TO MAKE SURE THAT THE BIG
INVESTMENTS THAT WE'VE MADE AS
A STATE AND THAT WE HAVE MADE
MANY TIMES AS A REGION IN MAJOR
TRANSIT I'M REALLY BEARS ALL
THE FRUITS OF VALUE GOES
TRANSIT STOPS CAN TAKE WHICH IS
SUPPORTING A TO A TYPE OF LAND
USE THAT ENCOURAGES PEOPLE TO
WALK MORE TO BIKE MORE AND TO
HAVE ADENSER MORE BUSINESS
RICH ENVIRONMENT IT ALSO
RECOGNIZES THAT IN MANY THAT
ALL CITIES PRETTY MUCH EXCEPT
FOR NOW A FEW CITIES. IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE TAKING THE
NEXT STEP HAVE A ONE SIZE FITS
ALL APPROACH WHEN. IT COMES TO
PARKING REGARD TELLING
DEVELOPERS WHAT THEY MUST-
PROVIDE. REGARDLESS OF. THE IS-
OF THOSE. EVEN IF THEY'RE RIGHT
NEXT TO A MAJOR TRANSIT STOP.
NOW DEVELOPERS KNOW VERY WELL.
WHAT THEIR TENANTS AND WHAT
THEIR CLIENTS REQUIRE FOR
PARKING AND YET CITIES.
HANDCUFF THEM. IN ORDER TO DO
THAT. SO IN CALIFORNIA.
GENERALLY APARTMENTS MUST
INCLUDE ONE OR TWO PARKING
SPACES PER UNIT. AND COMMERCIAL
PROPERTIES PROVIDING ONE SPACE
FOR EVERYONE TO TWO HUNDRED
SQUARE FEET. SO WHAT IS THE
RESULT OF THIS IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S LED TO AN OVER ABOVE
SUPPLY OF PARKING. IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WE HAVE EIGHTEEN
POINT SIX MILLION PARKING
SPACES WHICH COMES TO ABOUT TWO
FOR EVERY RESIDENT. WE HAD THAT
IS LED TO AN ASTONISHING TWO
HUNDRED MILES OF LAND DEVOTED
TO PARKING CARS IN LOS ANGELES.
S. N. A STUDY BY THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO OF TWENTY ONE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
FROM THE 39% OF THE PARKING
WHICH IS REQUIRED BY THE
CITY'S. FOR OVER FOUR HUNDRED
SPACES WERE UNUSED AT A COST OF
BETWEEN TWELVE AND THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS. ALSO WE KNOW
THAT WE ARE MOVING TOWARDS AN
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE FUTURE AT
WHAT POINT WE MIGHT REALLY
REGRET HAVING SPENT SO MUCH
MONEY. SO MANY RESOURCES AND SO
MUCH LAND CREATING PARKING. UGH
THE POLICY THAT WE HAVE NOW
ENCOURAGES CAR DEPENDENCE AND
DISCOURAGES MASS TRANSIT USE
INCREASING VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED. IT ALSO WORSENS
CALIFORNIA SEVERE HOUSING
SHORTAGE BY RAISING THE COST OF
HOUSING PRODUCTION ON AVERAGE A
GARAGE COSTS TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND TO THIRTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER SPACE TO
BUILD. A COST THAT IS OFTEN
PASSED ON TO HOUSEHOLDS
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THEY OWN
A CAR. RIGHT NOW. I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN A CONCERN ABOUT
WHAT THIS WILL DO TO DENSITY
BONUS AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THE
CONCERN IS THAT BECAUSE
DEVELOPERS TAKE THAT PARKING
REDUCTIONS AS PART OF DENSITY
BONUS THAT MAYBE IF WE DO
COUPLE THAT AND DON'T FORCE
THEM TO BILL PARKING WE CAN
SOMEHOW LEVERAGE THAT BACK TO
THEM. HOWEVER THE ONLY REASON
THE PARKING REDUCTIONS-
INCLUDED A DENSITY BONUS FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IT'S JUST
SERVICE THE ADDITIONAL DENSITY
IT'S A THAT DENSITY AND THE
ABILITY TO BUILD AFTER UNITS
THAT ADDS VALUE TO THE
BUILDING. NOT THAT ONE TIME
COST REDUCTION OF THE PARKING
HOW DO WE KNOW THIS FOR A FACT
WE KNOW IT BECAUSE SAN DIEGO
ELIMINATED MINIMUM PARKING
REQUIREMENTS IN THEIR TRANSIT
PRIORITY AREAS IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. AND TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY. AFTER THIS WAS ADOPTED
THE CITY SAW MORE THAN A FOUR
TIMES INCREASE IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS PROVIDE. SO WE
KNOW THAT REDUCING THE AMOUNT
OF PARKING THAT'S NEEDED THAT
ELIMINATING THAT MANDATE DOES
NOT NEGATIVELY AFFECT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNDER
DENSITY BONUS. AND WE HAVE
HEARD TESTIMONY BY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PRODUCERS AT THIS WELL
GIVEN THE KIND OF CERTAINTY
THEY NEED TO BUILD WILL HELP
THEM WITH FINANCING WILL IT
WILL. ALLOW US TO INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE
ARE USING IN ADDITION
DEVELOPERS WHO ARE BUILDING FOR
THE MISSING MIDDLE HOUSING THAT
IS NOT SUBSIDIZED THEY'RE NOT
GETTING TAX CREDITS FOR. FOR
ABLE TO BUILD UNITS AND RENT
THEM AT A LOWER COST IF THEY
CAN PROVIDE LESS PARKING OR THE
ABILITY TO BE MORE FLEXIBLE
WITH PARKING LIKE PROVIDING
TANDEM PARKING. AND WE'VE HEARD
THIS OVER AND OVER AGAIN FROM
DEVELOPERS PERSONALLY I'VE
HEARD FROM SMALL DEVELOPERS
PEOPLE THAT ON TWO OR THREE
UNITS COULD SQUEEZE IN ANOTHER
UNIT BUT AREN'T ALLOWED TO BUY
THEIR CIT BECAUSE OF PARKING.
REQUIREMENTS AND THEY KNOW
THEIR TENANTS DON'T NEED. THE
BILL CAN. TO REQUIRE PARKING
FOR THE DISABLED AND FOR A
LUXURY CARS. IT IS NOT. PART OF
BUILDING OWNERS FROM PROVIDING
PARKING. IN FACT IN PLACES THAT
HAVE DONE THIS LIKE BUFFALO NEW
YORK WE STARTED I BELIEVE FIVE
YEARS AGO. ONE OF THE BELPER
STILL INCLUDE PARKING INSTALL.
YOU KNOW A QUITE A BIT OF
PARKING BUT IT GIVES US A BILL
APPROVED THE FLEXIBILITY TO
RIGHT SIZE THE PARKING FOR
THEIR NEEDS AND THE NEEDS OF
THEIR TENANTS. AB FORTINO ONE
IS SPONSORED BY CALIFORNIA
YIMBY CBRE ABUNDANT HOUSING LA
AND THE COUNCIL OF INFILL
BUILDERS. IT IS SUPPORTED BY
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION. THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION SILICON
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP. BAY
AREA COUNSEL CAL ASIAN CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE NRDC. THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION AND TRANSFORM AND I
WILL SAY A GREAT MIX OF
BUSINESS GROUPS. AND
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS AND
HOUSING GROUPS. TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF COUNCIL MEMBERS ACT
HOLDEN FROM THE GUILD FROM KILL
RIGHT. AND MIA KANG THE SENIOR
VICE PRESIDENT OF RELATED
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH AS A MEMBER I WE HAVE
SOME GOOD NEWS HERE WE HAVE A
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THE BILL
ON EIGHTY. FOURTEEN A LINE ITEM
FOURTEENER GENDA. WE'RE GONNA
ASK OUR- WITNESSES AT TO BE
ABLE TO GIVE US A BIT OF A
TRUNCATED VERSION OF YOUR
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY AS WE DO A
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THE BILL.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO THE
NUMBER WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
GOING TO COUNCILMEMBER HILTON
FROM THE CITY GILROY- MR HELTON
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES BUT YOU DO
HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. IN
COMMITTEE SO THE FLOOR IS YOURS
MISTER HELM. THANK YOU DEAR.
HELLO COMMITTEE CHAIR MEMBER
STOP THE PUBLIC I'M JACQUELYN
PRESIDENT OF YOUR CALIFORNIA
AND COVERS THE COMPANY NUMBER.
HE'S ACROSS CALIFORNIA HAVE
MANY EXAMPLES OF PROPERTIES
WERE USED TO NOT REQUIRED
PARKING MANY DECADES AGO.
BEFORE MAJORITY IN GERMANY
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN ADOPTED
THAT REQUIRE MORE LAND TO BE
DEVELOPED FOR PARKING. WITH THE
RECENT IMPLEMENTATION OF
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED. WE LOOK
TOWARDS INCREASING ALTERNATIVE
OPTIONS IN A SINGLE OCCUPANT.
VEHICLE AND CREATIVE SOLUTIONS
LIKE AB PORT YOU KNOW WANT TO
CONTINUE QUESTIONS ALL FOR. BUT
THE REASON ADOPTION OF YOUR
GENERAL PLAN WE CALLED THE
BOOK. CALLED FOR BOLD ACTION
THAT INCLUDED CONTINUING TO
PROMOTE CLEANER MODES OF
TRANSPORTATION. WE ENCOURAGE
EXISTING AND PROPOSED
DEVELOPMENT INCORPORATES
TRANSPORTATION DEMAND
MANAGEMENT MEASURES. SUCH AS
CAR SHARING. DURING THE PATENT
ON BUNDLING A PARKING. APRIL
PROJECT BY THIS. AND HOW THEY
RESEARCH IN TWENTY ONE MAKE
THEM. AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
PARKING LOT. AND BE YOU KNOW
FOR US WITH A LOOK LEVEL TO BE
ABLE TO MAXIMIZE THEIR
COLLECTION OF PROPERTY TAXES.
AND A MIXED USE PROJECT WITH
SIGNIFICANT WILL GENERATE
SIGNIFICANT PROPERTY AND SALES
TAX. LASTLY AT THE STATE WE ARE
ACTIVELY EMBRACING ADVANCING
IDEAS AND PROJECTS TO PROMOTE
THE CONCEPT OF FREE RANGE
PEOPLE WE ADVOCATE FOR BUILDING
AND PLANNING THAT CONSIDERS
FUTURE GENERATIONS AS WELL AS
CURRENT PRESIDENT YOU DON'T OWN
CARS. ADVANCING MOBILITY
OPTIONS REFLECTS WHAT WE ARE
TEACHING THE YOUTH IN OUR
COMMUNITY THURSDAY PROBABLY
SCHOOL AB FORTINO ONE SUPPORTS
THE VISION OF A HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA AND ATTEMPTED.
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY AND
LIVABILITY THANK YOU ANY
CONCLUSION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE BOOK THANK YOU SO MUCH
COUNCILMEMBER GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
GOING TO MAKE CAME FROM THE
COUNCIL THEN TO LOOK UP.
BUILDERS I MISS KING WE DO
HAVE. BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THE
BILL SO WE'RE GONNA ASK FOR A
TRUNCATED VERSION. OF YOUR
STATEMENT THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU CHAIR- WELL MY NAME
IS MIA- AND I AM TO BE. A
PORTABLE HOUSING. AND A BOARD
MEMBER WITH THE COUNCIL INFILL
BUILDERS AND ONE OF THE BILL'S
PROUD CO SPONSOR. AND AS YOU
HEARD PARKING REQUIREMENTS
PERHAPS THE SINGLE MOST
IMPORTANT DRIVER OF HOUSING
COSTS AND GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS CALIFORNIA TODAY. BY
ELIMINATING MINIMUM PARKING
REQUIREMENTS IN TRANSIT RICH
AREAS AND ALLOWING DEVELOPERS
FLEXIBILITY TO RIGHT BY THE
PARKING. WE BELIEVE EIGHTY
FOURTEEN NO ONE WILL.
CONTRACTED TWO THOUSAND. AND
SLASH GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
OFF THE COST OF NEW HOUSING-
WHAT THE POTENTIAL FOR
CALIFORNIANS VACANT BUILDINGS
AND UNDER UTILIZED LAND BY. OUR
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT EIGHTY FOUR
G. MAIL ON WILL ALSO HELP. MAKE
CALIFORNIA DENSITY BONUS LAW
INCLUDING HOUSING PROGRAMS OF
WORK EVEN MORE PRODUCTIVELY. WE
WANT TO ASSURE YOU THAT
DEVELOPERS WILL CONTINUE TO
BUILD PARKING. RIGHT BY THE
PARKING LOT IN SOME OF OUR
RESEARCH WE FOUND THAT IN LA'S.
TRANSIT ORIENTED COMMUNITY
PROJECT HAS. BEEN APPROVED-
OVER EIGHTY OF ALL OF THE
DEVELOPERS OF ABSOLUTELY-
UTILIZED ALL OF THEIR GAMES
CITY. BUT THEY ALSO PROVIDED
MORE PARTY THAT JUST AND THEN
I'M ON REQUIRED SO BY BALANCING
BY ALLOWING DEVELOPERS TO
BALANCE THE COULD PRODUCE THE
HOUSING. IN THE AREAS THAT WE
KNOW THAT WE NEED TO HAVE AN
EXISTING COMMUNITIES AB FORTINO
ONE OF THE SIMPLEST MOST DIRECT
ACTION THE STATE CAN TAKE TODAY
TO LOWER THE COST OF NEW
TRANSIT ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT
FOR SMALL BUSINESSES AND TURN
BACK THE CLOCK. ACCORDING TO
CHANGE FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
COMMITTEE I VOTE AND WE REALLY
THANK YOU ALSO FOR HER
INCREDIBLE LEADERSHIP. THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION TODAY MISCARRYING
LADIES IN GERMAN LAZAR TO LEAD
SUPPORT WITNESSES WE HAVE ONE
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS ON FILE
HERE TODAY WE'RE GOING TO
WELCOME SYNDICATE STUDIO TO THE
COMMITTEE. MISCUE STILL THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH US
REPRESENTING THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY THIS
CONCEALED THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
YOUR TWO MINUTES PLEASE PROCEED
WELCOME. THANK YOU SHE COULD.
TURN THEM IN GOT THE- WITH
WEAPONS ARE AMONG. WE'RE
RESPECTFULLY OF UNLESS. TO
EIGHTY FOURTEEN THERE ONE.
WESTERN CENTER WHOLEHEARTEDLY
AGREED TO SUPPORT THE AUTHORS
INTENDED GALDERMA EXCESSIVE
PARKING REQUIREMENTS AND
ENCOURAGE HEALTHIER COMMUNITIES
LESS RELIANT ON GREENHOUSE GAS
THE CARD. UNFORTUNATELY AB
FORTINO ONE CURRENTLY DOES NOT
STRIKE THE RIGHT BALANCE
BETWEEN POLICY OBJECTIVES AND
THE DEEPLY CRITICAL GOAL OF
INCREASING AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
REALLY INTENSELY OFFER YOUR OWN
AND YOUR TRANSIT 4% AFFORDABLE
PROJECT. PROVIDING A
COMPETITIVE EDGE THE PROJECT IN
MANY MARKETS A COMPETITIVE EDGE
THAT THIS BILL WOULD ELIMINATE
IN ITS CURRENT FORM. REMOVING
THAT ADVANTAGE ENCOURAGES
MARKET RATE DEVELOPMENT NEAR
TRANSIT THAT IS LESS THAN AND
CONTAINS NO AFFORDABLE UNITS.
WE BELIEVE BECAUSE THIS IS A
POLICY OF CAPTURING VALUE THAT
IS BEING CREATED BY THE REMOVAL
OF THE PARKING TO PRODUCE
HOUSING. FOR BOTH THE MALE OF
THE HOUSEHOLD. REQUEST IS NOT
WHETHER WE ELIMINATE YOUR- WE
BELIEVE WE SHOULD. THE QUESTION
OF WHETHER THE ELIMINATION OF
PARKING REQUIREMENT SHOULD BE
DONE IN COORDINATION WITH MIXED
INCOME AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNDER THE DENSITY BONUS
REMARKS. OR DEALING TRONG THAT
THE BONUS. AS AB FORTY NO ONE
IN THE CURRENT FORM. MORE
SIMPLY AND THE QUESTION OF
WHETHER THE ELIMINATION OF
PARKING REQUIREMENTS. DAN
INCLUSIONARY DEVELOPMENT OR
LEFT AND INCLUSIONARY
DEVELOPMENT. MANY CITIES ARE
ALREADY LEVERAGING THAT THE
BONUS BOND LOWERING PARKING
MINIMUM. CITY OF LA HAS DONE
THAT LOOK AT THE CAPITOL
TRANSIT ORIENTED COMMUNITIES
PROGRAM. AND AS AUTHOR MENTOR
AND MENTIONED BENDIGO HAS LOWER
PARKING MINIMUM WE JUST AND
TRAFFIC. BUT HAVE ALSO MADE
CHANGES RECENTLY TO INCREASE A.
B. L. U. COURAGE AMONG
DEVELOPERS. PROJECT MAKING USE
OF REGARD REDUCED PARKING
REQUIREMENTS AND THAT THE
PRODUCT TOGETHER. IS IDEAL THE
OUTCOME. IN TO GET YOU THE-
GOAL WITHOUT HIM BRING AMERICA
BY WHICH DEVELOPER INCREASE. WE
WOULD THE FROM THE BILL THAT A
LIVE PARK MINIMUMS RENDON THAT.
YOUR OR THE DEVELOPER UTILITY.
DENSITY BONUS LAW OR INCLUDES
TEN ARE YOU GONNA. ORIGINALLY
THAT COMMITTEE AMENDMENT NOT
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS AND GIVEN
OUR HOUSING CRISIS. WE CANNOT
AFFORD TO FORGO AN OPPORTUNITY
TO BRING YOU PROJECT INTO AN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FRAMEWORK
AND WE CAN'T AFFORD TO LEAVE
ANY AFFORDABILITY ON THE
PEOPLE. WE SHOULD USE THE
POLICY THAT. POLICY OPTION THAT
REDUCES PARKING AND INCREASES
AFFORDABILITY TOGETHER. SO WE
REALLY THINK THAT WHENEVER
FRIEDMAN AND HER STAFF AS WELL
THE COMMITTEE FOR HEARING OUR
CONCERNS. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
FURTHER DISCUSSION TO
ACCOMPLISH A POLICY THAT WORKS
FOR A CLIMATE TRANSPORTATION
HOUSING AND EQUITY GOALS REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR TIME
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
RISKS YOU REPEAT YOUR TESTIMONY
TODAY AS WELL. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE GOING TO THOSE. IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE. IF YOU COULD PLEASE
STAND SEE NO ONE STANFORD AND
NOW GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY NO
ONE IS STANDING ROOM TWENTY
FORTY LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
COMMITTEE IN THOSE IN
ATTENDANCE WERE NOT GONNA BE
GOING TOWARD TELECONFERENCE
LINE. MADAM MODERATOR IF YOU
CAN PLEASE QUEUE UP ALL
INDIVIDUALS IN SUPPORT IN
SUPPORT. OF AB FORTINO ONE NOW.
IF YOU ARE IN PORT AT A-
FORTINO. PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AND WE WILL START
WITH MY NUMBER ONE NINETY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. RESEARCHER
NUMBERS ALEX OR THE STRATEGY
THREE SIXTY ON BEHALF OF THE
HOUSING ACTION COALITION IS
TRANSPORT LIKE TO THANK THE
FAMILY WOMAN. THANK YOU
TAURUSES BACK THANK YOU SO MUCH
SIR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE HAVE
ALIGNMENT NUMBER ONE FIFTY
FIVE. GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
TRACY MILLER CALLING ON BEHALF
OF SAN FERNANDO VALLEY IN BEING
IN A PLACE ON THAT DATE WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THE NEXT CALLER WOULD
BE A LINE NUMBER ONE AT THIRTY
ONE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE S.
ROSENBLOOM CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES BUSINESS
COUNCIL AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
THAT'S GOOD OR AN EXCELLENT. MY
NUMBER ONE SEVENTY ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR. DON'T PLANNING
AND URBAN RESEARCH ASSOCIATION
THAT PROBLEM BECAUSE BONTA
THEIR HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIA AT STANHOPE HAPPY
THE GREENBELT ALLIANCE
CIRCULATED CAN YOU GO AND TO BE
A AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMISSION COLLEGE STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH THAT'S GOT OUR NEXT CALLER.
MY NUMBER. ONE THIRTEEN. MISTER
JERRY MEMBERS AREN'T ABLE ONE
PAIR REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THE STORM THAT'S
CURRENT X. COLOR. MY NUMBER TWO
OH ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON TO YOU
ARE WE CAN TALK ABOUT
LEADERSHIP GROUP PROUD TO
SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. MY NUMBER IS TWO OH
FIVE. HE BOB IT. ZERO I THINK
LINE TWO OH FIVE INTO SOMEBODY
BUT- COMING TO US LIVE FOR
BENEATH THE OCEAN- MINE TO A
FIVE. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA GO
TO AN EXCELLENT BUT ROB BONTA
BELL WE. THIS IS SMOOTH AS SILK
RIGHT NOW ALL RIGHT SO LET'S GO
OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. OKAY WE
HAVE A LINE NUMBER ONE
SEVENTEENTH MY NUMBER ONE
SEVENTY. HI THIS IS OUR NEED
FOR LEYVA SPEAKING ON BEHALF TO
BURY COUNCIL'S BOARD THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THAT WOULD BE LINE NUMBER. TWO
ELEVEN NINE NUMBER TWO ELEVEN
YEAR OPEN. ONE NINETEEN WITH
ONE GIRL IN THE OFFICE OF MAYOR
LONDON BREED IN SUPPORT AND
ALSO I'LL BE HAPPY THE CAMPUS
DISCO MUNICIPAL TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY IN COURT THANK YOU THANK
YOU CENTER WIENER SAYS HELLO TO
THE MERRIMACK RIGHT. YOU SEE
THAT'S ALRIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. MY
NUMBER. TWO TEN- GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT YOU KERRY MEMBERS LEWIS
MANTE ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIAN
BEACH GEAR IN STRONG SUPPORT
AND AT THE PUMP I'M SURE THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH LUIS NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER ONE SEVENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON
CHAIRAND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THAT COLIN SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS
THE STRONG SUPPORT EAST BAY MD
ALAMEDA CRABBY WHEN NORTHERN
NEIGHBORS MOUNTAIN THE UNBEATEN
INFO FOR EVERYONE PEOPLE
BROWSING ORANGE COUNTY TREAT
FOR PEOPLE URBAN
ENVIRONMENTALISTS SOUTH BAY N.
B. AND YOU'D BE ACTION THANK
YOU MUCH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL. LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THAT WOULD
BE A LINE NUMBER. TWO OH NINE.
MEMBERS SIGN IS WARREN WELLS
FROM- MARIN COUNTY BICYCLE
COALITION AND CAR FREE RENTER
IN BERKELEY CALIFORNIA YOU CAN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT CAR PLEASE. MY NUMBER
TWO ZERO THREE TWO OR THREE. I
TOOK MORE SHAUNA CALLING FROM
LOS ANGELES ON BEHALF OF WHAT'S
BEST FOR EVERYONE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THINK
STEPHANIE. THE CARD PLEASE. AND
THEN WE- HELLO I NUMBER ONE
SIXTY THREE. RESEARCHER THIS IS
BOB NAYLOR FOR FIELD SEVEN IN-STRONG SUPPORT THANKS BOB NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. MY NUMBER TWO
SEVENTEEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARON MEMBERS JORDAN CRIMES ON
BEHALF OF THE PENINSULA YOUNG
DEMOCRATS IN EIGHTY TWENTY TWO
AND TWENTY FOUR IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FORTINO ONE
THANKS SO MUCH THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK JORDAN THAT'S OUR
NEXT CALLER. WE ARE MY NUMBER.
ONE SIXTY EIGHT. HI ALLISON
SCHALLERT CALLING ON BEHALF OF
STORAGE ON THE FRONT LINE AND
HOLLYWOOD FORWARD COMING IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
APPRECIATE THE PHONE CALL TODAY
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT LINE.
WOULD BE LINE OVER TO TWENTY
LINE NUMBER. TWO TWENTY. HI I'M
DAVID WATSON- MEMBER ID NUMBER
YOU CAN BE CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF AB AB FORTY ONE. THANK YOU
DAVID. LET'S CHECK IN WITH OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. MY NUMBER
ONE SEVENTY THREE. MICHAEL
IMMESBERGER PROUD TO SPONSOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU SO
MUCH. NEXT CAR. NUMBER. TWO
NINETEEN. MARKET OF ON AMERICA
ALAMEDA SB NINE ON BEHALF OF
JIMMY ACTUALLY. OR THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY LET'S
CHECK IN WITH THE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWO THIRTEEN. HI JOSH
AMERICAN THOUGHT THAT THE
DINNER WITH RENDON'S FIRST
POSSIBLE GROWTH IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH THE
CARD PLEASE BEEN A MODERN.
THIRTY MY NUMBER TWO OH FOUR.
HI THERE ARE THIS IS KATHY
BATES- WITH PLEASE LET HER
EVERYONE IN THE ACTION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
KELSEY LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. MY NUMBER. TWO SIXTEEN.
YEAH HI I'M PAUL BIG MORE-
CALIFORNIA B. AND A RENTER IN-
SUPPORT WORKING A LOT THANK YOU
THANKS THANK YOU NICE COLOR
PLEASE. WE HAVE A LINE NUMBER
TWO TWENTY TWO. HE MY NUMBER
TWO TWENTY TWO YEAR OPEN. WELL.
ALL RIGHT IT'S GOT OUR NEXT
CALLER. HEY WE HAVE MY NUMBER.
TO FOURTEEN. HI THIS IS MARTHA
NORMAN ALONG BID ON BEHALF OF
THE INLAND EMPIRE BIKING
ALLIANCE- IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. RIGHT AND
MODERATE OF THE CHECK IN WITH
AN EXCELLENT. IT WOULD BE TO
TWENTY FOUR. HI THIS IS HENRY
FONG WITH THE ABUNDANT HOUSING
LA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN ZERO ONE THANK YOU SO
MUCH YEAR THANK YOU SO MUCH
ENERGY. LET'S CHECK IN WITH A
NICE CAR. WE HAVE MY NUMBER TWO
FIFTEEN. THE POINT OF MEADOW.
WEBER WHAT IS THE FIRST ONE AND
I'M CALLING IN FOR. THANK YOU.
THAT'S CORRECT CALLER. MY
NUMBER TWO OH EIGHT. YOUR TRUE
IN ON BEHALF OF CUPERTINO FOR
ALL IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
NINETEEN TWENTY ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOONMY NAME IS HENRY
HOOKER I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
SANTA CRUZ JIMMY IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANKS HENRY.
THAT SAID LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
LINE. IT WOULD BE LINE NUMBER
TWO TWENTY THREE. HELLO THIS IS
MONICA DELA CRUZ CALLING WITH.
HE DEMOCRATS THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
FOURTEEN OH ONE THANK YOU HEY
THANKS FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
LET'S CHECK IN NOW WITH OUR
NEXT CALLER. IT WOULD BE TO
TWENTY FIVE. HI THIS IS A REAL
BAD DAY IN THE NO MONEY IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANKS GARY I'LL- LET'S
SEE WHO'S HONOR- INDEX COLOR
META MODERATORS. IT WOULD BE
LINE NUMBER TWO OH SIX. HI THIS
IS MARK SMITH FROM THE INITIAL
BUILDERS CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT AND PROUD OF OU
SPONSORSHIP. THANK YOU MISTER
SMITH. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. MY
NUMBER ONE NINETY EIGHT. IN A
SECOND BALLOT ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SAN JOSE AND ALTHOUGH
WE DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION ON THE TOPIC KIND WE
LIKE TO THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN FOR HER WILLINGNESS TO
WORK WITH THE CITY ON
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THE COMMENTS TODAY. AT THE
TO GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER. I
WOULD BE LYING. TWO OH FIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS WHAT THE
PROBLEM TOLD ON BEHALF OF THE
PUBLIC AND A GROUP OF FOUR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH LET'S CHECK
IN WITH THE NEXT CALLER. THAT
WOULD BE MY NUMBER. ONE SIXTY
NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON MANY
GENERATION HOUSING BACON
ACCOUNTING IN STRONG SUPPORT
COULD HEAR VOICES ON. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. MY NUMBER TWO OH
TWO. HI NEIL BARTLETT CRITICAL
CUPERTINO JEFF CUPERTINO FOR
ALL IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH ALL RIGHT NOT A
MODERATOR THAT'S GO TO OUR NEXT
LINE. OKAY WE HAVE ONE MORE IN
Q. AND THAT WOULD BE MY NUMBER
T. TWENTY SIX. HI THIS IS ADAM
BOOKBINDER CONCEDE CAMPBELL ON
BEHALF OF SOUTH BAY YOU'D BE
IMPROPER PORT OF AB FORTINO
ONE. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU ADAM
ALL RIGHT SO LAYS IN GERMAN
THAT IS CONCLUDED OUR COLORS IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN OH ONE.
WE ARE NOW GOING TO BE CHECKING
IN WITH THOSE WHO MAY BE IN
OPPOSITION SO WE'RE GONNA ASK
ANYONE HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE WHO MAY BE IN
OPPOSITION TO PLEASE STAND AND
COME FORWARD. SEE NO ONE COME
FORWARD WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
CHECKING IN WITH ROOM TWENTY
FORTY SEEN NO ONE STAND WE'RE
NOT GONNA BE GOING BACK TO
MADAME MODERATOR. NOT A
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN PLEASE
QUEUE UP THOSE WHO ARE IN
OPPOSITION. AND THE BE FORTINO
ONE NOW. SURE IF YOU'RE
OPPOSITION OF AB ONE FOUR ZERO
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE OF ONE
OF THIRTY THREE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
JASON RILEY CALIFORNIA CITIES.
WE ARE OPPOSED TO ALLOWING
THOSE WHO MAKE MONEY OFF
HOUSING ARE COMMUNITIES DICTATE
PARKING REQUIREMENTS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER RYAN LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. THAT WOULD BE
MY NUMBER TWO OH SEVEN.
REMEMBER DOES ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF BEVERLY HILLS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT LINE PLEASE. WHERE
DO I NUMBER. ONE EIGHTY FIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS
DEAN PENSIONS. POLICY GROUP-
SPEAKING OPPOSITION AFTER THE
JUDGE CARLSBAD CORONA FOSTER
SAID THANK YOU THANK YOU
RESURGENCE. LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THEY HAVE
MY NUMBER. TWO TWELVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARED MEMBERS ON
THAT FROM US ON BEHALF OF
PUBLIC ADVOCATES- WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY IN AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON THE
COURT YOU KNOW ONE OF FOR THE
REASONS EXPLAINED BY MISS
CASTEEL THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ALL RIGHT TO CHECK IN
WITH OUR- IT NEXT LINE. IT
WOULD BE LIKE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED TO TWO THEY'RE THEY'RE
ALL. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS DISAPPEAR OFF ON BEHALF
OF THE TOWN OF JACKIE AND THAT
MY COUNTY COUNCIL OF MAYORS AND
COUNCILMEMBERS ALL OF THE
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT THANKS.
THANK YOU MISS ROSS. LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. W. I.
NUMBER. ONE NINETY SIX. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN BRIAN I
GOT STUCK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN THE
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW PROJECT
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED THE
REASON. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. WE HAVE MY NUMBER ONE
EIGHTY FOUR. RECALL WITH
MOVABLE CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
RICK. LET'S CHECK IN WITH OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE ARE MY
NUMBER. ONE NINETY. ONE NINE
NUMBER ONE NINETY YEAR OPEN.
ARE THE TO GO TO OUR NEXT LINE
PLEASE. CAN WE HAVE MY NUMBER
TWO TWENTY EIGHT. TWO TWENTY
NUMBER TWO TWENTY EIGHT. ALL
RIGHT NEXT CALLER PLEASE. OKAY
WE HAVE ONE NUMBER. ONE ONE
EIGHTY SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN OR THE COMMITTEE PAUL
CONSULTANTS ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF BELLFLOWER GLENDORA
RANCHO CUCAMONGA AND THOUSAND
OAKS AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL ALL RIGHT LET'S
CHECK IN WITH OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WE HAVE THE RIGHT
NUMBER TWO THIRTY ONE. HI GOOD
MORNING CAMPAIGN IN SAN JOSE
WITH UNITED NEIGHBORS. ASSEMBLY
FIFTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN. AND ALL
POLITICAL CALIFORNIA AND THE
ALSO DOWNTOWN SAN JOSE
NEIGHBORS IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MONEY YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY THANKS FOR HANGING WITH
US LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. OKAY WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
MORE IN OPPOSITION OF AB ONE
FOUR ZERO ONE IN Q. OKAY THAT
IS IN GENERAL WE'RE GONNA BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE SEE IF WE
HAVE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONVERSATION FROM COMMITTEE YES
CENTER WIENER. PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
WANT TO PERSONALLY THANK THAT
THE CHAIR. OF FOR WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR- ON ON THIS BILL AND
FOR COMING TO GETTING GETTING
TO YES AND- COMING UP WITH-
WITH AMENDMENTS TO COMMUTE TO
GO FOR SOME VERY APPRECIATIVE
THE CHAIR. FIVE TAKING TIME AND
ENERGY TO DO THAT ONE THING THE
AUTHOR. FOR MOVING US FORWARD
SAYS IN THE FIRST TIME THIS
BILLS COMPONENTS CENTER SKINNER
WHEN SHE WAS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SKINNER- INTRODUCE BROUGHT
POINT. AND IT'S A VERY-
IMPORTANT BILL AND I THINK IT'S
DRIVE AN ECHO HERE. OF IT. OKAY
IS IT BETTER NOW OKAY ON THIS
IS IT'S HARD TO OVERSTATE. THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS BILL IN THIS
GENERAL ISSUE I KNOW THERE'S A
LOT OF TO BE A PARTICULAR
RESPECTFUL OF THE WESTERN
CENTER IS. POSITION I
UNDERSTAND I'M A HUGE SUPPORTER
OF THE DENSITY BONUS- AND I AND
I UNDERSTAND THAT I RESPECT OF
YOU BUT I ALSO KNOW THAT
MINIMUM PARKING REQUIREMENTS
HAVE BEEN ONE OF THE ABSOLUTE
PILLARS OF CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
CRISIS. THESE PARKING
REQUIREMENTS WHICH ARE
SOMETIMES OBSCENE. I MEAN IN
SOME PLACES SAN FRANCISCO
ELIMINATED. A PARKING
REQUIREMENTS A FEW YEARS AGO
NOT AS PART OF DENSITY BONUS
SIMPLY GOT RID OF THEM WHAT THE
WHAT THE AUTHORS PLAN TO DO IN
PROGRESS OF SAN FRANCISCO WHERE
WE HAVE A HIGH INCLUSIONARY
WITH TRULY BELIEVE IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE GOT RID
OF IT BECAUSE IT WAS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO A POLICY
PERSPECTIVE. BUT AT LEAST IN
SAN FRANCISCO BEFORE THAT WE
HAD HAD A LOT OF POINT TWO FIVE
IN POINT FIVE TRUCK CALIFORNIA
THE NUMBER OF LIKE. ONE TO ONE
ONE PARKING SPOT PER UNIT OR
TWO TO ONE. IT'S OUTRAGEOUS.
AND IT ABSOLUTELY EXPLODES THE
COST OF BUILDING ANY KIND OF
HOUSING. CAN NINE FIFTY SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER UNIT. TO
THE COST OF BUILDING THAT
HOUSING. IT ALSO MEANS THAT.
YOU KNOW BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
WHEN YOU BUILD. YOUR YOU HAVE
AN ENVELOPE THAT YOU BUILT ON
WITH SETBACKS AND HEIGHTS AND-
IT'S ALL YOU CAN BUILD INTO
INFINITY. AND YET YOU AND- WHEN
YOU HAVE TO DEVOTE LIKE HALF OF
THE SPACE- THIRD OF THE SPACE.
THE CARS. THAT HAVE FURTHER TO
THE SPACE IT'S NOT GOING TO
PEOPLE. IT MEANS YOU ARE
BUILDING WAS HOUSING.
DELIVERING FEWER UNITS. AND THE
UNITS YOU ARE DELIVERING. ARE
MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE IT IS
INCREDIBLY PERNICIOUS AND EVAN
SO MANY STUDIES. AND BOOKS
WRITTEN ON THIS. GUY IT'S LIKE
WE CARE MORE ABOUT CARS THAN WE
CARE ABOUT PEOPLE. FOR LIVING
IN CARS AND DUMPSTERS AND TEN
PERSONS TEN PEOPLE TO OUR UNIT.
AND WE'RE JUST OBSESSING ABOUT
DEDICATING MORE AND MORE SACE
THAT SHOULD BE HOUSING. AND
DEDICATING AT. THE HOUSE CARS
INSTEAD OF PEOPLE. AND IT'S
JUST IT'S JUST TOO MUCH AND
IT'S TIME TO AND THEN WE ALSO
IT'S IMPORTANT I MEAN SOME OF
THEM PEOPLE HEAR ABOUT. WORKING
MINIMUM TO GETTING RID OF IT
THEY THINK OH MEANS NO PARKING
IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT. IT MEANS
THAT WENT OUT DEVELOPMENT IS
BEING FORMULATED YOU CAN TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT WHAT IS THE NEEDED
PARKING. THERE IF PARKING IS
GOING TO BE REALLY IMPORTANT TO
ATTRACT PEOPLE LIVE THERE.
THERE'S GOING TO BE PARKING IF
IT'S NOT THEN THEY'LL BE LESS
PARKING OR NO PARKING AND SO
HAVING THAT FLEXIBILITY- IS
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT SO AS A
MATTER OF. I JUST ABOUT CLIMATE
AND HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
BECAUSE I AGREE WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER WE WANT TO. HAVE
A STRONG DENSITY BONUS BUT IF
WE ARE REDUCING THE SUPPLY OF
HOUSING SO DRAMATICALLY THAT
MAKES HOUSING. MORE AFFORDABLE-
THE DENSITY BONUS HAS A LOT OF
SUPPORT FOR EAGLE. OTHER THAN
PARKING YOU DO YOU GET MORE HOW
YOU CAN AFFECTS THAT BACKS YOU
CAN IN FACT THAT THEY ARE THERE
SO MANY OF- ADVANTAGES THE
DENSITY BONUS IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT PARKING. PARKING STANDS
ON ITS OWN WE NEED TO GET RID
OF THESE MINIMUMS. AND SOME
HAPPY TO MOVE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. SENATOR AND DO
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP ON-
AS HOUSING SHARES WELL IN VERY
GRATEFUL TO BE WORKING WITH YOU
SO LET'S GO TO CENTER DRAWS OF
PLEASE. YES- I- I APPRECIATE
VERY MUCH THE AUTHOR HOT THERE
AND I TALK ABOUT. THESE ISSUES
ALL THE TIME AND FEEL- VERY
FORTUNATE THAT. FEES THEY'RE
THINKING ABOUT EVERYTHING THE
WAY THAT THEY CAN DO AND THEN
THE GREAT. BUT I DO SEE A ARM
MORE OF AN IMPACT IN THE AND
IT'S PROBABLY BECAUSE WE START
OUT THINKING THAT WAY I KNOW
AND THE ONLY DELEGATION YOU
KNOW THIS ISSUE YOU BROUGHT IT
UP AND I WAS SUPPORT OF- I AND-
THINK THAT THE- UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES FOR COMMUNITIES
LIKE THE ONE THAT. ALL WE'RE
TRYING TO BUILD MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IS THERE IT'S A REALITY
AND I THINK THAT WE HAVE TO
WORK HARDER AT NOT HAVING A
OVER BALANCE ON THE SIDE OF.
THE WHICH WE ALL BELIEVE IN
PREACHING TO THE CHOIR HERE YOU
KNOW THAT ENVIRONMENTAL ASPECTS
OF SMOG AND THE POLLUTION- I
GET THAT. I KNOW THAT BECAUSE
IN MY DISTRICT WE HAVE SOME OF
THE WORST AND MOST CONTAMINATED
AREAS. YOU KNOW SOIL WATER YOU
NAME IT- SO I AM ABSOLUTELY
THERE ON THAT ISSUE. BUT THERE
IS- IMPACT AND WE HAVE TO WE
HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IMPACT
THAT IT'S GOING TO HAVE ON.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND I KNOW
EVERY TIME I BRING THIS UP I
WAS IN R. R. SENATE WORKING
GROUP ON HOUSING WE HAVE GOT TO
DO IT AT THE SAME TIME THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT- YOU KNOW
THE- THE PROPOSALS. TO ADDRESS
CLEANER AIR I SEE THE LIST OF
ALL THE ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS-
BUT ON THE OPPOSITION THERE ARE
SOME VERY LEGITIMATE DOWN TO
EARTH ORGANIZATIONS. THAT WORK
ON THESE ISSUES EVERY DAY AS OF
YOU KNOW THEY ALSO HAVE REYES
THIS UNITED. IT'S BEEN A ISSUE
OF HOUSE FOR A HOMELESSNESS FOR
MANY YEARS C. B. E. R. YOU NAME
IT SO THE ARE A- THAT REALLY
ARE ON THE GROUND THEY
UNDERSTAND THAT WHAT THE IMPACT
IS GOING TO BE. AND I REALLY
THINK THAT WE JUST HAVE TO PAY
SOME MORE ATTENTION ALL OF US
ON WHAT THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES COULD BE SO I
REALLY- YOU KNOW I KNOW YOU
MENTIONED- YOU KNOW THERE'S NO
PARKING BUT THERE'S PARKING FOR
ELECTRIC CARS IN ALL. OF LOW
INCOME PEOPLE ARE NOT LIKELY
THE ONES TO BE DRIVING THE
ELECTRIC CARS BUT THAT'S
PROVIDED FOR HERE- YOU KNOW
IT'S NOT IT'S NOT JUST- HOUSE-
WORKING FOR HOUSING BUT THERE'S
PARKING FOR THE COMMERCIAL
AREAS OR NO PARKING FOR THE
COMMERCIALS AREAS. SO I REALLY
HOPE THAT YOU CONTINUE VERY
STRONGLY TO WORK ON TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES ARE I'M NOT GOING
TO IGNORE THAT THE ISSUES AS
THEY'VE BEEN BROUGHT UP TO ME.
AND AS I'M LEARNING BETTER WHAT
POTENTIAL UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES ARE AND I REALLY
ASK THE AUTHOR AUG TO BE TO
TAKE ANOTHER STEP FURTHER. AS
UNCOMFORTABLE AS THAT MIGHT BE
I KNOW YOU'RE VERY COMMITTED TO
THIS I KNOW YOU PUT YOUR HEART
AND SOUL INTO IT ALL BUT WE
CAN'T IGNORE- THE CONCERNS THAT
ARE RAISED. BY YOU KNOW PEOPLE
WHO ARE- INVOLVED WITH LW
INCOME COMMUNITIES- EVERY
SINGLE DAY THEY SEE THE IMPACT
AND SO I REALLY URGE YOU I'M
GONNA SUPPORT TODAY BUT I
REALLY. I JUST ASK THE AUTHOR
DEGAN. EVEN TO A LOT OF A
GREATER LEVEL OF DISCOMFORT WE
HAVE GOT TO WE CAN'T LET THE
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUE AND
ECONOMIC JUSTICE THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ISSUES BE PITTED
AGAINST EACH OTHER AND THAT
HAPPENS TO A LARGE AND I. I
DON'T WANT TO SEE THAT HAPPEN
HERE SO. FOR MY COMMENT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH SANDRA'S I KNOW
THOSE ARE HARD SHELL IS WELL
INTO AS ALWAYS. SHE'S CARRYING
A TWO CRITICAL PIECES OF
HOUSING LEGISLATION SURE AS
WELL AND- ALONG WITH CENTER
WIENER IS REALLY BEEN FOCUSING
ON HOUSING FOR THE MOST
VULNERABLE- IT INCLUDING YOUR-
HOMELESS TAX CREDIT BY THE WAY
WHICH IS IN THE BUDGET WHICH IS
JUST AMAZING AND
CONGRATULATIONS ON THAT AS
WELL. I WHICH IS SO IMPORTANT
THANK YOU FOR THAT ALL RIGHT- I
BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE A MOTION
ON THE FLOOR BY SENATOR WIENER-
I'M GONNA IF IT'S ALRIGHT WITH
YOU SOON MEMBER AND HAVE YOU.
ADDRESS ANY COMMENTS IN YOUR
CLOTHES IF THAT'S ALRIGHT SO
WITH THE MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY
CENTER WIENER THE NUMBER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE PLEASE ALL TO
SAY THAT I ALWAYS TAKE
EVERYTHING THAT SENATOR DRUGS
WHO SAYS WITH A LOT OF GRAVITY
AND- WILL CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR. LETTING. US CONTINUE
THAT WORK ON THIS BILL. A I
JUST TO SAY THAT THE SAME
NUMBER YOU AS I SAY THE
BEGINNING AT ALL IN RIGHT HERE
YOU'VE BEEN INCREDIBLY
COLLABORATIVE. YOU HAVE BEEN
WILLING TO BE ABLE TO WORK AND
I JUST WANNA TAKE A MOMENT TO
SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH. FOR ALL
OF YOUR EFFORT ON THIS I KNOW
THIS IS. ABSOLUTELY NOT EASY.
SO THAT REALLY CRITICAL THOUGH
I THAT YOUR WORK IS BEING DONE.
TO LAYS IN GERMAN WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR. BY CENTER
WIENER WE'RE NOT GONNA HAVE
THIS ORDER NOW CALL THE MOTION
AND THEN CALL THEM. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING. SENATOR
MCGUIRE HI MCGUIRE AYE SENATOR
NIELSEN. NIELSEN HIS SENATOR
DORADO. DORADO A SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER I STATES CURRENTLY FOUR
ZERO VOTE FOR YOUR VOTE WE'RE
GONNA KEEP THE ROLE OPENLY
GERMAN AND ALLOW THE MAJORITY
LEADER TO BE ABLE TO ADD ON. S.
WE HAVE RECEIVED AN OFFICIAL
REQUEST BY SUMMER MULLIN I TO
BE A TAKE FOR MORE BILLS SO YOU
CAN BE HERE AND COMMITTEE
AMERICA SUMMER MULLIN BEFORE.
THERMALS THAT THROWS YOU- AT
COMMITTEE SO- SOME OF THEM WERE
AT THANK YOU SO MUCH ONE FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN THE
LEGISLATURE NUMBER TWO FOR YOUR
WORK ON EIGHTY NINE FIVE NINE.
AGAIN WE HAVE BEEN HONORED TO
BE TO WORK WITH YOU ON THIS
BILL WE DO HAVE AMENDMENTS IN
FRONT OF US WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU'RE GONNA BE TAKING IN
THEM IT'S AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
NOT AT ALL TRYING TO BE RUDE-
MYSELF IN A CENTER WIENER IN
SOME MEMBER GIVE ARE GOING TO
STEP OUT MOMENTARILY WE'RE
GONNA TURN THE MEETING OVER TO
THE VICE CHAIR. WE'RE GOING TO
ASK YOU TO BE A PROCEED AND
AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL
THE WORK ON THIS CRITICAL
ISSUE. THANK YOU FOR THE KIND
THE INTRO MISTER CARE MEMBERS
THAT WANT TO START BY THANKING
YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH ME ON THE MEASURE I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS THAT NARROW
THE- NUISANCE AUTHORITY TO
ALLOW DISTRICTS TO ONLY DECLARE
ENCROACHMENTS. AS A NUISANCE-
REMOVE THE SPECIAL ASSESSMENT
AUTHORITY FROM THE BILL AND
THREE MAKE OTHER TECHNICAL AND
CLARIFYING CHANGES. NINE FIVE
NINE WOULD SIMPLY ALLOW
INDEPENDENT PARKED RESEARCH TO
BE ABLE TO EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS A
MULTITUDE. OF PUBLIC NUISANCES
THAT THEY REGULARLY CONFRONT.
EXAMPLES OF NUISANCES ON PARK
DISTRICT LANDS INCLUDE ILLEGAL
WATER DIVERSION EXTENSION OF
YARDS IN THE PARK HABITAT
ILLEGAL DUMPING AND GRADING. ON
AUTHORIZED LANDSCAPING A LEGAL
STREAMBED ALTERATION ALL OF
WHICH IMPACT SENSITIVE HABITAT
WILDFIRE PROTECTION ZONES AND
OTHER PARK SPECIFIC USES. HER
DISTRICTS NEED TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS ILLEGAL ENCROACHMENTS
IN THE SAME COMPREHENSIVE WAY
THAT CITIES. COUNTIES AND OTHER
SPECIAL DISTRICTS CAN. GIVEN
THE PARK DISTRICTS ARE BEST
SUITED TO. ADDRESS LAND
STEWARDSHIP AND MANAGEMENT
ISSUES ON ITS OWN LANDS.
PROVIDING PARK DISTRICTS WOULD
BE APPROPRIATE NUISANCE
ABATEMENT TOOLS WILL BE THE
MOST EFFICIENT EFFECTIVE
ALLOCATION OF PUBLIC RESOURCES.
THIS MEASURE IS NO OPPOSITION
HAS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. AND I ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE WE HAVE A
COUPLE OF SUPPORT WEST
WITNESSES FROM A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT PARK DISTRICTS WILL.
BE ON THE PHONE I BELIEVE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MULLIN
HEALTH. AND THE YOU DO. A GROUP
WHAT. HELLO EVEN CORRECTIVE.
LET ONE OF YOUR WITNESSES. YES
I'M NOT I'M NOT SURE PRECISELY
WHO WE HAVE SERVED- WE HAVE A
COUPLE OF REPRESENTATIVES FROM
OF SOME OF THE AFFECTED PARK
DISTRICT LAST NIGHT AND-
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE HAVE.
SIX THE IMPORT OF ANY INPUT. WE
HAVE SOMEONE HERE PRESENT. OKAY
HERE IS HILLARY STEVENSON ON
THE LINE. GOOD AFTERNOON CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES GO AHEAD WE
HAVE A PERSON HERE PERSONALLY
AND PRESENT PRESENT TOO I GUESS
BUT NO OKAY GO AHEAD. HELLO GO
AHEAD THANK YOU REALLY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS YOU TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY NINE FIVE NINE. NINE
HILARY STEPHENSON GENERAL
COUNSEL FOR MID PENN REGIONAL
OPEN SPACE DISTRICT. AMID PENN
OWNS AND MANAGES TWENTY SIX
OPEN SPACE PRESERVES YOUR THEIR
CREATORS SANTA CRUZ MOUNTAINS
REGION AND OUR DISTRICT SPENT
PORTIONS OF THREE COUNTIES AND
SEVENTEEN CITIES. HANLAN'S
SERVES AS AN A GREEN BELT FOR A
DENSELY POPULATED URBAN AREA
AND ALTHOUGH WE PROACTIVELY
COORDINATE AND COMMUNICATE WITH
OUR NEIGHBORS. PROBLEMS
OCCASIONALLY ARISE- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MULLIN ALREADY DESCRIBED
SOME REAL LIFE EXAMPLES OF
ISSUES THAT WE COULD ADDRESS
USING THE MUSIC ABATEMENT
PROCESS. THAT WOULD- YOU WOULD
HELP US DELIVER OUR MISSION TO
PROTECT NATURAL WATERCOURSES
PRESERVE NATURAL LANDSCAPES
REDUCE WILDFIRE RISK AND
PROTECT PUBLIC ACCESS TO OUR
PRISONERS WE APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO HEAR THIS BILL
IT WOULD AFFORD OUR AGENTS BE
MORE A TANAMI AND FLEXIBILITY
IN OUR ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM
THANK YOU OR YOUR TIME I'M
GLAD TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THAT YOU MAY HAVE. MODERATOR WE
HAVE AN ADDITIONAL WHAT NASH
PRINCIPAL WITNESS RACHEL CENTER.
AND YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MMBERS AND
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY THIS IS RACHEL
SATYR- ASSISTANT DISTRICT
COUNCIL FOR THE EAST BAY
REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT. THE
EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT
IS A MULTI COUNTY REGIONAL PARK
AND OPEN SPACE DISTRICT CREATED
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
RESOURCES CODE OF COURSE
FUNCTION OF THE PARK DISTRICT
LIKE ANY PART DISTRICT IS THE
STEWARDSHIP OF THE NATURAL
RESOURCES WITHIN OUR
BOUNDARIES. THIS RESPONSIBILITY
HAS BECOME INCREASINGLY
CRITICAL GIVEN THE PRESSING
NEED TO ADDRESS A CHANGING
CLIMATE. THE PARK DISTRICT FOR
DISTRICTS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
PLANNING OPERATION AND
MAINTENANCE OF A SYSTEM OF PARK
LANDS HOWEVER BECAUSE OUR PARK
DISTRICTS DO NOT HAVE LAND USE
POWER LIKE CITIES AND COUNTIES
THE LEGAL TOOLS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO PREVENT
UNAUTHORIZED USES OF PARK LANDS
ARE STRICTLY LIMITED TO THOSE
GRANTED BY STATUTE. AN EXAMPLE
WHERE PARK DISTRICT'S STATUTORY
GRANT ABOUT FORTY IS LIMITED
COMPARED TO CITY AND COUNTY IS
THE ABATEMENT OF NUISANCES. IT
IS FOR THIS REASON I'M SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN SPELL A. B. NINE FIVE
NINE IF THIS BILL BECOMES LAW
IT WOULD PROVIDE PARK DISTRICT
WITH A VALUABLE TOOL. TO
EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY
MANAGE THEIR PARK LANDS. AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN- ALREADY
IDENTIFIED THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF- ILLEGAL ENCROACHMENTS THAT
WE TYPICALLY EXPERIENCE IN ONE
OF THESE EXAMPLES- THE PARK
DISTRICT WAS FORCED TO TURN TO
CIVIL COURT PROCEEDINGS TO
ADDRESS THE ENCROACHMENT. WHICH
WAS COSTLY AND TIME CONSUMING.
AND EVEN AFTER WE GOT A
JUDGMENT AGAINST THIS
ENCROACHING PROPERTY OWNER HE
HAS CONTINUED TO ENCROACH ON
PARK DISTRICT PROPERTY. DUE TO
OUR LIMITED ENFORCEMENT TOOLS.
BY COMPARISON HAVING THE
ABILITY TO ADMINISTRATIVELY
ABATE THESE TYPES OF
ENCROACHMENTS WOULD BE COST
EFFECTIVE. AND HELP THE PARK
DISTRICT EFFICIENTLY CARRY OUT
ITS LAND STEWARDSHIP MISSION.
NOTE THAT THIS ABATEMENT POWER
WOULD BE USED AS A LAST RESORT
WITH THE INTENT TO HAVE IT
FUNCTION AS A DETERRENT TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE CONDUCTING
ILLEGAL ACTIVITIES ON PARK
DISTRICT PROPERTY. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR ATTENTION THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME THIS
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU SO MUCH
YOUR TESTIMONY ADVOCACY WERE
REALLY GRATEFUL LADIES IN
GERMAN WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
CHECKING IN. WITH THOSE WHO MAY
BE IN SUPPORT IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE- WE DO NOT HAVE
A LEAD OPPOSITION LIGHTNESS ON
RECORD WITH THE COMMITTEE
TODAY. SO LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE WHO THAT TO STAND IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINE FIVE NINE
NOW. C. NINE WE'RE NOT GOING TO
GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY. WE
HAVE NO ONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER SUPPORT IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY ONE HAVING TO GO TO A
TELECONFERENCE LINE. NOT A
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE. QUEUE
UP ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS IN
SUPPORT OF. AB NINE FIVE NINE
NOW. IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ADVANTAGE ZERO.
AND WE WILL GO TO THE LINE OF
ONE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIR MARK BANNISTER
BAKER ON BEHALF OF AN ENVELOPE
AND STATE TRUST POSTS CLEARING
SUPPORT AND THANK MISTER MARKER
BRINGING ITSELF THANK YOU THANK
YOU DEAR BYE SIR THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE HAD
A LINE NUMBER TWO TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MICHAEL RAT AGAIN I'LL
BE HAPPY SANTA CLARA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FOR HOW MY
GOODNESS THE LEGENDARY MISTER
RATTIGAN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE PHONE CALL TODAY SIR GREAT
TO HEAR VOICES GO TO WITH THAT
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY MORE IN THE QUEUE. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
MATTER MODERATOR WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE GOING TO THOSE WHO MAY
BE OPPOSED TO THE BILL WE'RE
GONNA SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
OPPOSING ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE. C. KNOWING STAMINA GONNA
GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY. THREE
KNOWN STAMINA GO BACK TO THE
MODERATOR IN CHECKING. AT DC IF
THERE IS ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
OF EIGHTY NINE FIVE NINE NOW
CAN YOU PLEASE KEEP THEM UP
OPPOSITION. NINE FIVE NINE META
MODERATOR. THERE IF YOU ARE
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN. ZERO ONCE AGAIN IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYBODY QUEUING UP RESEARCHER
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH
MATTER MODERATOR VERY GRATEFUL
FOR THAT WE'RE GONNA BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE TO BE ABLE TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS OR MOTION.
ALL RIGHT WE GOT A MOTION BY
CENTER WIENER LAYS GERMAN LOOK
AT THAT- THANK YOU SO MUCH. THE
FINAL CALL FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS C. NINE.
MISTER ZIMMERMAN THE FLOOR IS
YOURS FOR CLOSE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK ON THE BILL MISTER
CHAIR AND STAFF AND I ASK FOR A
VOTE REALLY APPRECIATED THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS NUMBER MULLIN-
TRULY ONE OF THE BEST YEAR- IN
THE LEGISLATURE VERY GRATEFUL.
THAT WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR OF BY SOME BY SENATOR
WIENER MR CANAL CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE MOTION AND THE CALL OF.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FOR
SENATOR MCGUIRE HI MCGUIRE- A
SENATOR NIELSEN. NIELSEN HI
SENATOR DRAWS SO. THEY'RE ALSO-
A SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR
WIENER RIGHT HERE HI. BORDER
ZERO AT THE FOUR ZERO VOTE OVER
TO KEEP THE ROAD OPEN UNTIL HOW
MAJORITY LEADER HERTZBERG TO BE
ABLE TO ADD ON- DURAZO MISTER
HAS- WE HEARD FROM IS YOUR
HERTZBERG. THAT'S WHAT I'M
SAYING. THAT'S RIGHT TED
SPECIAL FORCES ARE LOOKING FOR-
SENATOR T. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
SO MUCH THERE'S A GERMAN WE ARE
NOT GONNA BE MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE ON OUR AGENDA WE
ARE IN THE HOME STRETCH WE HAVE
A CERTAIN NUMBER GABRIEL IS TO
BE IN PRISON AB NINE EIGHTY
NINE AND THEN. WE HAVE A DOUBLE
HEADER SIR DIDN'T- AS A MEMBER
GET REAL IS GONNA BE PRESENTING
ON BEHALF OF THE SIM NUMBER
BERMAN ON AB TWELVE NINETEEN
I'M AND I JUST I WOULD LIKE TO
BE ON THE SAFE YOU WORDS ON
THIS BILL- BEFORE- THE GOOD IS
SOME WOMEN ADVANCES IN AND I TO
TURN IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
SENATOR WIENER FIRST AND
FOREMOST I JUST WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT PUBLICLY TO BE ABLE TO
SAY THANK YOU. TO THE AUTHOR AT
FOR HIS STRONG COMMITMENT TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THERE IS NO
QUESTION THAT THAT IS THE
MEMBER GABRIEL FIGHTS FOR THOSE
WHO NEED HOUSING THE MOST AND
ALSO WANT TO SAY THANK. YOU FOR
WORKING THROUGH. THE DISCUSSION
THAT WE'VE HAD OVER THE PAST-
WEEK WEEK AND A HALF IT REALLY
MEANS A LOT TO US. AND I ALSO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE. MY PARTNER
IN CRIME IN THAT CENTER WIENER-
IN AS WELL AS HIS HOUSING
STAFF. FOR THEIR TIRELESS WORK
ON ALL ISSUES OF HOUSING-
CENTER WIENER AND I HAVE. GONE
OVER. MOST OF THE HOUSING BILLS
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS
THAT WE'VE BEEN TOGETHER HERE
IN THE SENATE. AND I WOULD BE
REMISS IF I DID NOT ACKNOWLEDGE
THE FRIENDSHIP- AND THEN ALSO-
THE PROFESSIONAL. RELATIONSHIP
THAT WE HAVE ON WORKING ON ALL
SHE'S HOUSING AND WORKING
THROUGH ALL ISSUES IS WELL AND
I'M JUST REALLY GRATEFUL. TO
THE GOOD SENATOR FOR SAN
THE AUTHOR IS GOING TO BE
ACCEPTING. WE BELIEVE WILL TAKE
THE POLITICS. OUT OF THIS
PROCESS IN ESTABLISH PANELS OF
THE MINISTRY OF. LAW JUDGES
WITH EXPERTISE NEEDED TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE. IMPARTIAL
DECISIONS ON COMPLICATED ISSUES
OF LAW. THAT SAID. I WHAT I
REALLY APPRECIATE BY- ABOUT AS
A MEMBER GABRIEL IS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE GOOD ASSEMBLY MEMON. SAID
ASSEMBLY MAN AS WELL SENATOR
WIENER. ON THE DETAILS OF THESE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE IN FRONT
WE'RE GOING TO PASS OUT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE IN FRONT OF
US. HERE TODAY FOR EACH OF THE
COMMITTEE. AND IT WILL WORK
THIS ANY FINAL TWEAKS ON THESE
AN IMMENSE OUT BEFORE WE GET
INTO HOUSING- WHICH WILL BE
NEXT THURSDAY. SO WITHOUT THAT-
WITHOUT FURTHER DO I'M GOING TO
TURN IT OVER TO THE GOOD
SENATOR CENTER WIENER. WHO IS
CHAIR OF HOUSING TO BE A SAFE
YOU WORDS THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
WE ARE. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN-
AND FEELING IS MUTUAL. SO I
APPRECIATED THE- THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE WORK VERY HARD. A
WITH THE AUTHOR ON SOMEBODY'S
AMENDMENTS AND USER- YOU KNOW
BY AND LARGE VERY SOLID-AMENDMENTS THAT REALLY. HAVING
THEIR STRENGTH AND MAKE A LOT
OF GOOD CLARIFICATIONS. ON THE
BILL IN TERMS OF TIME LINES ET
CETERA. I DON'T HAVE A TO
SUPPORT THESE AMENDMENTS- TODAY
OF THE ONE OF THE ONE AMENDMENT
THAT- TURNS FROM A VOLUNTARY
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESSES TO A-
MANDATORY ADMINISTRATIVE
EXHAUSTION. PROCESS BEFORE
FILING A HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY
ACT. LAWSUIT IS ONE DIED- I
THINK WE DISCUSSED- NEEDS
FURTHER REFINEMENT- TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE NOT. LEADING
TO UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF
THE ANY OF US. I INTEND AND SO-
I THINK OVER THE NEXT WEEK
THAT'S REALLY WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO FOCUS ON THAT PARTICULAR
PROVISION. WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY TO COMMITTEES
AND THE AUTHOR- TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE ACHIEVING OUR GOALS
AND NOT CREATING UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. AND SO ON I'M
CONFIDENT WE'LL GET THAT DONE-
WITH THE GOAL OF AND TAKING
THOSE REFINEMENTS AS
AMENDMENTS. AND THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS SENATOR IN THAT
WE'D BE REMISS ALSO IF WE
DIDN'T ACKNOWLEDGE IN TIME FROM
GOT INSIDE ALISON FROM HOUSING.
WHO ARE JUST REALLY WORK
COURSES- ON THIS ISSUE INTO
GRATEFUL FOR THEIR PARTNERSHIP
AS WELL BOTH AMAZING- STAFF
TEAM- BOTH HOUSING AND GIVEN BY
COMMITTEES ALL RIGHT. WITH THAT
WE'RE NOT GONNA TURN IT OVER TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL YOU DO
HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THIS
BILL SIR THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR BEGIN BY THANKING
YOU PERSONALLY. AND YOUR STAFF
FOR THE HARD WORK AND THE
FOUGHT FOR ASSISTANCE AND-
WE'RE GONNA BE ACCEPTING THESE
COMMITMENTS TODAY BUT WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE TIME AND
ATTENTION THAT YOU'VE GIVEN US
TO WORKING THROUGH THE BILL-
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP. AND YOUR
PROFESSIONALISM YOUR REALLY TO
MAKE YOURSELF AVAILABLE TO HAVE
THOSE CAR. REALLY GREATLY A-
AND FORWARD CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION WITH BOTH OF YOU
AND ANTON AUS IN A JUST A
WEALTH OF KNOWLEDGE THAT THEY
BRING TO THE SO THANK YU VERY
VERY MUCH FOR. FOR YOUR SINCERE
ENGAGEMENT HERE I'M PLEASED
TODAY TO BE ABLE TO PRESENT
THIS BILL WHICH WOULD CREATE A
SPECIALIZED APPEAL PANEL. TO
ADDRESS SITUATIONS WHERE LOCAL
OFFICIALS SEEK TO PREVENT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. IN VIOLATION OF STATE
LAW THIS IS A MODEST EFFORT TO
STRENGTHEN THE PURPOSE AND
INTENT OF THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT. IN THIS- ED
DEALS WITH THAT EFFORTS TO
BLOCK THE DEVELOPMENT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT
OTHERWISE COMPLIES WITH THE
APPLICABLE GENERAL PLAN. ZONING
AND SUBDIVISION STANDARDS. AND
REQUIRES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
MAKE SPECIFIC FINDINGS IN THE
EVENT THAT THEY DO SO.
PERSONALLY DESPITE ARE WELL
DOCUMENTED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CRISIS SOME LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE DEFIED THE ACT IN TONIGHT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS
EVEN WHEN THEY ARE FULLY
COMPLIANT WITH ALL LOCAL ZONING
AND REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS.
THESE OFFICIALS UNDERSTAND THAT
IN MOST CASES AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROPONENTS WILL HAVE NO
PRACTICAL MEANS. TO CHALLENGE
THE UNLAWFUL DENIAL AS THE
CURRENT REMEDY. LITIGATION IN
SUPERIOR COURT IS ALMOST ALWAYS
PROHIBITIVELY EXPENSIVE TIME
CONSUMING AND OTHERWISE
IMPRACTICAL. AB NINETY NINE
WOULD ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM BY
CREATING AN ALTERNATE PANEL
WITH SPECIALIZED EXPERTISE.
MODERN OFTEN PRO TO HAS
SUCCESSFULLY BEEN IMPLEMENTED
IN OTHER STATES THE
JURISDICTION OF THE REVIEW
PANEL WOULD BE LIMITED TO A
NARROW SINGLE ISSUE. WHETHER
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT VIOLATED
THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT
BY DISAPPROVING A PROJECT
WITHOUT MAKING THE APPROPRIATE
FINDINGS AS REQUIRED BY LAW. IT
WOULD JUST BE ABLE TO RESOLVE
DISPUTES AROUND IMPROPER AND
UNLAWFUL DENIALS ANYMORE
EXPEDITED LESS EXPENSIVE LESS
CONFRONTATIONAL AND MORE
CONSISTENT MANNER. TO BE CLEAR
AB NINE EIGHT NINE SIMPLY
PROVIDES A NEW PROCEDURAL
REMEDY TO RESOLVE DISPUTES IT
DOES NOT UPS ON CHANGING THE
LOCAL ZONING OR LAND USE
POLICIES OR OTHERWISE CHANGE
SUBSTANTIVE STATE LAW AROUND
HOUSING. LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
THE FOLLOW STATE LAW IN GOOD
FAITH ARE HIGHLY UNLIKELY TO
HAVE ANY INTERACTION WITH THIS
PANEL WELL THOSE ARE THE BEEN
ACTIVELY AND WILLFULLY
VIOLATING THE LAW WILL BE
ENCOURAGED TO COME INTO
COMPLIANCE. THIS LESS
ADVERSARIAL AND MORE COST
EFFECTIVE APPROACH IS SUPPORTED
BY A COALITION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING GROUPS HOUSING
ADVOCATES AND LOCAL OFFICIALS.
INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR RAW
HOUSING AND SACRAMENTO. MAYOR
MEANT SACRAMENTO MAYOR DARRELL
STEINBERG. WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY- MARK STIVERS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
IN TWENTY THREE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU AND AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH IS
ELIMINATE ALL RIGHT SO LET'S IN
GENERAL GONNA GO TO OR TO LEAD
SUPPORT WITNESSES ONE WHO WILL
BE IN PERSON AND THE OTHER WILL
BE ON OUR LIVE LINE WE'RE GONNA
NOW TURN IT OVER. TO MARK
STIVERS- HE IS A FORMER RETIRED
A LONG TIME- BELOVED STAFFER
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE NOW
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP JUST AVERAGE THE
FLOOR IS YOURS FOR TWO MINUTES.
AND WE'RE GONNA TURN IT OVER TO
TONY BUT WE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION MR SEVERS
THE FLOORS YOURS TWO MINUTES
THAT THANK YOU MR GLAD TO BE
BACK- MARC SUMMERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP.
THE PARTNERSHIP WAS ACTUALLY
CREATED BY THE LEGISLATURE TO
ADVICE ON- PRODUCTION AND
PRESERVING OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING- IN THE BOOK THE
PARTNERSHIP ALSO PROVIDES
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO MOST OF
THE NONPROFIT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS IN THE
STATE. OUR PARTNERS ARE ARE
WELL AWARE THAT THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
ON WALKING OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THE PARTNERSHIP OFTEN
HEARS FROM OUR DEVELOPERS THAT
THEY ARE NOT THEY WILL NOT TAKE
THE FINANCIAL RISK TO BUY A
PROPERTY IF THEY DON'T THINK
THEY CAN GET THROUGH THE LOCAL
ENTITLEMENT PROCESS. WELL THE
EXISTING HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY
ACT IN THEORY PROTECTS
DEVELOPERS FROM ARBITRATE NILES.
ARE UNREASONABLE CONDITIONS THE
MAKE DEVELOPMENT IN FEW. IS A
RELATIVE. AND PART- VERY FEW
DEVELOPERS WILL SPEND HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN
LEGAL FEES INTEREST AND OTHER
ADDITIONAL CARRYING COSTS AT
LEAST TWO YEARS OF THEIR TIME
TO GO THROUGH THE COURTS. AN
ADMINISTRATIVE APPEALS CUT
PROCESS HAS BEEN TRYING TO PASS
ACCESSIBLE IN MASSACHUSETTS
WHERE IT'S BEEN IN PLACE SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE. RHODE
ISLAND ILLINOIS AND OREGON.
DEVELOPERS ACTUALLY USE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS IN THE
STATE'S WHEREAS. AND THEY THEY
RARELY USE THE COURTS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. OUR DEVELOPER
PARTNERS TELL US THAT EVEN
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY CHANGE THE RISK
PROFILE. GIVING THEM GREATER
CERTAINTY AND CONFIDENCE TO
BRING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROPOSAL FORWARD AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY TO GET THEM BILL.
AB NINETY NINE IS ABOUT
EFFICIENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
WE STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT
AND I TO JUST WANT TO THANK THE
TWO CHAIRS OF THE HOUSING IN
THE GOVERNANCE OF FINANCE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR EXTREME-
ENGAGEMENT IN THESE BILLS AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO WORK ON THE FINE DETAILS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU SO
MUCH MR SERVERS AT LADIES IN
GENERAL NOT GONNA TURN IT OVER
TO TONY BUT WE- ALSO LONGTIME
STAFF MEMBER HERE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE NOW THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION. HE'S HAD
A VERY RELAXED YEAR I MIGHT
ADD- NOT STRESSED AT ALL MISTER
BILLY I WILL TURN IT OVER TO
YOU REPRESENT A CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. MCGUIRE THE CLOSE
COMBAT AGAIN TWENTY WOULD BE
CALL. PART WHICH IS. ON THE
BRIEF- OPERATED. ALREADY STATE-
THE PEOPLE TO TAKE AWAY ANY
WILL CONTROL. VOTER EXPECTED.
ABIDING BY. GAME ALL YOU REALLY
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT- AGAIN THIS
IS. PEOPLE MENTIONED. BUT BUILT.
ANOTHER IMPORTANT CALL IS FOR.
KERN ST LAW ALREADY ON THE
BOOKS- AND I'LL COLLECT. ACTUAL
HE THE COMMITTEES CAPITAL ANTON
IN L. ALONG GERMAN. THE CHAIR-
WE- OR OR OR TO DO WHATEVER WE
NEED TO WORK THING OUT GOING
ALL THOSE WHO I WAS THAT. YOUR
IDOLS ON. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MUCH REALLY GOOD TO HEAR YOUR
VOICE SIR ALL RIGHT LET HIM
GENTLEMEN DO NOT HAVE LEADOFF
WENT IT IS RICK. WITH TODAY. SO
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO WE'RE GONNA
TO IT OVER TO THOSE WHO MAY
WANT TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL HERE IN THE ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE CAN YOU
PLEASE RISE THIS TIME LOOKING
FOR SUPPORT AB EIGHT NINE EIGHT
NINE. THREE NINE ALL RIGHT HERE
WE GO WE'RE. GOING TO ROUTE
TWENTY FORTY DRAWS A WHAT WE
THINK- IT. SAID ALL RIGHT
NUMBER COMING BACK- LITTLE A
LITTLE DEPRESSING OVER IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WERE NOT IN CHECK
OUR TELECONFERENCE LINE- THAT
TO GO TO OUR LIVE LINE IN CHECK
IN WITH OUR MODERATOR META
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB NINETY NINE. NOW SURE IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
NINE EIGHT NINE PRESS ONE NINE
ZERO. THEN WE WILL GO TO THE
LINE OF Q. THIRTY SEVEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN THERE ANYMORE
REPRESENTING BRIDGE HOUSING
REPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WE HAVE ONE NUMBER TWO
THIRTY EIGHT. KELLY COUNTY
DAIRY COUNCIL OF THE PORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH KELLY
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
HEY AND THEY'RE GETTING THEIR
NUMBERS IT'LL BE JUST ONE
SECOND HERE. NO WORRIES NOT A
MODERATOR THANK YOU SO MUCH.
REMINDED INTERFERENCE A PART OF
AB NINETY NINE IT'S ONE TEN
ZERO. AND THEN WE HAVE A LINE
NUMBER TWO THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS MELISSA HI DO I
MEAN AT THAT THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
OKAY AND WE DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY
ELSE THANK YOU MR ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR YOU
DOING A GREAT JOB TODAY THAT'S
GO BACK HERE TO ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE THAT SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE. IN OPPOSITION IF YOU
COULD PLEASE RISE AND AB NINETY
NINE SEEN ON RISE ARE NOT GONNA
GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SEATERS ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY NO ELEVEN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO
BACK TO A TELECONFERENCE LINE.
CHECK IN WITH MADAME MODERATOR
META MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
QUEUE UP. ALL INDIVIDUALS IN
OPPOSITION TO AB NINETY NINE
NOW. SURE IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB NINE EIGHT
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
WE DO HAVE A COUPLE HERE IN Q.
WE WILL GO WITH LINE OVER. ONE
TEN. AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES LOOKING FORWARD TO
REVIEWING THE AMENDMENTS BUT
HOW THAT OPPOSED POSITION ON
THE CURRENT VERSION OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SINCERELY COULD HEAR VOICE
AGAIN LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. AND WE HAVE MY NUMBER
ONE TO THIRTY THREE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOUR MEMBERS JASON RILEY
CALIFORNIA CITY FOR IN THE SAME
BOAT AS THE FACTOR WITH
ACCORDION THE AMENDMENTS HI
THERE UNVEILED TODAY IN
COMMITTEE WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR WORKING MOTHERS US FAR
AND WE HOPE THAT THAT
CONTINUES. UNFORTUNATELY BILL
IMPRINT WE DO HAVE IN A
POSITION THANK YOU MISTER PRIME
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
SURE THERE ARE NO IN THE QUEUE
MANIMAL WRITER THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE GOT ANOTHER BILL TO GO
SO WELL AND THAT'S BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS CONCERNS OF MOTION
PLEASE. MOVE THE BILL. ON
HERE'S ONE MATE TWO COMMENTS
JUST TO BE. CLEAR A COUPLE OF
THINGS- A BIG FAN OF MR STIVERS
I DO ACTUALLY OF A DIFFERENT.
PERSPECTIVE ON THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE HA I AGREE
THAT FOR MANY MANY YEARS THE HA
WAS BORDERLINE. DEAD LETTER NO
ONE WAS USING IT- WE ACTUALLY
THANKS TO LEADERS OF THE CENTER
SKINNER. IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN-
DREW SIGNIFICANTLY BEEFED UP
THE HA THE REMEDIES ABILITY TO
USE THAT. ABILITY TO GET
ATTORNEYS FEES AND I THINK EVEN
IF I RECALL CORRECTLY
PENALTIES- FROM. CITIES THAT
WAS A VERY HARD BILL THAT
REALLY GAVE LIFE TO AND I'VE
SEEN. IN THE BAY AREA. I'M
INCLUDING MY OWN HOMETOWN- WE
HAVE SEEN. OUR DEVELOPERS BE
WILLING TO SUE. US CITIES AND
CITIES HAVE TO. PAY ATTORNEY'S
FEES AND I THINK IT HAS
ACTUALLY SHIFTED THE DYNAMIC
CITIES NO INCLUDING MY OWN CITY
OF SAN FRANCISCO WHICH HAS NOT
ALWAYS BEEN- 100% TIME THE BEST
DR. CITY OF BERKELEY WHICH USED
TO BE A VERY BAD ACTOR AND JUST
RECENTLY DENYING PROJECTS
WEALTHY CITIES ON THE
PENINSULA. SO I THINK IT HAS
HAD A REAL IMPACT I BUT I DO
AGREE THAT HAVING. A MINUTE
MINISTRY TO PROCESS- WHERE YOU
DON'T HAVE TO GO TO THE
POLITICIZATION. IS A GOOD IDEA
AND THAT'S WHY SUPPORT THOSE
ARE BUILT ON THERE'S I KNOW
THAT- THERE'S GONNA FOCUS ON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON THIS BILL
BUT TO BE CLEAR IT'S OFTEN I'VE
DISCUSSED. THIS BILL APPLIES AS
LONG AS THERE'S 20%
AFFORDABILITY- WHICH HAPPENS TO
BE THE INCLUSIONARY ABOUT A LOT
YOU KNOW A FAIR NUMBER OF
CITIES. HAVE SO A LOT OF
SUPERMARKET RATE WITH
INCLUSIONARY MIXED INCOME
HOUSING WILL BE PART OF THIS-
AS WELL AND SO AS WE DO THESE
CLARIFICATIONS- THEY NEED TO
BE. ABLE TO- BUT I'M HAPPY. THE
BILL- WITH MACHINE ON THE- BY.
AS SOON WE PLEASE ENTER. YEAH-
SINCE THIS IS BY BACK AND FOR
THE BILL HERE WITH THE- AND
WHAT WAS THEIR- HE- ME THROUGH.
WHAT THIS NOW MEANS THE END
RESULT. WHAT ARE THE CHANGES
COMBINING WHAT YOU ORIGINALLY
HAD. WITH THE AMENDMENTS. WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN NOW. YEAH
ABSOLUTELY SENATORS SO- ALL
WALKING THROUGH THEM AND THEN
OF COURSE IF THAT THE CHAIR
WOULD LIKE TO ADD ANY COMMENTS
TO THAT. SO PART OF THIS IS
BEFORE WE WERE HAVE- A NUMBER
OF FOLKS ON THE COMMITTEE THAT
WOULD BE- APPOINTEES OF THE
GOVERNOR AND OTHER FOLKS THAT
WERE COMING FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OR HAD EXPERTISE. IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE HAVE NOW
REPLACE THAT WITH A PANEL OF
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES. SO
WE'LL HAVE THOSE FOLKS INSTEAD
OF THE APPOINTEES- A SUNSET IT
HAS BEEN ADDED TO THE BILL OF
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
NINE. THE CAN OCCUR- ONLY AFTER
THE LOCAL AGENCY HAS MADE A
FINAL DECISION. SO THAT'S
CLEAR- BUT WE'VE ALSO BUILT IN
TIME FOR THE LOCAL AGENCY TO
CURE THE DECISION- SO THAT IF
THAT. IF THEY MAKE A DECISION
AND THEN THERE'S SOME DISPUTE
ABOUT WHETHER IT'S COMPLIANCE
COMPLYING WITH THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT THE PARTIES
WOULD THEN HAVE. SOME TIME TO
GO BACK AND TRY TO NEGOTIATE
SOMETHING THAT EVERYBODY FELT
GOOD ABOUT. BEFORE THAT. REVIEW
PROCESS WOULD BE TRIGGERED-
THERE WERE SOME ADJUSTMENTS TO
A FEW TIME LINES IN THE BILL-
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT THAT
THAT THE TIMELINE WAS WORKABLE-
AND THEN OBVIOUSLY THIS FINAL
POINT. ABOUT USING THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS NOT
FIRST SO THOSE WERE THE THOSE
ARE THE MAJOR- THOSE ARE THE
MAJOR MINUTES I THINK I'VE YOU
KNOW IF YOU WANT ANYTHING MR
CHAIRMAN THAT'S THAT'S MY
UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW YOU'RE I
THINK YOU'RE- YOU'RE PRETTY
MUCH SPOT ON THERE AS A MEMBER
I THINK THAT THE ONE PIECE THAT
WE- HAD FIVE DAYS PRIOR TO
GOING INTO. A POTENTIAL
CORRECTIVE ACTION BEING ABLE TO
GET THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENT THE
SIXTY DAYS TO BE ABLE TO GET IT
DONE UNDER THEIR J. I DIDN'T
DEATH TO BE ABLE TO CORRECT IT.
NUMBER ONE. AND THEN RATHER
THAN ANY OF THE POLITICAL
APPOINTMENTS. WE'RE TAKING A
VERY SIMILAR APPROACH THAT WE
DO WITH THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION OR THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION WHERE WE
HAVE A CONTENT EXPERT IS
ADMINISTERED LAW JUDGE. HEARING
THAT AS WELL- SO THAT'S THE
REMAINDER OF THE BILL HASN'T
BEEN TOUCHED IT SIMPLY- THE
PROCESS. RELATING TO WHO. AND
IN WHAT TIMELINE I WILL HEAR
ANY OF THESE ALLEGED
VIOLATIONS. SO IT SO THE-
THERE'S STILL- THE OP. THERE'S
STILL THE RIGHT TO GO TO COURT.
YOU HAVE TO GO TO LITIGATION
THEY EVEN. EVEN WITH THIS
PROCESS IT IT IT WOULD BE
ABSOLUTE TO SAY THAT IN
INDIVIDUALS IN FRONT OF THE
MINISTRY OF LOGICS THEY HAVE TO
BE TO COMPLETE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JEFF PROCESS
BUT THEN THEY COULD TAKE- THE
JURISDICTION TO COURT. AFTER
THEY. GO THROUGH THAT PROCESS
100% TWENTY FIVE. IT DOESN'T IF
IT DOES ELIMINATE THE LET'S NOT
LOSE SIGHT DOESN'T. OF THEIR
LIVES AND A NUMBER YOU CAN AND
I'M I JUST HAD ONE OF THE
THINGS OR IF I MAY THAT. FOR
THEIR DIFFERENT CLASSES OF
PLAINTIFFS PEOPLE WHO CAN BRING
CHALLENGE UNDER THE HOUSING
KIND OF ALL THE ACT AND SO FOR.
CIVIL RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS OR
PROSPECTIVE TENANTS THEY HAVE
THE ABILITY TO GO IMMEDIATELY
TO COURT THE- THE REVIEW PANEL.
IS INTENDED SPECIFICALLY FOR
APPLICANTS RICHEST DEVELOPERS
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND SO
WOULD YOU CONSIDER THIS THAT
IT'S GOING TO. EXPEDITE GIVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO EXPEDITE.
BUT IT STILL GIVES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO STILL GIVES THE
RIGHT TO GO TO COURT SO. HOW
HOW DOES THAT REALLY EXPEDITE
CORRECTIVE CHAU- THE IDEA HERE
AND PART OF THIS IS BASED ON-
YOU KNOW WHAT WE'VE HEARD FROM
FOLKS IN THE FIELD BUT ALSO
WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN OTHER STATES
THAT HAVE. THAT HAVE ADOPTED
THIS APPROACH. IF SOMEBODY NOW.
D. FILES A LAWSUIT IN ALL
LIKELIHOOD IT'S GOING TO TAKE
THEM TO YEARS OF TIME RIGHT TED
WE'VE GOT GOING THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF LITIGATION IT'S
GONNA COST THEM HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OR EVEN MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. TO HAVE THAT
LITIGATED- AND THERE'S A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT HOW THAT
PROCESS MIGHT WORK OUT. IT'S A
LOT OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS HAVE SAIDTHEY ARE
EXTREMELY RELUCTANT EVEN WHEN
THERE'S A CLEAR. OPEN VIOLATION
OF THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY
ACT TO ENGAGE IN LITIGATION
PROCESS AND SO. THIS PANEL IS
SOMETHING WHERE YOU CAN GO
BECAUSE OF THE TIME LINES THAT
ARE SET UP. YOU CAN GET A
DECISION MUCH MORE QUICKLY. YOU
CAN HAVE A LESS ADVERSARIAL
PROCESS- LESS EXPENSIVE PROCESS
AND WHAT REALLY STRUCK TO ME
ABOUT THIS. IS WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE RE THAT WAS DONE ON HOW
IT'S BEEN IN. ANOTHER STATES
BUT MASTER. A VERY SICK. NUMBER
OF THESE. THESE APPEAL. ACTION
OF SADDAM THEY'RE NOT HEARD BY
THE BOY SO. THE ME FACT THAT
THERE AN APPEAL. SURE TO GET
THE- TO GO. THEY CAN NEGOTIATED
FAITH OUT A DEAL GET TO YES AND
BE ABLE TO. TO PROCEED FOR TO
THE IDEA HERE IS TO CREATE. A
PROCESS THAT IS LESS
CONFRONTATIONAL LESS EXPENSIVE
QUICKER AND MORE EFFICIENT WITH
EXPERTS AS AS THE AS THE
CHAIRMAN. CHEN ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW JUDGES WHO HAVE DEEP SOUTH.
EXPERTISE WHO CAN HELP TO
RESOLVE THESE TO. MARC OKAY.
WELL YOU'RE HOPEFUL. RIGHT THIS
IS THIS IS B. THAT THIS WILL IN
FACT HELP. OF TO BRING PEOPLE
TOGETHER TO THE PARTIES
TOGETHER TO THE FALL I GUESS
I'M I'M CONCERNED THAT IF
THEY'RE STILL THE RIGHT TO GO
TO COURT THEN IS THIS ANOTHER.
ANOTHER DELAY. YOU KNOW IN THE
PROCESS YEAH I DON'T TO SENATE
SENATOR IF I MAY YOU KNOW THAT
THAT MIGHT MY HOPE HERE IS BORN
OUT OF TWO DIFFERENT THINGS ONE
IS THE RESEARCH WHICH- WAS DONE
BY MIT. THAT HELPED US TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THIS WORKS. IN
IN IN YOU KNOW IN PRACTICE IN
THE STATE OF MASSACHUSETTS
WHERE YOU'VE HEARD IT'S BEEN IN
PLACE FOR SEVERAL DECADES- AND
ALSO MY OWN EXPERIENCE AS AN
ATTORNEY- AND UNDERSTANDING THE
RELUCTANCE OF PEOPLE TO GO
ACTUALLY ENGAGE IN THE
LITIGATION PROCESS JUST HOW
EXTRAORDINARILY EXPENSIVE. AND
TIME CONSUMING CAN BE IT SO
OFTEN LITIGATION TO GET INTO
COLLATERAL ISSUES OF. WHAT
DOCUMENTS ARE AVAILABLE
DISCOVERED DISCOVERY WHOSE
DEPOSITION YOU GET TO TAKE I
MEAN YOU CAN JUST GO DOWN ALL
KINDS OF RABBIT HOLES IN THE
LITIGATION PROCESS. AND YOU
KNOW IN SOME WAYS THIS IS MORE
I CAN TO YOU KNOW AN EXPEDITED-
NEGOTIATION PROCESS OR OR AN
EXPEDITED RESOLUTION PROCESS
WHERE THE WHERE THE PARTIES CAN
GET TOGETHER. GET TO THE HEART
OF THE ISSUE WITH IT WITH AN
EXPERTISE WITH WITH FOLKS WITH
EXPERTISE. GET SOME KIND OF
RESOLUTION SO ULTIMATELY THERE
IS THAT OPTION OF LITIGATION AT
AT THAT THAT STILL REMAINS. BUT
I THINK BECAUSE OF INCENTIVES
IN ECONOMICS AND TIME AND A LOT
OF OTHER CONSIDERATIONS THEY'RE
GONNA BE VERY STRONG INCENTIVES
FOR FOLKS TO USE THE APPEAL
PANEL RATHER THAN TO ENTER INTO
LITIGATION. AND I KNOW THE ONLY
SAY THAT I'M SORRY NOT TRYING
TO BE CYNICAL OR NEGATIVE BUT-
OBVIOUSLY- ANY ENTITIES THE
FIGHTS. OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND A RESPONSIBILITY TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THEY GET
PRETTY A DUG IN THEIR HEELS SO
I'M HOPEFUL. ON AND I THINK YOU
SHOULD HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DO IT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR. PLEASE NO THANK YOU
ACCESS I WANT US TO RESPOND
FURTHER TO US IN REQUIRE CENTER
ROSS'S QUESTION BECAUSE IT'S
ACTUALLY THE ISSUES YOU RAISE
ARE EXACTLY WHAT WE'VE ALL BEEN
DISCUSSING FOR THE FINAL
AMENDMENT WHICH- THE BILL AS
INTRODUCED MAKES THE
ADMINISTRATIVE APPEAL OPTIONAL
TO SOMEONE CAN GO TO COURT
RIGHT WHERE THEY WANT WHERE
THEY CAN PURSUE THIS AND MANY
PEOPLE WILL PURSUE THE- OFF IF
THEY HAVE AN OPTION THE
ADMINISTRATIVE CODE BECAUSE IT
IS. I AGREE WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IT'S CHEAPER IT'S FASTER
AND MORE EFFICIENT BUT THEN
THERE ARE OF COURSE THERE ARE
THE DESTRUCTION OF CITIES THAT
ARE WILLING TO PAY WHATEVER WE
KNOW WE SORT OF KNOW WHO THEY
ARE- WHERE THERE COULD BE AN
UNSETTLED QUESTION OF LAW THAT
REALLY ALL TO MY HOUSE TO GO TO
THE COURTS. AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT- REALLY WORKING ON
NEXT WEEK IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
FIRST SOLAR THERE REALLY FIRM
TIME LINE SO YOU CAN'T GET
CAUGHT UP IN A IF IT IS GOING
TO BE NOT A GOOD ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCESS BUT YOU'RE NOT CAUGHT
UP INDEFINITELY AND YOU CAN GO
TO COURT IF YOU NEED TO. AND
ALSO MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE
CONTINUE TO HAVE A VERY
MEANINGFUL COURT REMEDY AND
WE'RE NOT EVEN FOR ME UNDERMINE
IT I'M NOT SO WE'RE GOING TO BE
WORKING ON OVER. THE NEXT WEEK
I'M CONFIDENT THAT WE'LL GET
THERE. ALL RIGHT. IN ADDITIONAL.
BECAUSE CAN. FROM COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SANDRA SO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY
CENTER WIENER ACTION THEN WE
GET CLOSE I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU AGAIN TO YOU AND YOUR
STAFF MISTER CHAIR REALLY
REALLY APPRECIATE ENGAGEMENT
AND THE THOUGHTFUL CONVERSATION
IN THE ASSISTANCE AND WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I LOVE
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A MEMBER
OF THE FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU
MISTER DE IS WELL- HERE IN THE
WEEK TO COME ALONG WITH SENATOR
WIENER. SO WE HAVE TO EIGHTY.
MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY CENTER
WINNER MR NOW CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE MOTION IN CALL OF A-
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING. SENATOR MCGUIRE AYE
MCGUIRE AYE SENATOR NIELSEN.
NIELSEN HIS SENATOR DORADO.
DRAWS FIVE SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SENATOR WIENER WIENER HI. FOR
DESSERT ALL RIGHT LAYS IN
GERMAN IT IS SAID THAT BILL IS
GOING TO BE PUT. ON CALL FILL
OUT A QUESTION YES PLEASE WHERE
IS THE MAJORITY LEADER THAT IS
A GREAT QUESTION ACTUALLY I WAS
GONNA ASK YOU THAT- CENTER
WIENER DO YOU KNOW. MY TRACKER
THAT I PUT ON THEM AS A PARENT
FAILED FAMILY NOR IS THIS A
VICE SHARING THE WORD OF THE
MAJORITY LEADER. NOT SEEING IT
TODAY ALL RIGHT SEE THERE WE GO
IT'S A IT'S A MYSTERY IT'S A
MYSTERY. THIS IS LIKE A DOUBLE
RICARDO R&B THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
HIS CONSTITUENT OF I'M NOT
MISTAKEN RIGHT I KNOW YOU'RE
NOT WE OVERLAP A LITTLE BIT-
YOU'RE A LITTLE BIT YOU KNOW.
OKAY ALTHOUGH HE WOULD PROBABLY
ARGUE THAT EVER LIVED ANALYSIS
CONSTITUENTS. THERE YOU GO. HI
DAY ON. ALL RIGHT WE DO HERE WE
GO TO LAYS IN GERMAN PRESENTING
ON BEHALF OF SIMILAR BERMAN
AND- SIMMER GABRIEL'S OFFER
DOUBLE HEADER AB TWELVE
NINETEEN THE FLOOR IS YOURS OR
YOU DO HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
WE'RE GONNA ASK FOR A TRUNCATED
VERSION OF THE STATEMENT PLEASE
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR HAVING A VERY DIFFERENT
DIRECTION HERE. THIS AS
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION
CONTINUES TO GROW WE NEED MORE
AREAS FOR PUBLIC RECREATION AB
TWELVE NINETEEN WOULD REINSTATE
THE VOLUNTARY NATURAL HERITAGE
PRESERVATION TAX CREDIT PROGRAM
WHICH WOULD SAVE LIMITED
FINANCIAL RESOURCES. AND THIS.
PROGRAM SUNSET LAST YEAR AND
THIS PROGRAM AS A TOOL TO SAVE
STATE AND LOCAL MONEY AND
PROVIDE MORE VALUE FOR EACH
DONDE BONTA DOLLAR SPENT. IN
THE LAW REQUIRES THAT THE
GENERAL FUND BE REIMBURSED FOR
THE COST OF THE TAX CREDIT. THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THIS WOULD ALLOW
LIMITED LAND ACQUISITION
RESOURCES TO BE STRETCHED
FURTHER THANK YOU AND WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THE PROGRAM OF THE BILL
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE FLOOR OF THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IS PRESENT ON BEHALF OF
MR BERMAN NAV. WE'RE GOING TO
NOW TURN TO ELIZABETH FORSBERG
I MISS FORSBERG FROM THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY WE HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT ON THE FLOOR- SO WE'RE
GOING TO ASK FOR A TRUNCATED
VERSION OF YOUR STATEMENT-
LIVES WITH THE FLOOR. IS YOURS
REPRESENT THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY. GREAT THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN. LIST BURKE ON THE
THIRTY DIRECTOR OF QUALITY THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY. WE ARE
SPONSORING AB TWELVE NINETEEN.
THOUSAND FOR NATIONAL HERITAGE
PRESERVATION TAX CREDIT PROGRAM
ALONG WITH THE STATE OR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OR QUALIFIED
NONPROFIT SUPPLIER CONSERVATION
LAND AT JUST OVER HALF OF THE
APPRAISED VALUE. BY STRUCTURING
ACQUISITIONS WITH THE LANDOWNER
CAN WITHIN A STATE TAX CREDIT.
PROGRAM PROVIDES IMPORTANT
PUBLIC BENEFITS AND REDUCE
COSTS TO THE STATE. FOURTEEN
STATES ACROSS THE COUNTRY HAVE
BEEN MORE TAX CREDIT PROGRAM.
UNDER ALL THE PROGRAMS TAX
CREDITS PROVIDED YOU DON'T HAVE
A PLAN TO THE STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. OR. NONPROFIT FOR
CONSERVATION PURPOSES. ALL OVER
THE PAST COUPLE. THE MET HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO PROTECT MILLIONS
OF ACRES OF HOW. AGRICULTURE
LAND A LOWER COST. THAN WHAT
THE CHOIR HAD WOULD HAVE BEEN
REQUIRED TO HAVE THE- STATE
PURCHASED SOME LAND A COUPLE
CREATES VALUE. TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM WAS INITIALLY
IMPLEMENTED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
ONE IN CALIFORNIA AND HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY RESULTED IN FIFTY
FOUR AND A HALF MILLION DOLLARS
IN TAX CREDIT. WHAT ABOUT
MYSELF ACRES OF CREDIT PART
PLAN OPENED AND ABOUT HABITS.
HELPING RULES FOR ELIGIBLE- OUR
COMPANY BUT WHILE THAT. BOARD
OVERSEES THE PROGRAM AND
REQUIRES HIM TO CLEAN UP
DONATION BEFORE THE PROGRAM
FIVE CONTRIBUTION HERE YEAH THE
PROGRAM ALSO REQUIRED TO TALK
THE FUNDS TO REIMBURSE THE
STATE BECAUSE OF THE. ISSUE TAX
CREDIT- NOW MORE THAN EVER WE
NEED MORE AREAS OF RECREATION
WE ALSO NEED HELP BY UNDER.
INTO AND THE CAN BE MORE TO THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE AB
TWELVE NINETEEN WILL ENSURE
COMPANY CONTINUES TO HAVE AN
IMPORTANT TOOL FOR CONFIRMATION
THAT THE INTERSTATE MONEY BY
CHARGING EACH STOCKS THAT. WE
THINK THAT THE ONLY NUMBER
BERMAN FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON
THE ISSUE I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH HAVE A GREAT. VERY
GREAT. MY GOODNESS. THIS
HAPPENED A CENTER ALSO.
REPORTER. RICARDO LARA. THANK
YOU MR VICE CHAIR EXACTLY.
THAT'S HOW HE'S OFTEN GREETED
IN THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY. HEY
THERE YOU GO. WE'RE GOING TO
CREATE A NATIONAL A VETERINARY
DOCTOR HERTZBERG AWARD CENTER
DON'T WORRY I JUST VOTED FOR
YOU CAN TIME MEETINGS. DEAR
LORD- IT ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH ELIZABETH WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
TODAY. WE ARE NOW GOING TO BE
CHECKING IN WITH THOSE WHO ARE
IN SUPPORT IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE WE DO NOT HAVE A
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSED. HERE
IN COMMITTEE- BUT WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYONE STANDING IN SUPPORT
OF ROOM IN HERE ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE AND WE'RE NOT GONNA
GET ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
NOTHING'S GOING ON ROUTE TWENTY
FORTY WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO
OUR TELECONFERENCE LINE THAT
WE'RE GONNA CHECK IN WITH
MATTER MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE NINETEEN
NOW. HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE NINETEEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AND WE WILL GO
TO THE LINE OF. ONE SEVENTY
SIX. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU MAKE THE
ONCE AGAIN THE PASSWORD THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF LAND
TRUSTS AND LOCAL OPEN SPACE
TRUST COAST AND STRUGGLING TO
BE TWELVE NINETEEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH MARKET
OFFICIATED AT LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. WHEN WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYMORE IN Q. ALL RIGHT
AND A MODERATOR WE'RE GOING TO
COME BACK TO YOU HERE SHORTLY
THAT'S AND SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME- IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE TO AB TWELVE NINETEEN IF
YOU COULD PLEASE STAND. SEEN NO
ONE WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO
OUR OVERFLOW ROOM ROOM TWENTY
FORTY SEEN KNOWN AND WE'RE NOW
GOING TO GO BACK TO MEMORY
MEMORY- ONE LAST TIME- IT'S
BEEN A PLEASURE TO WORK WITH
YOU TODAY. LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWELVE NINETEEN CAN YOU PLEASE
QUEUE THEM UP NOW. CERTAINLY IF
YOU'RE OPPOSITION OF AB TWELVE
NINETEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. OPPOSITION AB.
TWELVE NINETEEN. CAN WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYBODY QUEUING UP HAVE A
GREAT FOR THE JULY WEEKEND AT
MADAME MODERATOR VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH YOU TO
DO IT THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU ALL RIGHT NOW
WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE AND I CHECK INTO WE
HAVE QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
MOTION ON THE FLOOR. WE HAVE A
MOTION MY CENTER WIENER MOTION
MY CENTER WIENER NAY B. TWELVE
NINETEEN. FINAL CALL FOR
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. C. NINE IS
A MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. ALL RIGHT IN MOTION ON
THE FLOOR AT BY A CENTER
WIENER. MR NOW CAN YOU PLEASE.
CALL THE MOTION AND THE CALL
THE VOTE. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR MCGUIRE HI. MCGUIRE HIS
SENATOR NIELSEN. ALL RIGHT
NIELSEN AYE SENATOR DRAWS SO.
TORONTO HIS SENATOR HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE AYES SENATOR
WIENER. WIENER HI. HOW MANY
VOTES IS THAT CAUGHT. FIVE ZERO
FIVE WOW THAT'S AMAZING I
THOUGHT THERE IS FOR FOLKS OF
HIS COMMITTEE HOME. ALL RIGHT
THERE YOU GO OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH AS A MEMBER HAVE A
WONDERFUL WEEKEND THANK YOU
HAPPY FOR THE DRIVER THANK YOU
SO MUCH- DURAZO WE DO THIS WE
CAN EVEN GET. ALL RIGHT
HOPEFULLY NOT A DODGERS GAME.
OKAY. FIVE IF HE IF HE WAS
PULLED YES THANK YOU SO MUCH
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA ASK THE
VICE YOU'RE VICE YOU'RE ANY
GOOD PLANS FOR THE FOURTH OF
JULY WEEKEND MISTER VICE CHAIR.
MISTER NIELSEN. YES I'M GOING
TO SIT ON THE RIVER AND WATCH
THE FIREWORKS ACROSS THE RIVER
HERE WE GO I LOVE IT. RIGHT OUT
THERE WITH. ST VERY VERY VERY
CAREFUL ABOUT THAT ALL RIGHT I
LIKE IT THANK YOU SO MUCH- VERY
VERY GRATEFUL EVERYBODY ALL
RIGHT LET'S DO SOME QUICK
HOUSEKEEPING BUT WE'RE GOING TO
NEED TO ASK SENATOR WIENER ON
ITEM SIX SEVEN AND EIGHT WE'RE
GONNA NEED SENATOR HERTZBERG ON
ALL BILLS WITH THE EXCEPTION
OF. THIRTEEN MISTER VICE CHAIR
IN MISTER ROGERS WOULD HAVE A
WONDERFUL WEEKEND THANK YOU-
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER VICE
CHAIR MISTER OZ SO IS GOOD TO
GO THANK YOU AND HAPPY FOURTH
TORONTO. THANK YOU. HAVE YOU
FOR THE LINES NO SIMPLE THANK
YOU SO MUCH ALL RIGHT SO
THAT'S- JUMP IN HERE THAT START.
FOR A START WITH SIX SEVEN AND
EIGHT CELLS ARE WE CAN GET THE
HECK OUT. ALL RIGHT SO WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE TO ITEM SIX ITEM
SIX THIS IS- EIGHTY FIVE
SEVENTY ONE CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE ZERO. MR CANAL PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS SENATOR
HERTZBERG. I SENATOR WIENER
WIENER HI FIVE HERE THAT BILLS
THAT WERE CLOSE THE ROLE WE'RE
NOT GONNA MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN EIGHTY SIX OF TWO
KERN VOTE IS THREE ZERO MR NOW
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. SENATOR HERTZBERG TAKE
IMMENSE. TAKE EVERYONE TO THE
MANTIS THINKING RIGHT HERTZBERG
HI A SENATOR WIENER. WIENER I
FIVE ZERO VOTE THE BILLS THAT
WERE CLOSING THE ROLE LAST ONE
FOUR MISTER WINNER IS GOING TO
BE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT EIGHTY
SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR CURRENT VOTE
IS THREE ZERO. MR NOW. SENATOR
HERTZBERG AYE AYES SENATOR
WIENER. WIENER ON FIVE ZERO
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
WIENER. NICE WORK TODAY MILLION
THANK YOU HAVE A WONDERFUL
HOLIDAY. ADVISOR VOTE THAT BILL
IS OUR CLOTHES IN THE ROOM.
WE'RE GONNA PASS FOR THIRTY
SECONDS. ALL RIGHT TO OTHERS IN
GERMAN THE TO GET WERE IN THE
HOME STRETCH YOUR GUARANTEE- WE
ARE NOW GOING TO BE GOING ON
TOUR CONTINUE COUNTER CONTINUE
COUNTERS ITEM NUMBER TWO ITEM
NUMBER FOUR CURRENT VOTE IS
FOUR ZERO MR CONNEL. SENATOR
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI FIVE
ZERO BUT THE BILL THOSE BILLS
ARE OUT IN WE'RE GONNA CLOSE
THE ROLE LAYS IN GERMAN
COMMITTEE WERE NOW MOVING ON
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB THREE THREE
NINE CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR ZERO
MISTER NOW SENATOR HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG FIVE FIVE ZERO VOTE
THAT DEAL IS THAT WERE CLOSED
THE ROLE ITEM NUMBER THREE
EIGHTY THREE SIX ONE KERN VOTE
IS FOUR ZERO MISTER PER NOW
SENATOR HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG
FIVE ZERO VOTE THAT BILL IS
AFTER CLOSING THE ROLE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE EIGHTY FOUR TO
EIGHT CURRENT VOTE IS THREE ONE
MISTER NOW SENATOR HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG I FOR ONE VOTE THAT
FOR ONE VOTE THE BILL IS OUR
CLOSE THE ROLE I DON'T NUMBER
NINETY EITHER THREE CURRENT
VOTE IS FOUR ZERO MISTER NOW
SENATOR HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
FIVE FIVE ZERO VOTE THAT BILL
IS OUT RECALLSTHE ROLE ITEM
NUMBER TEN EIGHTY EIGHT FIFTY
FOUR ZERO VOTE MR NOW SENATOR
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG HIGH FIVE
ZERO VOTE THAT BILL IS OUR
CLOTHES IN THE ROLE. ITEM
NUMBER. ELEVEN IT WHICH IS A
NINE FOR NINE AND A CURRENT
VOTE IS FOR ZERO NOW SENATOR
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG HI THAT
DEAL IS OUT FIVE ZERO CLOSING
THE ROLE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE I
AB NINES I WITH THE MEN'S YES
SIR ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THAT. I'M AB NINE
EIGHT NINE CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR
EIGHT ZERO ON THE SERVER NOW
SENATOR HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG
AYE FIVE ZERO VOTE THAT BILL IS
OUT FOR CLOSING THE ROLE I WANT
TO MAKE NOTE THAT. FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN IS A FIVE ZERO VOTE
THE BILL IS THAT WERE CLOSE IN
THE ROLE- AND THEN FINALLY FIND
AB FORTINO ONE FILE ITEM
FOURTEEN CURRENT VOTE IS FOR A
ZERO MISTER PATEL. CENTER
HERTZBERG. I WAS IMMENSE THANK
YOU SIRALL RIGHT HERTZBERG
FIVE FIVE EIGHT ZERO VOTE THAT
BILL IS OUT WE'RE CLOSING THE
ROLE AND SO ONCE WE TALKED
ABOUT SO- THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE
MAJORITY LEADER OF A WONDERFUL
FOURTH OF JULY TO THE ENTIRE
GOVERNMENT FIGHTING THANK YOU
TO EACH AND EVERYONE WHO ARE
STILL HERE. THANK YOU HAVE A
GREAT FOR THE JULY IN WE'LL SEE
IT NEXT WEEK NEXT. THURSDAY
THIS MEANS THAT YOUR.